donne un avis favorable notre objectif
est très clair c'est la clarté du débat
nous pensons qu'il est normal que le
Sénat puisse voter sur ce texte nous
pensons qu'il est normal que les groupes
politiques et sénateurs puissent dire
leur position parce que c'est aussi une
question de clarté et de transparence
pour les Français
pas qu'il était le temps du débat dans
le temps
du débit un petit peu
forcé aujourd'hui par votre par votre
article 44-3 et surtout est-ce que ça
veut dire que le président a fermé la
porte au syndicat la portée Claude
finalement des idées alors qu'on me
faisait qu'elle soit toujours ouverte
Vous avez un temps de concertation avec
les organisations syndicales les
organisations patronales de la durée
quatre mois il a été riche puisque sur
la question des retraites progressives
sur la question de l'emploi des seniors
sur la question des carrières longues de
la pénibilité ou du minimum de pension
nous avons amélioré notre texte nous
avons enrichie nous avons tenu compte de
beaucoup des demandes des partenaires
sociaux qu'ils soient organisations
syndicale ou organisation patronales
cette concertation évidemment n'a pas
permis de lever tous les désaccords
notamment sur la question de l'âge mais
elle a permis d'avancer après ce long
temps de concertation qui vient après 4
ans de débat public sur la question des
retraites nous sommes dans un temps
parlementaire l'assemblée a été empêchée
par la France insoumise par les groupes
de gauche d'aller au terme de ce débat
et le Sénat aurait pu l'être aussi et
donc nous sommes dans ce temps
parlementaire ça n'empêche pas de
continuer à discuter ça n'empêche pas de
continuer à parler la première mise l'a
dit le mystère de travail et donc
moi-même comme une issus travail semble
toujours ouvert à la discussion au
dialogue et aux rencontres et chacun est
dans son rôle chacun est dans sa
fonction le débat parlementaire n'est
pas terminé nous avons jusqu'à dimanche
soir encore plus de 30 heures de débats
30 heures qui vont permettre à tous les
sénateurs qui le souhaitent devenir dire
leurs amendements quels sont les
positions qui le défendent quels sont
les amendements qu'ils veulent voir
intégrer le texte et ensuite il y aura
une réunion de la commission mixte
paritaire et celle-ci va travailler il
s'agit de cette députés de cette
sénateur et je l'espère trouver un
accord s'il y a un accord l'Assemblée et
le Sénat auront à se prononcer sur le
texte de la commission mixte paritaire
et s'il n'y en avait pas il aura une
nouvelle série de discussions
parlementaires donc le débat n'est pas
terminé et on ne peut pas dire que le
débat parlementaire est empêché quand on
a déjà passé 74 heures dans cette
hémicycle pour en discuter et je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure ce n'est pas la
première fois que le Sénat est appelé à
se prononcer par un vote unique c'est
arrivé en 2013 sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande alors même le
gouvernement de François Hollande avait
majorité au Sénat au bout de 18h de
débats sur la loi de sécurisation
professionnelle ou l'article 44-3 avait
été évoqué pour permettre et demander au
Sénat à votre unique donc il n'y a pas
de de brimade il n'y a pas de limite
posée au débat parlementaire nous sommes
dans le respect des procédures le
respect de la Constitution il y a
vraiment avec une volonté très très
claire qui est de permettre une clarté
dans l'expression des forces politiques
l'expression ici des sénateurs demain
des députés sur ce texte est un texte
important
le président le Président le
gouvernement gouverne ce qui a été
rappelé il a répondu ce matin nos
organisations syndicales en rappelant
l'importance qu'avec la concertation
l'importance aussi de son attention au
sujet qui était porté tout comme ce sont
les temps sur la mobilisation
en moyenne est-ce que ça vous paraît
normal il y a un principe de séparation
des pouvoirs qui fait que la retraite
des parlementaires et des idées pour les
députés par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale pour les sénataires par le
Bureau du Sénat je suis membre du
gouvernement respectueux de la
séparation du pouvoir donc je vous
invite à vous rapprocher du Sénat
sur la santé nationale est-ce que vous
pensez là on les compte sont très très
justes pour avoir un vote à la majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale est un 49.3 est
envisagée
sur ce texte majorité au scénario une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale on
travaillons nous avons entendu un
certain nombre de propositions de
l'opposition évidemment nous avons
entendu des propositions du groupe
républicain c'est ce que nous avons fait
ici avec une meilleure prise en compte
des trimestres à qui au titre de
l'accueil d'un enfant qui soit la
maternité ou l'adoption c'est le
principe de la surcotte vous entendons
des demandes sur les transitions
notamment sur les questions de retraite
progressive de transition pour l'emploi
des Sénats le Sénat a voté contre la vie
du gouvernement d'ailleurs un CDI
seniors
il faut que nous puissions continuer à
parler à l'Assemblée nous avons aussi
entendu un certain nombre de demandes et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
scénariote nous sommes prêts nous allons
nous allons créer des apporter des
modifications dispositif de carrière
longue pour prendre en compte ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler avant 21 ans
et donc nous allons continuer à avancer
à construire étape par étape avec
toujours une volonté très claire celle
d'avoir une majorité sur le texte
nous souhaitons avoir une majorité nous
souhaitons construire cette majorité et
continuer à convaincre merci à tous
monsieur ministre
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
alors que le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer ce matin l'utilisation de
l'article 44-3 de la Constitution pour
en quelque sorte passer en force sur
cette réforme des retraites qui examinée
au Sénat il y aura et bien seulement un
vote sur l'ensemble de la réforme des
retraites avec des amendements qui sont
sélectionnés par le gouvernement et dans
quelques instants et bien le président
du groupe LR au Sénat Bruno Retailleau
va également tenir sa conférence de
presse on va l'écouter
pas du tout l'application de l'article
44-3 du vote unique c'est la conséquence
de l'application de la constitution de
la 5ème République et il a sans doute
oublié que à l'époque la gauche sous
François Hollande dans son quinquennat
ici au Sénat avait utilisé à 9 reprises
ce vote bloqué nous on veut aller au
fond et on va aller au bout pour voter
et la gauche est mauvaise expérience
perdante puisque il sent bien qu'ils
sont en minorité évidemment sur ce texte
donc ils veulent à tout prix nous
empêcher empêcher la majorité de voter
ça c'est pas la démocratie ça on peut
pas tolérer avec une obstruction que je
n'ai jamais vu depuis 20 ans au Sénat
ils ont créé une sorte
d'industrialisation de l'obstruction
mais on peut pas vis-à-vis d’une
majorité que nous représentons se faire
prendre en otage par une minorité ça
c'est pas la démocratie vous voyez nous
on va aller au fond et on veut discuter
vous rendez compte été souligné 440 neuf
demande de rapport qui ont été déposés
des amendements des amendements et à
chaque fois un amant seulement de sous
amendement c'est-à-dire que on aurait pu
ajouter 10 jours 15 jours à chaque fois
il y aurait eu la machine à sous-amander
des amendements totalement ridicules qui
ne sont pas des amendements des
sous-amendements au fond c'est ça
l'obstruction bien contre l'obstruction
il y a le règlement du Sénat mais qui
n'y suffit pas il y a aussi des articles
de la Constitution on est sous la
Cinquième République passe sous la
Quatrième République ici au Sénat c'est
pas la rue qui fait la loi la loi c'est
la démocratie représentative il y a le
droit de grève on a le droit de
manifester dans le calme bien sûr
pacifiquement je le reconnais
complètement mais ici notre job c'est
pas selon de parler à l'infini notre job
c'est de voter mais après ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée est-ce que ce vote
bloqué ça fragilise pas la réforme sa
légitimité non on est déjà l'article on
a fait passer des marqueurs qui sont
pour nous très très importants et en
réalité il reste quelques articles
puisque sur les 20 articles de la
réforme la réforme tient en très
articles les derniers articles ce sont
des articles techniques que vous
retrouvez dans les lois de finances des
tableaux d'équilibre qui n'ont rien à
voir avec eux l'essentiel le cœur de la
réforme donc je pense que on peut
continuer à aller au bout de ce texte il
le faut impérativement en discutant du
fond ça sert à rien de discuter des sous
amendements qui par dizaines par
centaines sont déposées et qui leur
vient dire on déplace d'un jour un
rapport qu'il faut déposer à tel moment
etc etc nous on va aller au fond on veut
débattre par exemple de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants tous ceux
qui ont des enfants handicapés chez eux
des parents ils sont des aidants il y en
a 4 millions en France avec
l'obstruction de la gauche on n'y arrive
pas on y arrive pas nous on veut
vraiment discuter de chaque article
utile de la loi pour améliorer la loi
pour améliorer
plusieurs amendements qui vous tenez à
coeur qui restait encore à être débattu
est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui la
certitude que ils font partie des
amendements retenus par le gouvernement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
lesquels ont été retenues de tête très
franchement il y a eu une longue
énumération des ministres vous allez me
permettre quand même de les étudier les
plus importants on en a fait beaucoup
passer on a fait passer le CDI senior on
a fait passer ce que j'ai toujours
appelé la vraie ligne rouge c'est nous
qui avons porté et non pas l'Assemblée
nationale et non pas la gauche ici
l'injustice fait au maire de famille qui
était les vrais perdante de cette
réforme c'est nous la gauche araillé
évidemment cette droite ses droits
tringarde qui voulait parler pour les
maires de famille résultat notre
amendement il a passé hier sans aucune
voix contre sans aucune voix contre je
m'en réjouis il y a d'autres amendements
j'espère bien qu'on va les faire passer
notamment sur la pénibilité sur l'usure
professionnelle et celui sur la fin et
sur la sur les régimes spéciaux voilà
l'obstruction de la gauche il nous avait
sur cette sur ce sous amendement qui
était le mien accroché 250 sous
amendements pour faire en sorte
d'embourber totalement le débat je sais
très bien depuis le départ que c'est
amendement le gouvernement n'en voulait
pas et c'est bien dommage
gouvernement j'imagine qu'il n'aura pas
été retenu encore une fois j'ai pas
vraiment vérifié les numéros
d'amendement qui ont été appelés puisque
ça s'est pas passé par nature par nom de
l'amendement mais par numéro
régimes et chaud donc mais vous décidez
de ne pas toucher à votre propre régime
autonome pourquoi demander aux Français
de faire des efforts alors que vous vous
décidez pas en faire mais c'est faux
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire ça
gérarchie cet engagé à traduire un
certain nombre de règles dans notre
propre régime autonome qui n'est pas un
régime spécial d'ailleurs puisque si
c'est un régime spécial on aurait des
règles par exemple de départ d'âge légal
différent et on aurait des subventions
massives de l'État simplement c'est une
caisse autonome et on a décidé de
cotiser de surcotiser à hauteur de 20%
les députés c'est par exemple 14% donc
on va s'appliquer aussi ses règles il
est très difficile de savoir comment
sont cal lés
c'est parfaitement transparent c'est
l'argent c'est la cotisation des
sénateurs c'est la cotisation des
sénateurs voilà c'est la cotisation des
sénateurs on cotise à hauteur de 20%
c'est la cotisation uniquement de
l'employeur
c'est à mes collègues députés qu'il faut
le demander j'ai utilisé ce matin une
métaphore pour la première ministre en
disant soit c'est la roulette russe
c'est-à-dire il y a pas de 49-3 elle
essaie de faire en sorte que elle a une
majorité auquel cas elle fait ce Paris
ça peut être un pari bien calculé mais
aujourd'hui ça ressemble un peu à la
route à la roulette russe soit c'est le
49-3 c'est à dire la Grosse Bertha et
aujourd'hui moi je ne sais pas dire je
suis sénateur je suis président d'un
groupe au Sénat et je ne sais pas dire
qu'elle peut-être demain une majorité
pour ce texte là-bas à l'Assemblée
nationale
où on a du mal à suivre la ligne de
votre partie aujourd'hui vous vous
faites tout pour voter cette loi eux
nous explique qu'ils n'auront pas les
voies suffisantes pour donner la
majorité au gouvernement les députés de
votre partie on a un peu du mal à suivre
la ligne de votre de votre partie
aujourd'hui du parti elle très clair
Eric Ciotti Olivier Marleix et moi-même
nous l'avons exprimé à plusieurs
reprises il y a 61 députés est-ce qu'il
y aura l'abstention ou le con de 15 ou
de 20 j'observe que le gros de l'équipe
de leger Marleix votre apourse cette
réforme est-ce que ça suffira moi je ne
sais pas je peux pas faire des comptes
d'apothicaire aujourd'hui d'ici en plus
du sénates
à 49 fois moi j'ai toujours dit ici que
on peut pas varier je pense que ce qu'il
y a beaucoup abîmé les LR c'est nos
recul nous revirements de quoi
aurions-nous l'air si nous ne votion pas
ce texte 64 ans alors que depuis des
années on soutient en 65 ans il faut
améliorer le texte les députés l'ont
fait nous l'avons fait collectivement
sur les petites pensions sur les
carrières longues nous faisons aussi par
exemple sur les maires de famille je
pense que la politique même quand c'est
pas populaire c'est dire la vérité aux
Français et la vérité française c'est
que on a un choc démographique
précédent c'est plus le baby-boom c'est
le papy boom c'est à dire qu'on va
multiplier par 4 par 5 le nombre de
françaises de Français qui vont entrer
dans la période de la retraite comment
fait-on pour financer tout ça comment
fait-on si on accepte pas de travailler
un peu plus et bien on fait exploser le
régime par répartition et je voudrais
simplement dire que en 2030 quand c'est
très fort s'appliquera nous serons le
pays d'Europe où on partira le plus tôt
en retraite nous serons le pays d'Europe
où nous aurons le meilleur régime de
carrière longue de toute l'Europe voilà
merci
et voilà pour cette conférence de presse
du président du groupe les républicains
au Sénat Bruno Retailleau qui a justifié
en quelque sorte l'utilisation par le
gouvernement de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution pour accélérer
considérablement les débats au Sénat sur
la réforme des retraites passer en force
il y aura seulement un vote unique sur
l'ensemble du texte avec des amendements
sélectionnés par le gouvernement et
justement pour en parler j'accueille sur
ce plateau Franck Riester bonjour je
vous souhaite le ministre en charge des
relations avec le Parlement la gauche
sénatoriale on l'a entendu ce matin à
dénonce un coup de force historique
contre le Parlement avec l'utilisation
de ce 44 3 sur cette réforme des
retraites qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez non c'est pas du tout un coup
de force on a entendu effectivement des
mots comme coup de force coup d'État qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce qui se passe
ce qui se passe c'est que le
gouvernement souhaite la clarté des
débats souhaite éviter l'obstruction et
utilise une disposition de la
Constitution française qui est notre
règle la plus notre règle suprême en
matière de droit pour veiller à ce que
ils puissent y avoir le temps d'aller au
fond des débats et cet article 44-3 a
déjà été utilisé dans le passé encore il
y a pas si longtemps sur le quinquennat
de François Hollande ici au Sénat c'est
ce vote unique qui permet à être au
députés et au sénateur de l'opposition
pardon de pouvoir présenter leurs
amendements simplement on fera qu'un
seul vote sur le texte tel qu'il est
voté discuter voté jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ensuite tel qu'il est prévu par le
gouvernement plus les amendements pour
lequel pour lesquels le Gouvernement
émet un avis favorable il y aura un vote
à la fin donc de cette discussion où ça
laissera évidemment tout le temps au
sénateur de s'exprimer de proposer de
défendre et éventuellement de critiquer
les dispositions de cette texte de loi
finale les cinteurs de gauche ne vont
faire que présenter leurs amendements il
n'y aura pas de vote sur ces amendements
de la gauche finalement qu'un vote final
sur des amendements sélectionnés triez
sur le volet par le gouvernement est-ce
que votre utilisation du 24-3 c'est pas
un échec démocratique non l'échec
démocratique c'est l'obstruction alors
que ça fait plus de 70 heures je crois
74 heures de débats ici au Sénat qui
nous reste encore 30 heures il y a une
série de susamment en permanence qui
sont déposés par les sénateurs de
l'opposition pour n'ont pas aller au
fond des textes du texte mais ralentir
les débats et ne pas permettre la clarté
justement de ces débats quand on dépose
70 amendements de suppression d'un
article alors que un groupe politique
peut en faire un expliquer pourquoi il
souhaite que cet article soit supprimé
pas obligé d'en faire 70 quand il y a
toute une série d'amendements sur le
même sujet en simplement aux gens la
date pour par exemple une remise de
rapport qui fait des dizaines des
centres et voir parfois des centaines
d'amendements tout ça est de
l'obstruction c'est une technique
d'obstruction avérée et le gouvernement
veut éviter cette obstruction pour
permettre le débat justement et c'est ce
que donc nous faisons avec l'utilisation
de cet article 44-3 pour un
Franck Esther on va se projeter un peu
sur la suite de l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites il devrait donc
avec ce 44 3 avoir un vote de la
majorité de droite et du centre pour
cette réforme des retraites ensuite il y
aura ce qu'on appelle la commission
mixte paritaire c'est à dire une réunion
dans une salle entre 7 députés cette
sénateurs pour trouver une version
commune de cette réforme vous pensez que
cette commission mixte paritaire peut
aboutir un accord je le pense je
l'espère et ensuite une fois que il y a
cet accord sur ce texte il y a le vote
des conclusions de la CMP conclusive qui
doit avoir lieu jeudi matin si la CMP
qui devrait se tenir mercredi et
conclusive jeudi matin au Sénat et je
dis après midi à l'Assemblée nationale
mais effectivement petite précision de
procédure parlementaire c'est le Sénat
qui examinerait en premier justement
cette version commune de la réforme des
retraites c'est assez inédit notamment
pour un texte budgétaire est-ce que ça
veut dire que vous voulez utiliser et
bien finalement le vote de la droite
sénatoriale pour convaincre réputé LR
qui serait encore récalcitrant
concernant cette réforme pour avoir une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et
éviter un 49-3 non simplement que vous
avez besoin de temps à l'Assemblée
nationale pour finir les discussions du
projet de loi nucléaire jeudi matin et
c'est pour ça qu'on a décalé à jeudi
après-midi la discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale classification technique juste
une dernière question est-ce que vous
craignez l'utilisation d'être obligé
d'utiliser un 49,3 l'Assemblée nationale
sans majorité nous voulons avoir un vote
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est pour ça que nous avons écouté les
oppositions écouter les organisations
syndicales modifier notre notre texte
nous sommes toujours et encore à
l'écoute et nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
au-delà de la majorité présidentielle
majorité plus large pour voter cette
réforme essentielle qui permet de sauver
notre système de retraite par
répartition parce que la droite a
toujours défendu et vous pensez la voir
à ce moment où on se parle cette
majorité plus large nous travaillons et
nous continuons d'y travailler merci
beaucoup merci Esther d'être venu sur le
plateau de Public Sénat on conclure
cette émission spéciale en rejoignant
Quentin Calmet dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle Quentin racontez-nous un
petit peu les temps forts de cette
matinée très particulière dans ce débat
sur la réforme des retraites au Sénat
oui on avait vu le temps monter depuis
plusieurs jours depuis mardi entre la
droite et la gauche sénatoriale ça y est
ça a atteint son point culminant
aujourd'hui lors de cette séance après
que le ministre du Travail a déclenché
l'article les 44-3 de la Constitution
c'était à 11h34 et Olivier du stop t'a
demandé est-ce qu'il y ait ce vote
bloqué ce vote unique sur l'ensemble de
la réforme des retraites ainsi tous les
amendements qui ne sont pas retenus par
le gouvernement sont démonétisés ils ne
seront pas intégrés à la version finale
sur lesquelles les sénateurs vont voter
à la fin de cette examen du texte et le
gouvernement qui a annoncé qu'il
retenait au stade 70 amendements
uniquement qui pourront être ajoutés à
la réforme des retraites à partir de là
on a vu une levée de bouclier une Bronka
sur les bras de sur les bandes de la
gauche la gauche qui dénonce ce coup de
force ce passage en force à l'image de
ce qu'a dit et bien le chef de fil des
écologistes Guillaume Gontard a écouté
le
des syndicats Unis demande sonnaiement
être reçue par le Président de la
République il leur refuse toujours
d'ouvrir la porte et de et de continuer
des discussions
l'ensemble de la population et dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement voilà des phrases qui ont
été marquantes des phrases très dures
venus de la gauche sénatoriale et on a
même et bien entendu à ce moment-là des
sénateurs de droite tapé sur les
tablettes ce qui est très rare ce n'est
pas du tout l'habitude comme à
l'Assemblée nationale ici c'est très
rare qu'on assiste à ce genre de
spectacle dans la chambre haute du
parlement alors de son côté la droite
sénatoriale assume de soutenir aussi en
cette démarche du gouvernement écouté le
chef de fil des allers Bruno Retailleau
la construction c'est quand on dépose
449 demandes de rapport l'obstruction
c'est quand on multiplie des amendements
identiques des sous amendements
ridicules qui n'apportent rien des
rappels au règlement qui n'en sont pas
ça c'est de l'obstruction et
l'obstruction finalement c'est la
négation du rôle du Parlement vous
transformez le Sénat en un groupe de
parole le Parlement ne vaut bien sûr
qu'avec les débats pour éclairer la
délibération et le vote c'est notre
métier c'est notre devoir le devoir que
nous avons pris par rapport aux Français
mes chers collègues et on ne peut pas
dans une enceinte parlementaire on ne
peut pas supporter qu'une minorité
prenne en otage une majorité par le seul
fait par le seul fait que vous ne
vouliez pas
être perdant nous voulons voter voilà
Alexandre on pourra le dire il y aura un
avant et un après réforme des retraites
au Sénat il était et on n'avait jamais
avez vu un tel niveau d'énervement dans
l'histoire contemporaine récente du
Sénat prochain état à 14h la réunion de
la Conférence des présidents qui réunit
et bien tout le bureau du Sénat avec les
présidents de commission des présidents
de groupe pour faire le point sur ce qui
se joue maintenant dans les prochaines
heures Alexandre merci beaucoup Quentin
de nous avoir fait vivre ce matin c'est
débats palpitants au Sénat dans le cadre
de cet examen de la réforme des
retraites un jeu le rappelle
l'information de la matinée c'est que le
gouvernement utilise l'article 44 alinéa
3 de la Constitution pour passer en
force en quelque sorte sur cette réforme
des retraites avec un vote unique sur
l'ensemble du texte et des amendements
sélectionnés trier sur le volet par le
gouvernement voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale en direct sur Public
Sénat on devrait reprendre le direct le
dans une heure sur notre antenne pour
vous faire vivre ces échanges sur notre
antenne également sur notre site
internet public sénat.fr des débats qui
s'annonce PA lpitant cet après-midi avec
une gauche sénatoriale qui est bien vent
debout sur cette utilisation du 44 3 par
le gouvernement une utilisation qui
d'ailleurs a été justifiée par la
majorité de droite du Sénat je vous
propose de revoir le film de la matinée
qui a été préparé par Cécile even
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous débattons du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale
rectificative depuis le 2 mars dernier
dans cette émission vos travaux ont
commencé les jours précédents en
commission de très nombreuses
amendements ont été déposés examinés et
les débats ont été nourris
nous avons eu ensemble dans cette
émission 74 heures de débat sur un sujet
central celui de l'avenir de système de
retraite par répartition à chaque
article malgré des discussions de fond
malgré des avancées portées par la
commission bien sûr par plusieurs
groupes nous le regrettons mais
l'obstruction est devenue un choix
méthodique et répété des groupes
d'opposition
nous avons eu quelques illustrations pas
plus tard que ce matin je pense à la
déclaration de madame la sénatrice
brûlant qui ne vous dit très clairement
et je la remercie de cette clarté qu'à
chaque fois que nous avons nous
avancerons tous sera mis en oeuvre pour
nous ralentir je pense aux expressions
utilisées hier au sujet du dépôt des
sous amendements qui ont été présentés
comme une vie sans fin et avec la
volonté de faire en sorte que le nombre
de sous-amands déposés soit toujours
plus important pour empêcher le Sénat de
se prononcer dans la clarté sur
l'ensemble du texte et sur les
dispositions de fonds je pense aux
séries d'amendements identiques ou
analogue avec des déclinaisons de
profession avec des déclinaisons
d'institutions à concerter avec des
déclinaisons de dates lorsque les sous
amendements non comme seul objet que de
décaler d'un jour puis de deux jours
puis deux trois jours puis de 4 jours la
date de remise d'un rapport lui-même
demandé par un parlementaire d'un groupe
d'opposition cela caractérise une
obstruction méth
et une volonté de priver le Sénat de sa
capacité à délibérer et à se prononcer
dans la clarté pour dire qui soutient et
qui ne soutient pas les dispositions qui
sont proposées le choix du gouvernement
la ligne du gouvernement est la seule
qui vaille à nos yeux et celui de la
clarté des débats pour les sénateurs
comme pour les Français qui nous
regardent et qui vous regardent nous
faisons un choix clair nous avons une
volonté claire celui d'éviter de
contourner et de mettre fin à une
obstruction qui est devenue systématique
et qui n'a comme ça l'objectif je le
répète d'empêcher les sénateurs et les
sénatrices de se prononcer sur les
dispositions de ce texte et sur cette
réforme qui est majeure pour l'avenir
des Français
nous aurions pu considérer que le
calendrier parlementaire tel que prévu
par la Constitution la loi organique
serait suffisant nous considérons qu'il
est absolument essentiel que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur le fond dans la
clarté que cette clarté des positions
toute respectueuse dans l'opposition
comme dans la majorité dans le soutien
comme à l'opposition à ce texte mais que
cette clarté des débats est tout à fait
primordiale pour pouvoir ainsi avancer
et que cette réforme puisse continuer à
être discuté
c'est la raison pour laquelle mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente en application de l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat le gouvernement demande à votre
assemblée de se prononcer par un vote
unique sur l'ensemble du texte ainsi que
sur les articles 9 à 20 en retenant les
amendements et les sous-amendements
suivants je vous ferai la liste dans un
instant mais en précisant que cette
annonce ne remet pas en cause ce qui a
déjà été examiné et adopté à l'article 9
avant la suspension de semences le
gouvernement propose que soit soumis à
sevate unique les amendements pardon
pour des itérations numéro 21 33 21 34
21 41 21 36 modifié par le
sous-amendement 47 61
21 35 21 37 21 39 21 43 21 45 21 44 21
46 21 47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 à
l'article 9
pour ce qui concerne l'article l'article
10 les amendements 21-54 20 59 rectifier
terre 21 55 20 58 rectifiés 20 60
rectifié bis 21 56 21 57 21 58 21 59 et
21 60 pour ce qui concerne les
amendements portant additionnels après
l'article 10 les amendements 22 95 20 24
20 21 61 rectifié bis 45 47
475 rectifié pour les amendements on
interrompt un instant le ministre parce
que il va égrener une liste
d'amendements pendant les prochaines
minutes mais comme nous vous n'allons à
l'antenne de Public Sénat il y a
quelques minutes le gouvernement en
l'occurrence représenté par Olivier du
socle le ministre de travail qui
déclenche l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution le vote bloqué et qui est
donc en train de donner tous les
amendements qu'il souhaite voir voter
dans la réforme des
retraites puisque effectivement cet
article de la Constitution lui permet de
choisir la liste des amendements qu'il
souhaite voir examiner et donc faire
tomber tous les amendements de
l'opposition ou qu'ils ne souhaitent pas
voir examiner et voter par le Sénat
c'est donc si en train de se jouer c'est
une nouvelle étape l'étape majeure dans
l'utilisation de la Constitution ou du
Règlement du Sénat puisque c'est une
c'est une arme très contraignante on
retourne écouter le vie du socle
ou encore qui vont nous permettre de
donner suite à un vote intervenu en
première partie permettant la
modification du niveau
du niveau de l'objectif national de
dépenses en matière d'assurance maladie
autant d'amendements qui permettent
d'améliorer ce texte et qui permet de
poursuivre je tiens à préciser mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que nous
allons en ce qui concerne les articles
qui suivent notamment les tableaux
financiers avec mes excuses puisque
j'aurais dû traiter l'article 13 dans la
première série de numéros que j'ai
indiqué le gouvernement propose aussi
donc de retenir les articles les
amendements pardonnez-moi 21 66 21 67 21
69 21 70 21
73 21 71
214 21 75 21 76 21 77 ainsi que les
amendements 23 60 rectifié bis 21 78 21
79 21 80 21 82
à l'article 13 que nous proposons aussi
de retenir pour ce qui sera soumis au
vote unique les amendements très 69 et
21 83 qui portent arctique additionnelle
après l'article 13 l'amendement 25 50 25
63 pardon rectifier avant l'article 14
l'amendement 47 23 à l'article 14
l'amendement 47 24 à l'article 15 et
l'amendement 2184 à l'article 16
évidemment cette liste vaut exclusion de
tous les autres amendements y compris
des amendements portant articles
additionnels
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc en
application de l'article 44 dernier
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du règlement le
gouvernement demande au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur les
articles 9 à 20 et sur l'ensemble du
texte en ne retenant à partir de
maintenant que les amendements proposés
ou acceptés par le gouvernement sans
remettre en cause les amendements
précédemment
adoptés y compris ce adopter jusque à
cet article 9 les amendements restants
en discussion retenus par le
gouvernement viennent d'être listé par
le ministre il reçoivent donc en quelque
sorte un avis favorable
si vous me l'autorisez je ne vous
redonnerai pas la liste vous allez avoir
la distribution de cette liste dans
quelques minutes
à l'exclusion donc de tous les autres y
compris des amendements portant articles
additionnels acte et donc donner de
cette demande
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
nous avons bien entendu vos propos il
s'agit par le recours à cette procédure
d'assurer la clarté et la sincérité de
nos débats et de mettre un terme à
l'obstruction
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je finis de vous expliquer et ensuite
vous ferez des rappels aux règlements
laissez moi finir vous expliquer et nous
ferons ensuite les rappels au règlement
mais certains souhaitent avoir cette
explication
de même les prises de parole sur
articles sont possibles dans les
conditions fixées par la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents réunis le 8
mars dernier c'est à dire à raison de
deux minutes pour un orateur par groupe
à l'issue de la présentation des
amendements nous passerons aux
explications de vote et au vote unique
sur les amendements retenus et sur
l'ensemble du texte
voilà les explications mes chers
collègues je vois quelques rappels au
règlement monsieur Kanner pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur la base
de l'article 44 bis
la mèche est dite mes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
vous indiquez mes chers collègues que
voilà nous ne sommes pas étonnés
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans mon
rappel le règlement je lui ai dit
j'avais dit à Monsieur mimi mais quand
allez-vous sortir le 44 3
c'est fait c'est fait je vous rappelle
que si on en arrive là c'est parce que
bien évidemment des articles du
Règlement général du Sénat ont été
utilisés que le 47 1 de la Constitution
a été utilisée en amont par le
gouvernement et que la tactique et la
technique de l'amendement prioritaire
rectificatif a été utilisé pour faire
tomber nombre d'amendements de
l'opposition
nous vous donnons acte monsieur le
ministre et Mesdames et Messieurs et
sénateurs
et sénateur de la droite sénatoriale que
vous avez décidé donc avant la grande
journée du 11 mars
de
montrer au pays vos réels intentions que
je qualifierais et ne le voyait pas mal
de réactionnaires puisque c'est bien une
réforme réactionnaire dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui une réforme de régression
sociale il restait 1000 amendement à
examiner
il nous restait plus de 30 heures de je
crois de débats et donc nous pourrions
nous aurions pu tranquillement montrer
aux Français notre volonté
nous allons nous allons nous allons
rester je vous assure nous serons en
séance pour débattre des amendements que
vous nous tolérez monsieur le ministre
en termes d'examen mais madame la
Présidente pour nous permettre néanmoins
de prendre acte mais aussi de considérer
les conséquences d'une telle décision du
gouvernement je sollicite de votre part
et je crois que ce sera bien légitime
une suspension de séance pour permettre
aux on a trois groupes de faire le point
de la situation
monsieur le Président je vais d'abord
prendre les autres rappels aux
règlements notamment celui de Monsieur
gontin pour rappel au règlement
oui merci merci madame la Présidente sur
l'article 44 bis
quel aveu de faiblesse quel aveu de
faiblesse ouais ouais franchement
je crois que franchement je l'ai dit
beaucoup de fois ces derniers temps mais
là un terrible aveugle à votre faiblesse
oui votre majorité se fissure ce texte
n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
et on a vu on a vu les conditions
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis demandent
demande solennellement être reçue par le
Président de la République il leur
refuse toujours d'ouvrir la porte et de
et de continuer des discussions
l'ensemble de la population et dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement
alors
la majorité sénatoriale effectivement
voilà oui allez allez oui monsieur
carucci je sais que ça vous embête mais
je continuerai je continueai voilà oui
rappelle aux règlements oui on n'a pas
le droit de s'adresser quand je parle
voilà ok voilà
donc moi je demande également évidemment
évidemment une suspension de séance et
suspension de séance qui soit suffisante
parce que vous vous accordez une
suspension de séance le gouvernement
s'accorde une suspension de séance pour
pouvoir réécrire son texte on a quand
même la possibilité de pouvoir réagir et
pouvoir se réunir mais en tout cas moi
je le dis on ne pourra pas continuer à
accepter cette aléation du du Parlement
et on nous on ne sera pas le toutou du
gouvernement
monsieur le Président Laurent pour
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente nous y sommes voilà
donc le coup de force du gouvernement
que vous prépariez en fait depuis mardi
depuis les appels incessants au recours
à toutes les procédures pour mettre fin
au débat
comme l'a dit à plusieurs reprises la
présidente de notre groupe Eliane
assassy il s'agit effectivement d'un
terrible aveu de faiblesse vous qui êtes
ultra majoritaire au Sénat vous êtes
incapable de faire voter le texte dans
des conditions normales de débats et
tout cela parce que vous avez décidé
parce que vous avez décidé depuis le
premier jour non seulement de faire
voter les 64 ans mais de les faire voter
en acceptant les conditions imposées par
le gouvernement avec le recours aux 47
ans et vous vous êtes mis dans une
situation d'abaissement du Sénat de
jouer le jeu que vous imposez le
gouvernement vous vous êtes condamné au
silence pendant les premiers jours du
débat pour jouer ce jeu puis à partir de
mardi quand vous avez vu que le
mouvement populaire prenait une telle
ampleur vous avez décidé l'obstruction
c'est vous qui avez organisé
l'obstruction depuis mardi
pour finalement justifier ce coup de
force du gouvernement et vous allez donc
aller chers collègues à la CMP mercredi
alors que l'Assemblée nationale n'aura
pas voté le texte et qu'il aura été
adopté ici par au fait ce qu'il faut
bien appeler en 49-3 senatorial parce
que le vote bloqué c'est la même chose
donc vous allez aller à la CMP je vous
le dis mes chers collègues de droite ne
cautionnez pas cela parce que vous le
paierez très cher dans le pays parce que
le pays vous regarde ne cautionnez pas
la seule issue possible aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente comme vient
de le dire mon collègue Pierre Laurent
le 44 3 c'est le 49.3 du Sénat et
franchement le Sénat ne sort pas grandi
par cette nouvelle procédure le
parlementarisme est piétiné par le
gouvernement je dois le dire mais avec
la sentiment de la majorité de droites
LR
centriste et c'est triste c'est triste
pour la démocratie c'est triste pour le
peuple c'est triste pour tout celles et
tous ceux qui qui nous regardent et
franchement pourquoi vous avez fait ça
parce que depuis le début procédure sur
procédure vous avez souhaité tendre les
débats vous allez vous avez souhaité
dramatiser les débats et vous avez
refusé de parler du fond c'est à dire
des conséquences de votre projet sur la
vie des gens c'est ça la réalité et
pourquoi il y a une telle attitude des
droites avec le gouvernement c'est parce
que bon le projet du gouvernement c'est
le frère jumeau de votre projet mesdames
et messieurs de droite puisque ça fait
quatre ans c'est un C4 ans que René Paul
Savary présente le recul de l'âge de la
retraite donc vous êtes enfin soulagé de
voir cette réforme scélérate votez de
cette manière-là par des parlementaires
qui acceptent que le parlementarisme
soit piétiné c'est pas glorieux c'est
triste mais les conséquences vont être
graves parce que aujourd'hui vous
piétinez l'opposition et demain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer alors ne
mettez pas la main sur le cœur en disant
oh le Sénat c'est bien mieux que
qu'ailleurs nous nous sommes respectueux
c'est être respectueux que de bafouer
l'opposition de gauche de la baïonner
bah pour moi c'est anti-démocratique et
c'est ce que vous faites et en plus la
commission des affaires sociales a été
piétiné puisque elle n'a jamais été
réunis depuis le début et ça c'est aussi
très grave si Madame Rossignol madame la
Présidente Rossignol pour rappel aux
règlements
merci madame la Présidente pour que tout
le monde à l'extérieur qui cherche à
comprendre qui s'instruit sur la demande
du Sénat comprennent bien quel est la
conséquence de la décision du
gouvernement en accord avec la majorité
sénatoriale à partir de dorénavant nous
n'allons discuter que les amendements
retenus par le gouvernement nous serons
tout à l'heure quand on nous aurons pu
examiner la liste précise combien
d'amendements de l'opposition des
groupes de gauche ont été retenus
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y en ait
beaucoup ensuite nous allons discuter
des amendements probablement qui ont
convenu au gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale et quand on dit sura ses
amendements il y aura je le précise un
orateur pour c'est pas nous puisque on
présente pas l'amendement le rapport la
commission c'est pas nous parce que nous
ne sommes pas rapporteur et ensuite le
gouvernement ce qui revient à dire que
sur tous les amendements que vous avez
retenus qui ne viennent pas de
l'opposition nous ne pourrons pas nous
exprimer c'est ça la procédure que vous
mettez en place alors vous ne pouvez pas
dire que ce n'est pas une procédure
bâillon vous avez décidé que la gauche
devait se taire jusqu'à la fin de ce
débat et puisqu'on parle de la fin de ce
débat puisqu'on parle de la fin de ce
débat il nous devions siéger jusqu'à
dimanche soir vous avez retenu 70
amendements ça peut aller très vite
visiblement votre intention c'est ça et
très vite et nous ne sommes que vendredi
midi il y avait encore deux journées et
demi complète de travail soit 3 6 8
séances 8 séances alors vous qui voulez
faire travailler des Français deux ans
de plus vous n'êtes pas capable de
travailler trois jours de plus c'est pas
glorieux
[Applaudissements]
comme la présidente Rossignol juste de
vous indiquer que tous les amendements
qui restent jusqu'à la fin de la
discussion seront présentés vous aurez
donc à présenter les amendements pas
seulement les amants qui viennent d'être
cités les amendements qui viennent
d'être cités par le ministre ont reçu un
avis favorable mais l'ensemble des
amendements le petit millier qui reste
seront présentés je donne la parole pour
rappel au règlement au président à
Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
tout au long de ces débats on
s'attendait bien à ce que vous vous
opposiez à ce texte et on en a pas été
surpris on avait vu au compteur un
certain nombre d'amendements mais la
question qui était posée c'était de
savoir si vous vouliez que dans le temps
qui était quand même compter plus de 120
heures de débats nous puissions nous
exprimer et voter et plusieurs fois
Roger caroutchi avec calme et
pondération à appeler les débats à
progresser à avancer
c'est étonnant et se demandant s'il y
avait pas une forme d'obstruction au
fond c'est toute la question bien sûr
qui a ce texte des retraites bien sûr
que vous avez le droit de vous y opposer
nous-mêmes parfois on a des réserves sur
le calendrier sur la forme sur la
question du travail sur le sens du
travail et tout ça c'est le rôle du
Parlement mais le Parlement et c'est
même j'irai dire quelque chose qui
dépasse la réforme des retraites le
Parlement la démocratie représentative
elle doit parler débattre mais aussi
s'exprimer et c'est ça qui fait notre
clivage on n'est pas très heureux de
devoir utiliser une procédure comme
celle là mais pourquoi on fait ça
pourquoi on fait ça
on a parlé de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quelquefois quelquefois je dis qui rôde
mais c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire
c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire c'est
pas ça que je vais vous dire au moins
lui il y a une différence avec vous
c'est qu'il a l'obstruction glorieuse et
vous vous avez l'obstruction honteuse et
c'est ça mes chers collègues qui depuis
le début est une forme d'hypocrisie vous
ne voulez pas vous exprimer mais vous
vous camouflez derrière des arguments de
procédure et cette obstruction honteuse
elle vous grandit pas et nous on veut
aller au bout de ce de ce texte pour le
Sénat pour la démocratie représentative
je vous remercie madame pense et mange
pour rappel au règlement madame
pansement pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente qu'est-ce qui
se joue avec ce 44.3 c'est que le
gouvernement la droite devient
e-libéral il libéral vous devenez
autoritaire et pourquoi bah tout
simplement parce que vous êtes
extrêmement minoritaire et quand on est
minoritaire qu'on veut imposer son point
de vue on devient illibéral vous avez
usé du triptyque bien connu provoquer
réaction répression vous nous avez
provoqué constamment ce matin quel était
le sens de la priorité de l'article
aucun ce que vous vouliez c'est qu'on
fasse des rappels au règlement donc vous
nous avez provoqué nous avons réagi et
maintenant vous nous réprimer en 68
c'était bien connu ça oui tout à fait
moi
personnellement je tiens à adresser un
message au mouvement social qui est
majoritaire et que le gouvernement
malgré cela veut
en force oui mais parce que j'explique
rappelle au règlement madame ponce non
je ne peux pas accepter donc je donne la
parole à Monsieur Fernique pour un
rappel au règlement en attendant
la Présidente chers collègues donc sur
la base de l'article
sur la base sur la base de l'article 42
9 de notre règlement qui dit comment se
passe les choses quand le gouvernement
dégaine le 44 3 de la Constitution je
crois qu'il faut bien qu'on prenne
conscience les autres que si ça se passe
ainsi ça signifie que nous n'aurons plus
qu'un seul vote un sol sur l'ensemble du
texte et sur l'ensemble des amendements
dont on nous a donné oralement une liste
et dont nous attendons de pouvoir
découvrir ce que nous aurons au menu que
nous aurons à avaler d'un seul coup
belle clarté belle sincérité des débats
quand il n'y a que les pour qui
s'exprimeront car ça aussi il faut en
prendre conscience un seul vote mais
systématiquement un seul son de cloche
en trois temps en trois temps je le
concède il y a les auteurs de
l'amendement cela ils sont pour leur
amendement en principe
il y a la commission favorable à ses
amendements et il y a le gouvernement
dont j'ai l'impression qu'il sera
favorable aussi à ses amendements les
autres se taisent ils écoutent c'est
tout alors je veux bien que que le
décorum de cette émission que notre
salle des conférences que notre palais
du Luxembourg
fasse un petit peu Second Empire c'est
clair mais que notre Sénat bascule dans
sa pratique vers un tel
bonapartiste non non
que les amendements qui ont été élus par
le ministre ce sont ceux qui vont
recevoir un avis favorable
mais nous verrons tous les amendements
qui restent dans l'allias nous verrons
donc le petit millier d'amendements qui
nous reste dans la liasse ceux qui ont
été cités par le ministre sont ceux qui
ont un a priori favorable monsieur
Bocquet pour rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente
en vertu d'article 49 notre règlement
effectivement je voudrais d'abord donner
lecture de la Linéa 3 de l'article 44 de
la Constitution sur lequel on est en
train de se prononcer les uns et les
autres je le cite si le gouvernement le
demande
l'assemblée saisie se prononce par un
seul vote sur tout ou partie du texte
tandis que si on ne retenant que les
amendements proposés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement fin de citation
il y a quelques jours ici que il n'y
avait plus au Sénat qu'un seul bloc
libéral pour soutenir cette réforme
libérale il y a un accord de fond on le
sait ce n'est pas une surprise mais là
on est en train d'assister à une forme
de sabordage du Sénat dans cette
république il y avait le BIC amerisme
j'ai envie de parler à l'imparfait
malheureusement le Sénat joue son rôle
dans cette république mais là on est en
train de le saborder et où est la
séparation des pouvoirs dans cette
situation c'est gravissime ce qui est en
train de se passer le ministre choisit
les amendements publics conviennent
sincèrement ce moment est grave je veux
le dire avec solennité après la crise
économique qui sévit depuis longtemps
dans ce pays la crise sociale qui est en
train de s'exprimer vous allez ajouter
une crise politique majeure dans un pays
fracturé et en tension
monsieur chanterelle
[Applaudissements]
madame madame la Présidente se rappelle
au règlement en vertu de l'article 44
bis de notre règlement intérieur
aujourd'hui vous piétinez le Sénat avec
la complicité de la droite sénatori
gouvernement est responsable de ce qui
se passe depuis le début en ayant choisi
justement l'utilisation du 47 ans qui
limite les débats qui n'ont pas permis
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale
d'aller au bout des débats et qui
brutalise à nouveau à travers
l'utilisation de cet article de la
Constitution 44-3 pour brutaliser le
Sénat vous avez une pratique du pouvoir
brutal vous prouvez à travers tous ces
artifices l'essoufflement de cette
république de cette cinquième république
aujourd'hui vous en faites à nouveau la
démonstration d'ailleurs
hasard du calendrier sort aujourd'hui un
livre intitulé une république à bout de
souffle que je vous recommande justement
de lire elle montre à quel point les
contradictions les archaïsmes de cette
constitution sa vulnérabilité qui
augmente face aux tentations
autoritaires et qu'un nouveau partage
des pouvoirs serait savateur pour une
république enfin sociale et écologique
mais face ce coup de force que vous
essayez de faire c'est un coup de force
contre les Françaises et les Françaises
qui se battent aussi contre cette
réforme c'est eux que vous brutalisez à
travers ces outils quand vous
bretallisez le Parlement c'est pour ça
que malgré tous ces artifices nous
serons nombreux nous appelons justement
les Françaises et les Françaises de se
mobiliser en masse encore plus nombreux
et nombreuses face à cette volonté de
nous brutaliser car samedi nous serons
avec eux dans la rue
désormais les Français
à partir du moment où leur privé de
débat
monsieur kerouge vous demande de faire
votre appel au règlement en indiquant
l'article auquel vous faites référence
[Musique]
c'est Monsieur kerouchki à l'appart à la
parole pour son rappel au règlement
monsieur querrus sur quel fondement du
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente
encore une remarque à notre collègue
Hainaut parce qu'il nous interpelle vous
êtes obsédé monsieur par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous faites une fixation il y
a de très bonnes consultations
psychologique en ce qui nous concerne en
ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
socialistes et écologistes et communiste
bien
un bel exercice quand même commun de
médiocrité parlementaire parce que
vous nous expliquez l'ensemble des
mesures ou des dispositions que nous
aurions prises pour ne pas faire avancer
le débat ou pour faire obstruction ceci
étant je rappelle notamment pour le
Conseil constitutionnel que par exemple
il y a une collusion évidente entre la
commission des affaires sociales et sa
présidente et le gouvernement parce que
en ne réussissant en ne réunissant pas
la commission cela permettait de mettre
en place l'article 44 alinéa 2 c'est de
la collusion ensuite vous avez utilisé
l'article 38 avec une seule prise de
parole l'article 42 10 le temps
déterminé l'article 44-6 sur les
priorités l'article 46 bis 2 sur les
examens 10 juin l'article 46 bis 4
dites-moi vraiment qui a fait de
l'obstruction parlementaire qui
en fait
en fait nous aurons eu avec ce débat la
preuve que cette réforme était mauvaise
je salue la présence de Frank et Esther
qui le premier a manifester le fait que
cette réforme se faisait au détriment
des femmes et bien tout le long de
l'examen tout le long de l'examen nous
aurons montré que cette réforme est très
mauvaise et je terminerai par une
formule bien connue mais elle est
vraiment vérifiée aujourd'hui la
roche-tard Payenne n'est pas loin du
capital du Capitole pardon
je voyais monsieur carucci je voyais
monsieur les mais très sérieusement le
succès que vous pensez avoir aujourd'hui
et déjà la défaite de demain brûlant
pour rappel
aux règles madame
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
le temps du débat c'est le gouvernement
qui la volontairement réduit d'abord en
soumettant l'examen de ce texte à
l'article 47 1 qui oblige à finir ce
débat dimanche minuit et qui ensuite
refusent d'ouvrir ce qui reste possible
le débat au-delà de dimanche minuit il
serait d'ailleurs peut-être encore temps
de le faire parce qu'il reste un certain
nombre d'amendements à exposer et je
pense que si vous vouliez vraiment
montrer que vous êtes prêt au débat vous
ouvrirez la séance au-delà de dimanche
la majorité sénatoriale ne s'est en
effet pas grandi de prêter le flanc à
toutes ces manœuvres elle s'est réduite
à une béquille du gouvernement en se
prenant les pieds dans le tapis puisque
toutes les procédures activées depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant n'ont
contribué qu'à une seule chose c'est à
retard er encore le débat et à ne pas
avancer sur l'examen du texte
je crois que ce vote bloqué vous
l'activez aussi parce que dans la
majorité sénatoriale comme dans la
majorité présidentielle les fractures et
les lézards se font de plus en plus
ouvertes ici je l'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire et je vais le redire
55 de nos collègues qui appartiennent au
banc de la droite et du centre ont
refusé de voter l'article 7 c'est ça qui
vous pose problème je tiens c'est
absolument leur droit et nous les en
félicitons ce qui est en revanche
irresponsable c'est que à activer ce
petit frère du 49-3 vous allez redoubler
la colère du pays et c'est absolument
irresponsable dans le contexte où nous
sommes pour ce qui nous concerne nous
allons continuer de défendre argument
après argument les méfaits de cette
réforme qui repousse l'âge de la
retraite de deux ans vous pouvez compter
sur nous nous ne lâcherons pas sur
chacun de nos arguments
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'avais vu
que le président rotaïo s'était inscrit
moi j'espère que je lui passe pas devant
vous avez perdu le débat politique
l'utilisation du 49-3 sénatorial c'est
la preuve que vous avez perdu le débat
politique vous avez d'abord accepté le
47 heures la procédure contrainte pour
les débats y compris vous avez un texte
qui a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale puis ici après l'obstruction
silencieuse vous avez utilisé
l'obstruction réglementaire en allant
chercher ce bouquin au fin fond d'une
armoire poussiéreuse avec des arguments
et des règlements qui n'avaient jamais
utilisé été utilisé auparavant et je
vous le redis vous ne règlerez pas la
question politique par des argusies
réglementaires et maintenant vous vous
en remettez au gouvernement qui active
l'arme du 49-3 sénatorial pour mettre
fin
à nos débats mais le débat il continue à
l'extérieur des millions de travailleurs
et travailleuses se sont mis puissamment
en grève et celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qu'ils sachent une chose nous
continuerons à défendre nos arguments et
nos amendements jusqu'au bout vous allez
être contraintes d'entendre tout ce que
nous voulions débattre et il faut
continuer à se mobiliser puis ça
m'incendie parce que nous voulons une
chose et nous ne céderons rien et les
trois groupes de gauche écologistes
socialistes et communiste resteront une
IRM assemblée jusqu'au retrait de cette
réforme unique et chers collègues vous
êtes rentrés très fort et majoritaire
vous en sortez affaibli et tout petit et
si vous pensez que vous allez régler la
chose à 14 dans une salle en CMP contre
la majoritaire des Français vous vous
gourouez merci chers
[Applaudissements]
règlement monsieur symbole de lipo
règlement
oui merci 44 bises vous avez raison
d'être vigilante
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues d'abord je trouve que
franchement
j'écoutais madame borne qui nous
rappelait mercredi
elle a évoqué la séparation des pouvoirs
je suis assez scandalisé de la
proposition du missile du socle en
l'absence du président du Sénat
c'est un événement important pour notre
institution donc on choisit pas
au minimum on se respecte et je peux
d'autant plus me dire que vous le savez
mes collègues et l'air j'ai porte une
appréciation assez dure à l'encontre de
notre président à un moment donné de nos
débats avec vous me connaissez avec ma
sincérité s'agissant l'obstruction
monsieur Hainaut alors là franchement
ne portons pas des mots plus hauts on
n'a pas besoin d'invective ici personne
n'a à avoir honte moi je vais vous dire
des 145 LR des 145 élèves il y en a 127
qu'on vote pour mais les autres n'ont
qu'une honte à avoir les centristes
étaient 50 157 il a 35 ont voté pour
mais les autres n'ont pas de honte à
avoir les indépendants Républic et
territoires sont 24 22 ont voté pour les
deux autres n'ont pas de honte à avoir
et je peux continuer la liste comme ça
donc il n'y a pas eu d'obstruction il
n'y a pas eu d'obstruction il y a des
parlementaires des sénatrices et des
sénateurs qui ont eu l'occasion
d'exprimer des au contraire donc il n'y
a pas eu obstruction du débat vous
n'allez pas changer y compris des
éléments de votre majorité c'est pas
sérieux et puis après là quand même on
est dans un duo là franchement c'est
impressionnant on a un article 7 qui est
réécrit en duo en 10 minutes après on
nous a fait l'article 38 moi je vais
vous dire ce qui est en train de se
passer vous êtes en train de créer un
régime des pleins pouvoirs voilà ce que
vous êtes en train de faire et vous et
je le dis à la majorité senoriale
sénatoriale en acceptant le diktak du
gouvernement vous êtes en train de faire
de la béquille parce que vous êtes en
train de préparer un nouveau régime
parce qu'on est en train d'affaiblir les
deux assemblées le pouvoir parlementaire
et je vous dis ça sans invective et sans
polémique il y a 82 % de Français en
colère ce matin
82% de français en colère ce matin
Madame Van egg pour rappel au règlement
et madame la Présidente un rappel au
règlement en vertu de l'article 44 bis
personne n'est dupe monsieur le ministre
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale
votre pénible liste à la Prévert de
justification à votre décision de
piétiner l'opposition n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
ici et avec la brutalité qui s'est
exprimée c'est vous monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale qui nous avait
muselé bâillonner
bâillonné embarrassé
embarrassé que vous êtes
par nos arguments et nos propositions en
opposition à votre réforme réactionnaire
et néfaste pour les Français
les Français n'y comprennent plus rien
mais il doit savoir que c'est un coup
d'État que vous venez de déclencher ici
au Sénat
et vous allez tristement aujourd'hui
marquer l'histoire
jumia pour rappel au règlement
merci Madame la prudente au moins trois
articles 46 bits 44 bits 44 terre
je
à cet instant je constate que la
discussion a démarré avec un accord
politique légitime oui oui monsieur
caoutchi légitime entre la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement sur le
fond d'un texte
vous nous avez donné l'habitude d'être
plus placide chers préavis président
et cet accord politique s'est transformé
et c'est là qu'elle problème en accord
institutionnel
la constitution de notre République elle
donne beaucoup de pouvoir à l'exécutif
plus que dans tout autre démocratie
parlementaire et le règlement du Sénat
il tente de préserver les droits de
l'institution parlementaire
l'activation du 49-3 fait partie des
prérogatives constitutionnelles du
gouvernement 44-3 pardon constitutionnel
du gouvernement le ministre choisit de
l'activer
mais là nous avons assisté à autre chose
nous avons assisté à une majorité
sénatoriale qui a organisé l'activation
de cet article avec le gouvernement
il en résulte une confusion
institutionnelle qui est grave vous ne
défendez plus le Sénat vous utilisez les
outils que notre Constitution donne à
l'exécutif pour activer accélérer
l'adoption d'un texte au Sénat vous
n'utilisez pas le fait majoritaire là
vous utilisez vous vous pliez à une
demande de gouvernement avec les outils
de l'exécutif et ça c'est grave et ça
c'est grave parce que je comprends que
le fait majoritaire vous donne le droit
de faire voter un texte vous pouvez vous
exclamer
comme nos droits d'opposants nous
donnent le droit d'accéder les outils
pour le freiner mais là vous avez
franchi le Rubicon vous êtes mis dans la
main de l'exécutif
S
[Applaudissements]
madame
la Présidente au nom de l'article 42 9
et à propos de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution
nous parlions au début de ces débats de
des traditionnels des bains feutrés du
Sénat et nous allons terminer sur des
débats Bayonnais la démocratie se mesure
au respect des minorités mais aussi des
syndicats des corps sociaux pour les
syndicats lorsqu'ils demandent à être
reçus par le Président de la République
la première ministre les renvoie dans le
bureau de Monsieur du soft
du respect je ne le sais pas sans
vouloir manquer de respect au ministre
je pense que l'ampleur de la
manifestation nécessitait que le
président les reçus en ce qui nous
concerne après le choix d'un véhicule
législatif qui contraint nos débats et
qui nous oblige à terminer dans les
délais contraints fixés par l'article
47.1 pour voter vite trop vite cette
mauvaise réforme avec votre accord et
lâche chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale voilà donc le 44 3 utilisé
pour bâillonner c'est le mot
l'opposition sénatoriale et hélas je le
dis avec la complicité de la majorité
sénatoriale je suis tout récent ici j'ai
toujours vu les sénateurs bataillés pour
le respect de leurs droits et de la
capacité d'agir et de débattre du
Parlement
et si cette capacité est mise à mal
après que reste-t-il que reste-t-il
chers collègues lorsque les
manifestations sont méprisées monsieur
le ministre que reste-t-il quel article
de la Constitution permet de bâillonner
des millions de manifestants et vers
quel régime allons-nous aller
pour rappel aux règlements pardon
monsieur Dantec
oui merci madame la présidente rappelle
au règlement évidemment sur la base du
44 bisous je voudrais vous relire
l'article 28 le Premier ministre a pris
consultation du président de l'assemblée
concernée ou la majorité des membres de
chaque assemblée peut décider la tenue
de jour supplémentaire de séance avec le
47 ans nous avons 50 jours nous pouvons
donc aller plus tard que dimanche si
vous vouliez vraiment que nous
débattions vous aviez la possibilité par
la constitution de rajouter des jours et
c'est ce que j'ai d'ailleurs proposé
hier soir simplement vous ne le voulez
pas et ce matin vous avez même multiplié
les
provocations y compris pour se faire
tomber 10 ou amendements pour justement
arriver à ce que vous aviez décidé
depuis déjà longtemps je crois
qu'effectivement ça a été dit par mes
collègues c'est un affaiblissement
terrible du Parlement c'est un
affaiblissement du Sénat avec le soutien
de la majorité sénatoriale et je vais
pas être très très long mais ça parlera
aux quelques gaullistes qui sont encore
sur les bandes droites je crois que le
titre de ce qui se passe ce matin c'est
balle tragique au Sénat un mort la
société française qui sort plus
fragilisée que jamais
monsieur Paco pour rappel au règlement
oui madame la Présidente merci en vertu
de l'article alors on a entendu des mots
quand même assez fort le président kaner
a parlé de réactionnaire
notre ami salvadélie a parlé des pleins
pouvoirs les pleins pouvoirs ils ont été
votés à Pétain en juillet 40 c'est quand
même une référence navrante on a parlé
de bonapartisme ce n'est pas le 18
brumaire le ministre du socle n'est pas
Joachim Murat il n'y a pas de grenadier
pour vous sortir d'ici
vous avez parlé
il n'y a qu'un seul regret c'est que
nous soyons contraints de subir ce que
vous appelez un 49-3 sénatorial nous
aurions tous aimé vous comme nous mais
peut-être pas avec la même sincérité
aller jusqu'au bout du vrai débat cette
espèce de 49-3 sénatoriale il est
provoqué il est provoqué il faut que
vous l'assumiez par votre coagulation
des débats votre attitude aboutissait à
une embolie sénatoriale et je suis navré
de conclure en utilisant la morale du
rat et de l'huître de la Fontaine tel
est pris qui croyait prendre
monsieur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mais mes chers collègues les
Français et les Françaises nous
regardent et ne comprennent qu'une seule
chose face à cette hémicycle les
républicains du Sénat sont entrés au
gouvernement voilà ce que les Français
comprennent aujourd'hui nous sommes face
à une crise politique majeure majeur
l'autorité du Président de la République
est en question l'autorité de la
première ministre est en question le
groupe majoritaire de l'Assemblée
nationale a éclaté il ne reste plus
qu'au gouvernement l'assurance de
pouvoir disposer des votes du groupe
républicain au Sénat chers collègues je
vous pose la question est-ce que vous
allez sauver le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron
monsieur dossier pour rappel au
règlement sous quel fondement monsieur
dessus
sur le 44 bis madame la Présidente merci
on va remettre un peu de contexte parce
que j'entends un peu n'importe quoi qui
est raconté sur les rangs de la droite
qui réécrit qui réécrit largement
l'histoire de ce débat qui réécrit
largement l'histoire de ce débat on a eu
un débat sur un jusqu'à mardi à peu près
on a étudié jusqu'à 6 articles
sereinement ça a été long évidemment
mais on a étudié six articles
sereinement jusqu'à mardi mardi il s'est
passé quelque chose les Françaises sont
levés ils sont ils vous ont dit à quel
point ils rejetaient cette réforme les
grèves ont commencé à se mettre en place
et là ça a été le début de la panique
début de la panique c'est 1000
amendements de la gauche qui sont tombés
pour un effet de procédure ensuite ça a
été la montée en puissance du règlement
42 38 44 de hier mais aussi le début de
la fissure on a vu certains de des
sénateurs de droite et du centre qui ne
votaient pas l'article 7
on a vu aussi qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
les menaces commençaient à pleuvoir sur
les les députés de la majorité qui ne
voteraient pas ce texte aujourd'hui pour
12 sous amendements 12 sous amendements
c'est une demi-heure de débats 12 sous
amendements le ministre a craqué il a
sorti le 44 3
il nous reste 900 amendements 900
amendements
1000 sous amendements il nous restait
trois jours de débat on aurait même plus
ouvrir une journée de plus on aurait pu
aller au bout c'était les débats sur le
sucré de la réforme sur les mesures
d'athénomation de la brutalité de la
réforme mon avis hier quand on a
commencé à les débattre qu'on n'avait
même plus à les expliquer ici que
personne ne comprenait que c'est que ces
mesures d'atténuation n'étaient pas à la
hauteur donc on vient comprendre ce qui
se passe c'est à dire que vous n'arrivez
pas à masquer la brutalité de la réforme
vous arriverez plus à l'assumer ces
débats et donc vous essayez de nous
faire taire tout le monde l'a compris et
vous n'y arriverez pas et demain les
manifestations seront massives monsieur
Tissot pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon rappel
au règlement sera sur la base de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf de notre
règlement alors que l'avenir des
Françaises et les Français est en jeu et
que nous débattuons du droit à avoir une
retraite en bonne santé et un repos
mérité après de longues carrière
éreintes je suis profondément choqué par
le contournement du Parlement et du
débat démocratique décidé par le
gouvernement en seulement 30 minutes
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatorial en acceptant la proposition
du gouvernement prenez-vous conscience
de ce que vous venez d'accepter alors
que vous cessez vous ne cessez de
rappeler la grandeur du Sénat à laquelle
je crois vous venez de réduire au néant
son rôle institutionnel au sein de notre
République
je souhaitais revenir sur les propos de
notre collègue qui parlaient
d'obstruction honteuse des groupes de
gauche et vous mon cher collègue
n'avez-vous pas honte de refuser un
débat sur un texte qui privera les
Français de deux ans de vie et de
projets à accomplir
moi j'aime bien quand la droite
manifeste quand je parle parce que ça
veut dire que moi en tant qu'élut de
gauche je touche juste
monsieur du soft monsieur le ministre
vous justifiez cette manœuvre de
contournement vous faire aboutir un
texte de loi
soi-disant de justice sociale pourtant
mardi dernier plus de 6000 personnes
étaient réunies dans une ville que vous
connaissez bien Annonay commune vous
avez été maire député de cette
circonscription commune qui joue ce
monde de nombreux manifestement
rappelaient qu'il y a 12 ans vous
manifestiez alors côté contre la réforme
des retraites des rivort en dénonçant et
se sont vos mots de l'époque une réforme
doublement injuste pensez-vous cette
fois que votre réformé juste monsieur le
ministre je pense que l'ensemble des
interventions que nous avons plus sur le
rappel aux règlements monsieur le colis
merci merci madame la Présidente la
semaine la Présidente je souhaitais
finalement réagir à quelques-uns des
rappels au règlement sur un point en
particulier mais monsieur Tissot
évoquant une commune qui m'est cher
m'invite finalement à réagir plus vite
encore que ce que je le pensais je dis
ça vous avez évoqué la manifestation qui
s'est déroulée dans ma commune celle où
j'habite et ça me permet d'apporter un
élément nouveau et je le dis en
précisant que aucun destinateur ici
présent n'est responsable de cela
j'ai indiqué il y a quelques heures de
débat maintenant peut-être deux jours
que de 10 heures à 15h 2400 foyers de ma
commune avait été privé d'électricité
après une coupure volontaire
cette coupure volontaire a entraîné la
nécessité pour les lycées de fermer leur
porte empêcher les commerçants de
travailler à nécessité que les pompiers
interviennent pour débloquer délivrer
plus exactement des personnes bloquées
dans des ascenseurs à contraint les
résidents d'un foyer de personnes âgées
à manger froid et des interventions de
pompiers pour des personnes placées sous
respirateur et à causer le désordre que
vous imaginez
cette coupure volontaire monsieur le
sénateur a été depuis revendiqué par la
CGT énergie si c'est de ce mouvement
social dont vous réclamez je ne suis pas
sûr que ça participe à la clarté ou la
légitimité des débats
ensuite
j'ai entendu à plusieurs reprises des
mots qui je crois dépassent largement le
cadre de nos débats
j'ai entendu et les rappels éducats des
rappels de règlement mais monsieur le
Président caoutchi n'étant pas moi-même
sénateur je n'ose me prononcer sur cet
aspect là sur les mots que j'ai entendus
coup de force bâillon censure régime
libéral il démocratique coup d'État
régime autoritaire je crois
véritablement que ça n'est pas
nécessairement adéquate lorsqu'on met en
oeuvre une procédure prévue par la
Constitution par notre texte principal
par des dispositions qui autorisent le
gouvernement à solliciter du Parlement
une seule chose c'est la clarté
d'impositionnement et d'un débat j'ai
aussi entendu des discours ou des
interventions offusqués disant mais
finalement que faites-vous personne n'a
jamais osé faire cela c'est absolument
incroyable les quelques rappels qui se
sont succédés m'ont permis de consulter
les archives du Sénat
le 20 avril 2013 après 18h de débats
après l'examen de 156 amendements sur
les 679 qui étaient déposés sur le
projet de loi relatif à la sécurisation
professionnelle
qui comptait 20 article c'est le hasard
de la comparaison un de mes
prédécesseurs Michel Sapin
avait recours à l'article 44.2
considérant qu'il n'y avait pas de
possibilités autre pour faire aboutir le
texte et c'est d'autant plus particulier
que le gouvernement qu'il représentait à
l'époque au bon
44-3 vous avez raison un type 44 3 ou
gouvernement que je soutenais j'ai voté
la loi à l'Assemblée nationale mais le
gouvernement auquel participait monsieur
sapin pour porter cette ce projet de loi
en 2013 et pour lequel il a utilisé
l'article 44 3 était majoritaire dans
cette assemblée c'est la démonstration
mais que même lorsqu'un gouvernement est
majoritaire dans une assemblée s'il fait
face à l'obstruction il a recours à des
dispositions constitutionnelles pour
permettre l'expression de la clarté des
débats de l'Assemblée
monsieur le président pour rappel au
règlement
sur la base madame la Présidente de
l'article 46 bis je voudrais premier
élément parce que en fait bon c'est vrai
que le débat était contraint par le 47
ans mais je voudrais juste dire
puisqu'il y a eu dans un dérapéro
règlement que le gouvernement est très
bien pu laisser un jour de plus sur la
base de l'article 28 mais c'est faux
mais c'est fou pardon de vous le dire
parce que l'article 28 dit il y a 120
jours possible dans une session
ordinaire et le gouvernement peut
rajouter une journée pour faire 121 122
le cas échéant et ça n'a rien à voir
avec le 47 ans qui lui fixe très
clairement le nombre et là-dessus vous
ne pouvez rien rajouter donc c'est
totalement faux non mais pardon on peut
tordre le cou à la Constitution mais
tout mais ce que j'entends ici me désole
pourquoi parce que un coup on remet en
cause le règlement du Sénat qui je le
rappelle a été adopté à l'unanimité de
tous les groupes en 2015 un coup on
remet en cause des articles de la
Constitution
merci d'être de 1958 en tout cas pour
les articles concernés le 44.2 ou le
44,3 aucun gouvernement de gauche depuis
1958 n'a modifié la constitution de ce
côté là aucun parce que chacun des
gouvernements est considéré qu'il
fallait évidemment avoir une capacité de
passer outre à l'obstruction
gouvernement de gauche gouvernement de
droite gouvernement Macron personne n'a
envisagé et même dans les idées de
réforme qui viennent aujourd'hui
personne ne remet en cause l'article 44
c'est quand même un peu un problème non
mais écoutez merci Monsieur Savoldelli
mais la vérité c'est que quand j'entends
coup d'État quand j'entends je ne sais
quoi nous essayons nous essayons de
débattre à plusieurs reprises j'ai
demandé pour la sérénité des débats
qu'on arrête les sous amendements qu'on
arrête les explications multiples pour
rentrer dans le fond dans le respect de
tous ça n'a pas été possible vous portez
la responsabilité
vous portez la responsabilité du fait
qu'aujourd'hui le débat parlementaire
doit céder le pas malheureusement à une
méthode plus autoritaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le Président Retailleau pour
rappel aux règlements pour un rappel au
règlement mes chers collègues de gauche
vous surjouez le 46 bis
vous surjouez l'indignation
chers collègues de gauche et vous faites
mine d'être surpris mais vous ne l'êtes
pas
l'application du vote bloqué c'est la
Constitution
ça n'est pas une application il libérale
de notre loi fondamentale ici nous
sommes sur la 5e République nous ne
sommes pas sous la Quatrième République
l'application du vote bloqué la cause
c'est vous c'est votre obstruction vous
avez donné votre version des faits je
vous donne notre version des faits bien
sûr jusqu'à mardi 7 mars tout se passait
bien puisque nous avions un engagement
vous souhaitiez discuter et que l'on
vote l'article 7 pas avant le 7 nous
nous sommes tu pas bâillonner nous nous
sommes tu pour respecter notre
engagement et ensuite vous n'avez tenu
aucun de vos engagements très vite nous
sommes aperçus que vous vouliez nous
empêcher d'aller au bout de débattre du
fond et de voter le texte
l'obstruction c'est quand on dépose
449 demandes de rapport l'obstruction
c'est quand on multiplie des amendements
identiques des sous amendements
ridicules qui n'apportent rien des
rappels au règlement qui n'en sont pas
ça c'est de l'obstruction et
l'obstruction finalement c'est la
négation du rôle du Parlement vous
transformez le Sénat en un groupe de
parole le Parlement ne vaut bien sûr
qu'avec les débats pour éclairer la
délibération et le vote c'est notre
métier c'est notre devoir le devoir que
nous avons pris par rapport au français
mes chers collègues
voilà on se retrouve sur Public Sénat
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver poursuivre l'examen de la
réforme des retraites au Sénat le Sénat
qui débat maintenant depuis 9 jours sur
ce projet de loi toute la rédaction de
Public Sénat se mobilise pour vous faire
vivre ces discussions dans l'hémicycle
où se trouve cet après-midi Audrey
vuettaz qui va nous accompagner tout
l'après-midi poursuivre analyser tout
l'examen de ce texte bonjour Audrey à
tout de suite bonjour sur ce texte les
débats et bien vont accélérer d'un coup
puisque ce matin alors que les sénateurs
des battaient de l'article 9 du projet
de loi qui porte sur la pénibilité que
les débats sont lisait devenant plus des
débats sur les conditions du débat que
sur le fond de la réforme le
gouvernement a fini par dégainer
l'article
44-3 de la Constitution le vote unique
que l'on connaît mieux sous le nom de
votre bloqué Audrey que prévoit
exactement cette procédure et bien Tam
on veut dire que c'est l'arme ultime
pour contraindre les débats c'est une
arme qui doit être déclenchée par le
gouvernement et cela oblige le Sénat à
ne voter le texte qu'avec les
amendements choisis par le gouvernement
entre l'article 9 qui était examiné au
moment du déclenchement jusqu'au dernier
le 20 le gouvernement en a choisi 70 sur
le millier qu'il restait deux précisions
cela ne change rien à ce qui a été voté
depuis une semaine avant le
déclenchement de cet article autre
précision tous les amendements même ceux
qui ne sont pas retenus par le
gouvernement peuvent être présentés et
débattus peuvent être présentés et
défendus pardon cet après-midi et demain
à raison de deux minutes par amendement
vous le voyez ça devrait durer encore un
petit moment
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explications et on a vu et bien la
gauche dénoncer un coup de force la
droite qui estime elle que cela réponse
à l'obstruction de la gauche et que le
Sénat devenait ce son les mots de Bruno
retaillaux
otages d'une minorité j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau Françoise
Gatel bonjour bonjour la sénatrice Union
centriste présidente de la délégation en
collectivités Françoise Gatta la gauche
dénonce un coup de force est-ce que ça
l'est
non le mot n'est pas juste du tout je
pense que si on comptabilisait le temps
de parole de la gauche depuis le début
des débats je pense qu'il serait très
impressionnant et c'est le cas et que je
crois qu'ici il y a beaucoup de respect
de la part du président du Sénat de
chacun d'entre nous pour écouter
entendre sauf qu'à un moment on parle
plus du sujet c'est-à-dire on est on est
vraiment sur de l'obstruction il n'y a
pas de débat puisque la majorité c'est
Nathaniel est relativement empêché de
parler et que ce qui est le plus navrant
c'est qu'il y a ici des propositions
très fortes pour améliorer la retraite
de des femmes améliorer un certain
nombre de de choses extrêmement
importantes et demandées par nos
concitoyens et que la gauche refuse le
débat et son objectif c'était surtout à
mon avis de ne pas arriver à la fin du
débat en fin de semaine un objectif
assumé de ne pas vouloir voter le reste
dimanche là finalement on va être sûr de
pouvoir voter ce texte sans doute je
pense que c'est de leur part un objectif
de ne pas voter mais que votre compte
ils ont tout à fait loin et c'est tout à
fait respectable qu'ils empêchent un
vote sur un texte qu'on peut discuter
une méthode de dont on peut discuter
mais qu'ils empêchent que le Sénat fasse
ce qu'il doit faire c'est à dire aller
au bout d'un texte examiner l'enrichir
et l'améliorer ça c'est pas acceptable
on est plus du tout dans un débat de
fond sur les retraites on est sur autre
chose est-ce que justement c'est pas ça
le problème c'est que même depuis
l'article 7 on a été beaucoup plus sur
un débat sur les conditions du débat
finalement que sur le fond de la réforme
et cela de part et d'autre il y avait
effectivement la gauche qui a multiplié
et bien les amendements identiques les
amendements de suppression etc il a le
droit du coup à utiliser les armes comme
l'article 38 l'article 42 on a vu
ensuite et bien essentiellement des le
règlement on a découvert la couleur du
Règlement du Sénat on le connaissait pas
jusqu'ici le règlement vert du Sénat
dans tout cela où se passe le débat de
fond alors la forme des retraites moi je
dis que ceci la conséquence de cela
c'est-à-dire quand on contrevient à la
liberté parlementaire quand on parle 124
fois de manière identique sur un article
7 et qu'à un moment on est on aimerait
pouvoir avancer la discussion on
aimerait pouvoir s'exprimer qu'est-ce
qu'il fait vous vous adaptez et vous
prenez le règlement que tout le monde le
connaît pour permettre que le débat se
poursuive alors ensuite on a la gauche
qui est indigné alors elle obstrue elle
s'indigne parce qu'on n'empêcherait non
mais sincèrement il faut qu'on soit
réalise et que moi je me dis avec
beaucoup de gravité de respect pour mes
collègues de gauche que je me demande
parfois si le débat ne se situe pas
ailleurs c'est-à-dire s'il y a pas une
utilisation de ce débat sur les
retraites qui méritent d'être discuté
sur le fond pour
arrête être comme il nous disent du côté
du pape mais le peuple nous le
connaissons aussi bien que et qu'il y a
de la enfin moi je pense qu'il y a de la
diversion assez grave quand vous voyez
que le Président de la République ne va
pas se voir les syndicats qui a
maintenant le recours à votre bloqué
est-ce que tout cela ne risque pas et
bien de mettre de l'huile sur le feu à
la veille d'une manifestation importante
celle encore de demain ça n'est pas à
même d'apaiser les esprits bien sûr
alors moi je regrette profondément la
manière dont nous sommes amenés à
procéder à dire voilà maintenant on
arrête la récré et on se met vraiment au
travail parce que tous les amendements
vont être examinés quand même donc il y
a pas il y a pas de censure
et pourront être présenté
absolument ils seront présentés le
gouvernement a dit qu'il retiendra du
texte enfin le texte sortira s'il est
voté que les amendements qu'il accepte
dans la règle éclair voilà mais le droit
d'expression et d'un moment il est
totalement inspecté il faut aussi qu'on
arrête de nous en fumer donc ça va
encore durer longtemps moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse notre travail
jusqu'au bout si on nous laisse le faire
ensuite que le Président de la
République
ne répond pas moi j'en sais rien je fais
pas le secret d'arrêt du président de la
République donc voilà maintenant que le
pays soit dans une situation extrêmement
difficile je partage moi j'en suis
désolé et je le regrette que la réforme
est dû être présentée autrement qu'on
ait une conférence travail etc d'accord
mais maintenant on est là et je pense
que tout ça ne doit pas nous faire
oublier la question de fond c'est oui ou
non voulons nous sauver le système de
répartition
ça c'est un enjeu majeur qui cerne nos
concitoyens alors ça n'est pas génial ça
n'est pas extraordinaire mais
aujourd'hui est-ce que la réforme elle
est juste est-ce qu'on pourrait la
mélanger je crois maintenant on le fait
pas et quand on nous dit que il faut
aller au F1 d'homme et est-ce que la
gauche a parlé aussi de faire un homme
sur la gym spéciaux et est-ce que on dit
que dans cette dans notre République le
droit de grève qui doit être respecté il
ne doit pas entraîner de droit d'entrave
et d'empêchement et que la rue est là
pour exprimer les choses et dire le
mécontentement mais qu'en même temps le
Parlement il est aussi là pour faire son
travail ou va-t-on sinon si le Parlement
est empêché de faire son travail il faut
que chacun prenne sa part de
responsabilité dans les choses et bien
merci merci beaucoup Françoise Gatel
pour votre réaction on voit tout de
suite rejoindre Audrey Audrey bias qui
se trouve toujours dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat pour nous raconter comment s'est
passé il y a le déclenchement ce matin
de ce mode bloqué dans l'hémicycle
Audrey et bien ce matin nous avons si
c'est un véritable coup théâtre dans
l'hémicycle les observateurs
s'attendaient à ce que cet article 44 3
soit déclenché par le gouvernement mais
peut-être pas aussi rapidement il est
11h30 nous sommes au milieu de l'examen
de l'article 9 sur la pénibilité quand
Olivier du socle le ministre du Travail
demande à prendre la parole écouter
4 lignes à 3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat le gouvernement demande à votre
assemblée de se prononcer par un vote
unique sur l'ensemble du texte ainsi que
sur les articles 9 à 20 en retenant les
amendements et les sous amendements
suivants je vous ferai la liste dans un
instant mais en précisant que cette
annonce ne remet pas encore ce qui a
déjà été examiné et adopté à l'article 9
avant la suspension de semences
cela veut dire qu'il déclenche un vote
unique ou bloqué le Sénat va devoir
voter le texte final avec les seuls
amendements retenus par le gouvernement
entre l'article 9 où nous en étions et
le 20 le dernier il en a retenu 70 sur
le millier qui restait Bronka à ce
moment là dans l'hémicycle sur les rangs
de la gauche et pendant que la gauche
s'insurge se plaint d'être muselé Bruno
Retailleau le patron des républicains
s'avance au micro et explique en
filigrane que la gauche ne peut s'en
prendre qu'à elle-même et que le
gouvernement a agi pour défaire leur
obstruction écoutez
l'obstruction c'est quand on dépose
449 demandes de rapport l'obstruction
c'est quand on multiplie des amendements
identiques des sous amendements
ridicules qui n'apportent rien des
rappels au règlement qui n'en sont pas
ça c'est de l'obstruction et
l'obstruction finalement c'est la
négation du rôle du Parlement vous
transformez le Sénat en un groupe de
parole le Parlement ne vaut bien sûr
qu'avec les débats pour éclairer la
délibération et le vote c'est notre
métier c'est notre devoir le devoir que
nous avons pris par rapport aux Français
mes chers collègues et on ne peut pas
dans une enceinte parlementaire on ne
peut pas supporter qu'une minorité
prenne en otage une majorité par le seul
fait par le seul fait que vous ne
vouliez pas
être perdant nous voulons voter
réponse cinglante du président du groupe
écologiste Guillaume Gontard
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis demandent
demande solennellement être reçue par le
Président de la République qui leur
refuse toujours d'ouvrir la porte et de
et de continuer des discussions
l'ensemble de la population et dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien Sénat
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement
vous le voyez Tam à l'image de cette
intervention les débats cet après-midi
risque d'être enflammés alors que les
sénateurs commencent à regagner leur
place derrière moi
avec la sénatrice les républicains
bonjour
du gouvernement que lui répondez-vous à
droite est-elle à la remorque du
gouvernement absolument pas il y a qu'à
voir le nombre d'amendements qui avaient
été déposé sur ce texte un certain
nombre d'amendements avait d'ailleurs
été travaillé par la commission des
affaires sociales donc déjà sur la base
d'un texte qui était déjà qui est qui
ressemble fortement à l'amendement qui a
été adopté depuis plusieurs années par
le Sénat dans le cadre des projets de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale nous avions fait un certain
nombre d'autres corrections d'autres
ajouts donc en fait c'est finalement le
gouvernement qui revient reprendre une
proposition à des républicains que nous
avons continué à améliorer au cours des
débats
avec le recours à cet article 44-3 de la
Constitution qu'est-ce que vous lui
répondez j'ai envie de leur dire que
s'ils avaient pas fait tout ce cirque
depuis le début et toute cette
obstruction n'aurait peut-être pu
débattre sereinement du contenu du texte
et pour avoir fait un certain nombre
d'heures de présence dans l'hémicycle
j'avoue que par moment on perd
complètement le fil du sujet sur lequel
on est en train de discuter pour pour
avoir des arguides procédure qui
d'ailleurs ne font même pas référence à
un quelconque au Règlement du Sénat ou
autre et on se on s'éloigne beaucoup du
fond pour ne parler que de la forme et
c'est vraiment dommage de pas avoir
parlé du fond on aurait pu le faire on
avait le temps de le faire mais c'est le
débat était complètement dévoyé par ses
centaines de sous-amendements c'est les
amendements identiques et toutes les
toutes les manœuvres autour de la
procédure ordinaire pour allonger
inutilement les débats parce que bien
évidemment la gauche ne voulait pas
avoir à se prononcer sur ce projet de
loi le problème est-ce que c'est pas
aussi les réponses qu'on qui a apporté
la droite l'article 38 l'article 49
nombre de procédures aussi bien pour
pouvoir contracter à nouveau les débats
et qui ont finalement donné lieu à
encore plus de débats sur les conditions
du débat des rappels en règlements en
cascade on s'en est jamais sorti de
cette histoire depuis le milieu de
l'examen de l'article 7 mais il y a
aussi eu quand même une sorte de il y
avait une sorte de gentleman agreement
entre les différents groupes politiques
du Sénat pour effectivement accordé à la
gauche de ne pouvoir discuter l'article
7 le cœur de la réforme qu'après les
manifestations de mardi cela a été
respecté ça a été complètement respecté
nous qu'est-ce qui s'est passé nous
avons laissé parce que eux même
d'ailleurs sont venus rompre cet accord
pendant depuis vendredi après-midi
regarder le nombre de prises de parole
qui a fait la droite et on aurait des
choses à dire on aurait envie de venir
expliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
proposé ces modifications par rapport au
texte initial on n'a pas voulu le faire
pour que justement on puisse aller au
bout de ce texte et on puisse aller au
bout de ce texte dans des conditions
normales de débat ça il m'appartient pas
enfin c'est pas nous qui sommes allés
mettre c'est tombereau de sous
amendements et en France j'ai même
parfois envie de dire pour des gens qui
se revendiquent de l'écologie bah
franchement regardez le nombre de
feuilles de papier qui ont été imprimés
pour des amendements qui à la fin de son
même pas défendu
oui donc vous estimez que ce sont des
effectivement des manœuvres de diversion
des sous-hormans qui avaient été
photocopier etc
identique où il y a chacun écosignateur
unique ce qui lui permet de s'exprimer
et après on a les sous amendements qui
chacun viennent soit changer décalés
d'un jour la date de remise d'un rapport
où viennent ajouter chacun un organisme
supplémentaire à consulter je suis pas
sûr que ça participe vraiment du fond du
débat je vous interrompre Christine
lavard car nous voyons et bien la
conférence de presse de la gauche
justement qui va et bien maintenant dire
ça position après le recours à cet
article 44-3 de la Constitution le vote
unique ou le vote bloqué c'est Patrick
canard le président du groupe socialiste
qui s'exprime donc
nous sommes devant la mise en oeuvre ce
qu'on appelle l'historiquement en droit
constitutionnel le parlementarisme
rationalisé
rationaliser ça signifie que nous
passons d'un débat parlementaire à une
succession de monologue parlementaires
au travers de l'application de l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution là le 44
2 avec déjà été utilisé deux fois
quelques format part par Monsieur du
soft c'est ce qu'on appelle la pratique
du vote unique mais plutôt du vote
bloqué puisque il s'agit pour le
gouvernement de faire voter un texte
réduit en fait à son texte initial et
avec les amendements les amendements
acceptés par lui-même donc situation qui
a déjà été utilisée par un gouvernement
mais qui sur un texte aussi majeur à
savoir
chlore du réacteur à savoir augmenter
de deux ans le départ de l'âge à la
retraite
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez pas vous de gauche c'est le
dire offensé qu'ils peuvent compter sur
nous
ils continueront bien sûr à manifester
leur désaccord majeurs face à cette
réforme y compris demain lors de la
manifestation du du 11 mars ou sieron et
Parlement nous défendrons les derniers
amendements qui nous sont donnés presque
par une forme de mode par l'exécutif
gouvernementale et par la majorité
sénatoriale sachez que le travail que
nous avons mené jusqu'à présent a permis
quand même de remarquer que certains
sénateurs de droite avaient pu être
convaincu par nos arguments je rappelle
qu'il y a 5 ans sénateurs de droite qui
n'ont pas voté la situation
voire même voter donc ça signifie que
cette réforme
méritée du temps beaucoup plus de temps
que ce que le gouvernement nous a imposé
à savoir l'article 47 1 qui limite le
temps internationale
qu'au Sénat voilà l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous trouvons aujourd'hui devant
merci merci Patrick et je le dis devant
tout le monde nous avons une chance
aussi
comme ça c'est que nos trois groupes ont
toujours été le groupe socialiste de
groupe écologiste et bien les
économistes sont toujours été d'éclairs
sur la la façon de mener le débat dans
dans la société importante donc c'est
recours au Règlement et ou à des
articles de la Constitution je l'ai déjà
vu attribuer reprises de ils ont pas
surpris on a bien vu monter de plus en
plus la complicité entre la droite
sénatoriale dans sa diversité et le
gouvernement
le Sénat peut retrouver au règlement de
son parti de son règlement et le
gouvernement peut retrouver à une remet
ton passage en tous ces panneaux au
sujet c'est que cette multiplication de
recours a quand même des objectifs
cognitifs
pour lesquelles voilà donc et je pense
que c'est ça nous sommes au cœur de ce
départ cette réforme des retraites est
un sujet éminemment politique
elle est éminemment politique et nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyennes
fortes aussi on cette visibilité si je
puis dire on bien compris qu'il
s'agissait d'un texte de nature de
nature politique donc ce n'est pas
simplement
de restreindre tous ces tous ces
procédures de restreint de le débat
parlementaire c'est porter un coup quand
même assez mignon de concitoyens des
concitoyennes qui sont mobilisés et
au-delà de celles et ceux qui sont
mobilisés assez 90%
60% de la population française qui exige
le retrait de ce texte donc nous nous
n'allons pas en rabaisser nous avons
encore des amendements à défendre nous
allons défendre ces réservements même si
on est contraint nous aussi maintenant
par le fait de pouvoir les expliquer ou
de du Zénit notre modalités que nous
permet le règlement donc voilà on
défendra de nos amendements on sera à la
hauteur de ce qui s'exprime très
largement dans le pays et qui dit que le
gouvernement est minoritaire aujourd'hui
dans le dans le pays qui n'est pas
majoritaire donc voilà ça s'exprime un
petit peu un petit peu partout donc on
sera là on
ira jusqu'au bout de ce qu'il est
possible de de faire en essayant de
créer des conditions pour que ce texte
soit vous connaissez notre ambition on
l'avait dit on a respecté
la voiture là sur l'article 7 vote sur
l'article 7 mission accompli et là
deuxième mission c'est de pousser le
débat malgré des restrictions bien
évidemment mais de pousser le débat pour
que ce texte ne soit pas soumis au vote
le chemin n'est pas facile je vous
l'accorde tout de suite mais
on va bien trouver on a la volonté comme
dirait l'autre ça se sentir la remonter
voilà
bonjour
ça a été ça vient d'être appelé c'est
vrai qu'on est passé par le 47 ans ce
choix du gouvernement déjà ce véhicule
législatif l'article 38 l'article 42 et
puis on attendait de toute façon c'était
pas une surprise ce cet article 44 3 qui
ah oui
Uzel tout simplement le Parlement
alors on nous dit ça déjà été utilisé
c'est pas parce que ça déjà utilisé que
c'est une bonne chose je pense qu'on ne
peut pas se satisfaire de l'utilisation
de cet article et que c'est toujours et
ça sera toujours un navet de faiblesse
et là ça va tarif terrible à votre
faiblesse du gouvernement de la majorité
sénatoriale parce que ça a été dit leur
majorité ce qui est sûr on a vu le vote
sur l'article 7 qui est loin d'être
unanime
deux personnes même dans le groupe RDPI
Renaissance se sont abstenus non pas
voté et que petit à petit il le voit
bien sur le terrain et bien oui grâce au
travail parle grâce à l'action syndicale
grâce à tout ce qui peut se faire à la
fois les mobilisations dans la rue et
ben oui on comprend que ce texte
n'importe quoi rien pour les Françaises
et les Français et bien au contraire
elle leur prendra 2 ans de leur vie donc
il y a ce choix mais c'est un choix
grave lourd qui est pris aujourd'hui je
dirais une coproduction entre la
majorité sénatoriale et le gouvernement
on sait qu'il l'avait préparé mais c'est
un choix Hélène assassin a dit je pense
que c'est important c'est un choix
politique mais ce choix politique il est
il est lourd parce que derrière on le
voit tous on le sent il y a une colère
une colère terrible qui monte dans notre
dans notre pays et le Parlement doit
justement être là où s'exprime cette
transmission de ce qui peut se passer
dans notre pays c'est ça notre
démocratie c'est de pouvoir travailler
sur des textes faire remonter on est des
élus de chaque territoire
on a cette responsabilité là oui que ça
soit dans les villages dans les villes
de faire remonter justement cette cette
colère cette cette demande le fait qu'on
nous l'interdise parce que c'est quand
même ça qui est fait aujourd'hui on aura
juste l'autorisation de expliquer nos
amendements on sait qu'ils ne seront pas
votés on connaît déjà le texte qui a été
décidé encore une fois en coproduction
entre les républicains et puis le
gouvernement on le connaît déjà
maintenant nos seuls moyens c'est
effectivement c'est qu'il ne soit pas
voté et je pense qu'on mettra toutes nos
forces toute notre énergie pendant ces
quelques heures cette trentaine d'heures
qui restent pour faire en sorte pour
être à la fois le relais justement de
ces françaises et de ses français qui
qui attendent beaucoup de mots de part
on sera ce relais là on sera aussi
présent en tout cas sur la manifestation
alors évidemment certains tiendront le
siège ici mais en tout cas on se fera le
relais de ce qui se passe de ce qui se
passe dans la rue et puis peut-être pour
terminer
franchement la responsabilité du
gouvernement d'un président de la
République qui aujourd'hui refuse encore
de recevoir l'ensemble des syndicats on
n'a jamais eu une unité syndicale de
cette manière le président qui ne veut
pas leur ouvrir la porte qui ne veut pas
discuter qui ne veut pas discuter
dialoguer au Parlement c'est une
terrible responsabilité qu'il a
est-ce que vous avez des questions oui
donc un petit point d'ordre donc
vraiment nous souhaitons être en séance
dans 5 minutes pour des raisons
symbolique que vous comprendrez
conférence que nous avons demandé oui
c'est justement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous éclaircir un petit peu il reste
enfin combien d'amendements il vous
reste du coup à défendre est-ce que
est-ce que vous allez prendre la parole
comme il est prévu donc 2 minutes avant
chaque amendement même ceux qui n'ont
pas été retenus par le gouvernement
c'est vrai que si vous défendez chaque
amendement en fait vous pouvez encore
vous avez encore les armes pour pousser
les débats jusqu'à dimanche soir est-ce
que vous allez le faire alors il est
clair que au moment où le 44 aligné à 3
a été déclenchée des gainés comme vous
voulez il restait je pense je crois le
tableau j'avais eu 1000 le chiffre 1000
amendements à présenter devant devant le
Sénat le gouvernement a décidé de
préempter 70
amendement disant cela je les prends et
tous les autres je n'en veux pas ce qui
n'empêche pas de pouvoir les présenter
voilà c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle pour que les Français soient
informés des prises de position des
propositions que nous voulions défendre
et nous Inter dans cette conférence de
presse je suis à présent avec le
rapporteur de la branche de Yes le
rapporteur de cette réforme des
retraites René Paul Savary bonjour Alors
René Paul Savary et bien le coup de
théâtre de ce matin c'est bien sur le
recours à la petite le 44-3 de la
Constitution par le gouvernement le vote
unique le vote bloqué en entendu la
gauche qui dénonçait un coup de force
que lui répondez-vous c'est pas un coup
de théâtre
c'est la suite logique d'une tentative
d'obstruction qui n'est pas acceptable
en tout cas sûrement au Sénat c'est de
la raison pour laquelle
les engagements n'ayant pas été tenus la
gauche avait souhaité que le 7 le 7 mars
soit
décliné l'article 7 nous avions dans le
cadre des travaux respectueux que nous
menons toujours accepter l'engagement
suivant
l'engagement suivant a été de laisser
faire le débat or on voit que les
engagements ne sont pas tenus et qu'il y
a des tentatives d'obstruction en
multipliant les les sous amendements qui
sont répétitifs et qui n'amènent aucune
valeur ajoutée c'est dommage parce que
c'est en train de pourrir le débat et je
le regrette considérablement parce que
nous abordons vraiment les articles qui
amènent à cette loi la dimension de
justice sociale
les petites pensions on entend les
difficultés c'était le moment de
s'expliquer montrer ce qu'il en était
exactement et un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui sont véritablement
attendus ils nous l'ont dit les Français
et qui permettent de que cette réforme
soit un peu plus acceptable me
semble-t-il ne seront pas suffisamment
débattus peut-être si cette obstruction
continue moi j'en appelle le sens de la
responsabilité de mes collègues
l'article 44 c'est l'obstruction
consiste à faire des appels au règlement
et non pas il va y avoir que des appels
au règlement et retourner tout cela et
donc on va voir si cette volonté
d'obstruction continue et ben on verra
le nombre d'après le règlement mais
quand on regarde le nombre d'heures de
débats et en tout cas de monologue
surtout
de l'opposition par rapport au nombre
d'heures réelles de débats on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a quand même une différence
énorme j'avais cité 48 heures de débats
il y a quelques jours et 8 heures 48
heures de discussion pardon et 8 heures
de débat voyez-vous voilà on en est là
et ça continue donc il y a des
discussions qui sont traduisent une
opposition on a bien compris que
l'opposition était opposée il n'empêche
que la majorité doit aussi avoir la
possibilité quand même d'exprimer sa
volonté de soutenir ce texte je voudrais
aussi vous faire réagir à ce que disait
un paprikaner tout à l'heure maintenant
elle dit c'est la droite parlementaire
et la droite Élysée elle en a entendu
Guillaume Gontard qui disait la droite
sénatoriale et le toutou du gouvernement
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez ils est et c'est vrai sur ce
texte il y a une alliance claire entre
le gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale
est-ce que vous êtes à la remorque du
coup du gouvernement non c'est le
gouvernement qui est notre remorque que
je pense plutôt plus que ce texte ça
fait 4 ans que je le présente au nom de
la majorité sénatoriale et effectivement
le gouvernement a suivi les mêmes pistes
il manque une dimension sociale parce
que si ça avait été notre texte nous
aurions ajouté cette dimension de
justice sociale et en conséquence nous
souhaitons que le gouvernement nous
rejoigne également sur ces dispositifs
il y a déjà les maires de famille par
exemple
que le débat nous soit privé pour
convaincre le
gouvernement de nous de prendre en
compte les mesures que je propose en ce
qui concerne la capacité permanente en
ce qui concerne la retraite progressive
sont des une avancée importante dans le
dispositif nous aurions pu par le débat
convaincre le gouvernement dès à présent
de prendre en compte ces mesures et là
on nous prive de cette volonté de
convaincre et on prive les Français de
cette inventé sociale c'est quand même
grave est-ce que vous craignez quand
même que ça met de l'huile sur le feu
pour demain tout en tout cas le symbole
que représente les votes uniques le vote
bloqué demain il y a une grande journée
de manifestation écoutez je ne sais pas
si ça mettra d'huile sur le feu en ce
qui concerne les manifestations c'est le
droit de chacun de manifester son
mécontentement mais on peut comprendre
que certains a tenté du débat une
avancée ils sont privés d'avancer et en
tout cas en ce qui concerne le feu j'ai
l'impression que ceux qui ont mis le feu
se présentent maintenant comme les
pompiers de service et en conséquence
c'est une attitude inacceptable qui
prive les Français du débat démocratique
et qui n'est pas en faveur de l'image du
Sénat qui a quand même l'habitude de
travailler à fond ces textes nous
n'avons jamais vu ça et bien merci merci
beaucoup René Paul Savary d'avoir
répondu à toutes mes questions alors que
la séance va commencer d'un instant à
l'autre on va d'ailleurs rejoindre ma
collègue Audrey Vitas dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat à quoi s'attendre cet
après-midi Audrey et bien tamilia une
information principale à retenir car il
y a eu une conférence de presse des
groupes de la gauche la gauche qui a
décidé de siéger jusqu'au bout mal créé
l'activation de l'article 44-3 qui fait
que seuls les amendements retenus par le
gouvernement figurant dans le vote final
pour précision le gouvernement en a
retenu 70 sur le millier qui restait
encore à examiner et d'après Patrick
Kanner le président du groupe socialiste
tous les amendements de la gauche ont
été retoqués je vous propose de
l'écouter à l'occasion de cette
conférence de presse
qui nous est
de fait retirer aujourd'hui et nous le
regrettons nous avons dit il y a un
instant pris dans l'archet en conférence
des présidents ce texte aurait mérité un
débat allant jusqu'au bout cela ne sera
pas possible et la droite parlementaire
et la droite est l'iséenne ont trouvé
cette base d'accord et nous l'avons vu
d'ailleurs y compris physiquement le
rapprochement entre les différents
représentants de ces droites mais même
s'il y a un millier d'amendements qui
n'a pas été retenu par le gouvernement
cela n'empêche pas leur auteur de les
défendre à raison de deux minutes par
prise de parole vous le voyez il reste
encore au moins une trentaine d'hommes
d'heures de débats qui devrait donc se
poursuivre au moins jusqu'à demain
demain nouvelle journée de mobilisation
dans la rue Tam merci beaucoup Audrey je
suis à présent avec le sénateur
communiste du Nord Eric Boquet bonjour
Eric Bocquet bien que penser du recours
à l'article 4-3 j'ai eu plusieurs
sénateurs de droite qui disent et bien
c'est la suite logique de l'obstruction
de la gauche non écoutez depuis le début
on est dans un temps contraint le
gouvernement a opté pour une procédure
qui limite à 20 jours à l'Assemblée
nationale et 15 jours au Sénat le débat
donc d'emblée on était dans un corset
ici malheureusement la majorité
sénatoriale complètement en osmose avec
le gouvernement a pris le relais pour
faire que André mise pas les conditions
d'un débat serein et en profondeur sur
un texte une importance pareil quoi
rejetée par une majorité de Français ce
n'était pas une surprise même on
entendait ce matin Patrick canard qui
disait il va y avoir un vote bloqué
certainement quand allez-vous le
déclencher non mais la rumeur courait
effectivement aussi attendait mais ça ne
justifie pas pour autant le bien fondé
d'une telle décision le Parlement pris
un mauvais coup ce soir et
particulièrement le Sénat dans dans
cette république je crois que ça aura
des conséquences malheureusement vous
allez quand même présenter tous vos
amendements absolument nous allons
utiliser tout le temps qui nous reste à
défendre nos amendements et bien merci
beaucoup Eric Bocquet d'avoir répondu à
mes questions car la séance a commencé
c'est Gérard chez le président du Sénat
qui préside en ce moment tout de suite
non direction l'hémicycle de même les
deux motions de renvoi en commission qui
subsistent tombent
la conférence a évoqué également les
rappels au règlement à l'appréciation
bien sûr du président de séance ils ne
devront pas constituer un détournement
de procédures par ailleurs la conférence
et je crois que ça a été partagé à
réaffirmer que notre vivant ensemble
c'est notoriale ne doit pas nous
autoriser ni aux interpellations qui
sont je le rappelle
interdit par notre l'article 36 de notre
règlement comme on l'utilise beaucoup je
voudrais rappeler quelques principes du
vivre ensemble et à nous filmer les uns
les autres à notre insu je rappelle que
voilà je compte sur vous pour assurer
dans le respect des convictions de
chacun jusqu'à la fin de nos débats la
sérénité qui doit être la marque de
notre assemblée voilà les conclusions
mes chers collègues de la Conférence des
Présidents et nous allons passer à
l'examen des amendements quatre
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le premier amendement
porte le numéro 330 8 et il est présenté
par Madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à rétablir la notion de
pénibilité dans la loi en général et
dans les codes de la sécurité sociale et
du travail en particulier
l'ordonnance du 2017 13 89 du 23
septembre 2011 17 a supprimé le terme
pénibilité du Code de travail le
remplaçant par les mots facteurs de
risque professionnel
Suite effectivement aux réserves émises
par les organisations patronales qui ont
voté autour du fait qu'il faut pas
associer travail et pénibilité Emmanuel
Macron lors d'une concertation citoyenne
à l'occasion de son précédent projet de
réforme du système de retraite avait
déclaré qu'il n'adorait pas le mot
pénibilité car ça donne le sentiment que
le travail serait pénible
ce glissement sémantique
monsieur
le ministre n'est pas neutre
Jean Jaurès disait
quand les hommes ne peuvent changer les
choses
ils changent les mots
quand les hommes ne peut changer les
choses il change les mots c'est ce que
vous faites
quand on parle d'usure ce sont les corps
qui s'usent par le travail ce qui
renvoie à une réalité individuelle
constatée apostériori donc curative
alors que quand on parle de pénibilité
ce sont les métiers qui sont pénibles
d'où une présomption d'usure et une
notion préventive
il est d'autant plus urgent que soit
réhabilité cette notion et ne pas
l'escamoter dans le concert d'amatrice
banc de la protection de la santé du
fait de la suppression des CHSCT je ne
doute pas que cet amendement aurait pu
ouvrir un débat sincère
et je sais plus quoi
éclair mais par le 49.3 sénatorial
malheureusement vous nous en empêcher
ensuite qui porte le numéro 2971
rectifié monsieur Cardon le présente
il va être suivi de deux amendements
identiques en même temps
étant donné qu'il n'y a plus de vraiment
de débat mais je vais donc présenter cet
amendement donc c'est un point
d'information c'est amendement visa
réinstaurer la notion de pénibilité dans
la loi sachez qu'en 2017 le gouvernement
a supprimé par ordonnance le compte
personnel de prévention de pénibilité le
C3 P les quatre facteurs de pénibilité
postures pénible manutention manuelle de
charge vibration mécanique agent
chimique dangereux tout ça a été
supprimé la notion de pénibilité au
travail a été supprimée alors comme la
droite est pas très fan des rapports et
des avis
sachez que fin décembre 2022 un rapport
sur la santé au travail publié par la
Cour des comptes exprimée de une ville
déception concernant ces mesures prises
par ordonnance ce même rapport pointe à
l'écoute excessif du patronat qui qui a
conduit justement une dégradation de la
gestion de la pénibilité au travail et
donc une dégradation de la santé des
travailleurs
alors monsieur le ministre pour mettre
en oeuvre des politiques de santé de
travail ça lui a implique donc de nommer
les choses oui monsieur le ministre le
travail peut être pénible et il peut
même altérer la santé des travailleurs
il est donc urgent de réhabiliter la
notion de pénibilité dans la loi et donc
malheureusement comme vous ne l'entendez
pas monsieur ministre et puis on est
contraint par le temps
je vous et je sais que vous avez plutôt
de l'humour et le et un goût profond
pour les mots croisés je vous fais
parvenir une grille de mots croisés pour
faire preuve de pédagogie en espérant en
espérant qu'elle vous fasse réfléchir à
défaut et qu'elle vous fasse tout
simplement revenir et qu'on puisse
réintroduire la mobilité alors si on
commence par le le mot critère supprimé
en 2017 par Emmanuel Macron qui ne sont
pas repris dans votre projet de réforme
impopulaire pénibilité monsieur ministre
donc pour vous occuper pendant les
suspensions de séance je vais vous
l'envoyer puis si certains collègues
parce que premièrement
merci d'amendement 3801 monsieur le Elec
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
souhaitions par cet amendement remplacer
toutes les occurrences du mot
usure par le mot pénibilité qui nous
paraît plus adéquate pour décrire les
modalités de travail de certaines
activités je ne vais pas reprendre
l'étymologie du mot travail tout le
monde sait ici qu'il vient du latin
tripalium et vous irez vérifier plus
amplement évidemment les racines de ce
mot de cette dénomination mais il y a
une réalité mes chers collègues
historiquement dans la question du
travail car le travail ne génère pas
spontanément la joie et l'allégresse
même lorsque le travail que nous faisons
nous plaît
il est plus fort que l'usure il affecte
le physique et le mental et c'est pour
cela que le terme pénibilité est bien
plus adapté le travail ne peut être
uniquement vu comme une activité
sacro-sainte il est primordial d'en
soulever les conséquences et nous avons
besoin de travailler mais pas au prix de
notre santé c'est pourquoi nous
proposions de remplacer le mot usure par
le mot
pénibilité car la pénibilité appelle une
compensation
l'usure n'appelle pas la compensation
mais le remplacement merci de votre
attention
super Nick
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues je vais donc
présenter
l'amendement 4692 qui est à l'initiative
de ma collègue Mélanie Vogel il vise à
spécifier que le fond pour la prévention
de l'usioprofessionnelle pourra financer
les actions de sensibilisation et des
mesures de prévention de l'usure
professionnelle causées ou renforcée par
le changement climatique le changement
climatique a déjà des impacts sur le
monde du travail impact qui ne cesseront
de de s'aggraver alors que le premier
janvier le Président de la République
est modèle Macron s'est demandé qui
aurait bien pu prévoir la crise
climatique je crois que nous devons
prendre les devants et mettre en place
des mesures de prévention permettant de
lutter contre ces effets sur les
travailleuses et travailleurs alors
qu'il faudrait un profond changement
pour adapter le monde du travail et pour
mieux protéger les salariés
cet amendement vise déjà à ce que le
fond pour la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle en tienne compte en
détail il s'agit précisément de
clarifier que les actions de
sensibilisation et prévention du genre
professionnel qui sont financées par le
fond pour la prévention professionnelle
pourront aussi être utilisés pour mener
des actions de sensibilisation et
prévention sur les effets d'usure causés
ou renforcés par les effets des
changements climatiques cet amendement
nous l'avons compris mais je le précise
n'est plus à proprement parler tout à
fait un amendement puisqu'il ne pourra
pas amender la loi puisqu'en vertus de
l'article 44,3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 points alinéa 9 de notre
règlement il ne sera pas soumis à notre
vote unique c'est donc en quelque sorte
pour mémoire que je voulais présenter
afin de préserver si c'est possible un
petit peu de clarté merci alors la vie
sur le rapporteur
de la Commission sur ces quatre
présidents la vie a été défavorable de
la part de la Commission à tous ces
amendements la vie du gouvernement mais
ma vie monsieur le Président merci nous
avons ensuite 6 amendements qui vont
faire l'objet d'une discussion commune
nous commençons par l'amendement 425
monsieur Benarroche merci monsieur le
Président
la question de la santé au travail est
majeur vous le savez la Commission des
accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles la catmp et gouvernée
par les termes le financement de cette
broche de la sécurité sociale s'appuie
sur la cotisation des employeurs
uniquement et ce depuis le compromis
social historique et fondateur de la
branche ATMP entre les partenaires
sociaux et l'État
notre amendement prévoit que les
modalités de fonctionnement du fond et
les conditions dans lesquelles il
finance les actions prévues sont
déterminées par les partenaires sociaux
siègea à la Seat TMP la branche accident
du travail et maladie professionnelle
étant financeuse du fort de prévention
de l'usure professionnelle via une
partie de ces excédents il appartient
aux partenaires sociaux de déterminer
les financements accordés en lien avec
les politiques de prévention primaire de
désinsertion professionnelle et de
maintien en emploi
l'amendement que nous avons déposé sur
ce base sur les travaux de la CFDT vous
savez la CFDT c'est ce syndicat à 6
révolutionnaire qu'il a appuyé le
gouvernement dans sa tentative de
réforme de 2019 après il est sûr que
l'idée du gouvernance paritaire du
respect de certaines équilibre dans la
prise de décision n'est pas forcément
dans l'ADN de ce gouvernement et de son
président pourtant c'est bien cette
parité qui est qui est à la tête de la
brosse à TNT qui par ailleurs est une
broche excédentaire les partenaires
sociaux sont déjà en lien avec la
Direction des Risques Professionnels
garant de l'équilibre financier de la
broche par les actions menées en matière
de prévention et de réparation il paraît
si logique que ceux qui jusqu'à présent
assurent l'équilibre financier de ces
missions puissent prix prioritairement
proposé le montant de la dotation ce
refus de permettre à continuum dans la
vision et la gestion de ces questions
réponses sans doute à un souci de
pragmatisme toujours avancé par le
gouvernement alors madame
Annick billon
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président c'est amendement déposé par
Michel Canevet et défendu je vous
remercie il est défendu et nous
passement à l'amendement 26 38
rectifié madame Ferret merci monsieur le
Président donc c'est amendement porte
sur mon déclinaison on va dire
concrètement de la création du fipu le
fond d'investissement de prévention à
l'usure professionnelle qui n'a qui
n'est pas comparable avec le C DEP nous
l'avons déjà dit et je veux le
réaffirmer à ce moment votre vision
monsieur le ministre avec cette réforme
sur la prise en compte de la pénibilité
est éloignée de la nôtre ce fond créé
permet effectivement de donner quelques
moyens mais totalement insuffisants par
rapport aux conséquences du recul d'âge
notamment pour bon nombre de celles et
ceux qui pourraient bénéficier de cet
accompagnement particulier au titre du
film et insuffisant aussi par rapport au
fait que le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron dès 2017 avait supprimé quatre
critères sur 10 critères de pénibilité
qui sont pourtant essentiels et qui sont
le lot commun le lot quotidien pardon de
bon nombre de nos concitoyens alors avec
cet amendement et bien nous proposons
parce qu'il s'agit là de organiser on va
dire le fonctionnement de ce fond nous
proposons que la Commission est
rappelons que la Commission
ATMP excusez moi qui gouvernait Paris
clairement et le financement de la
branche s'appuie sur la cotisation des
employeurs uniquement c'est ce que l'on
a rappelé alors il est important que on
remette et on préserve ce maintien du
paritarisme également dans ce fond donc
l'amendement prévoit de laisser prieuré
le clairement à la main
de cette commission
la décision du montant des dotations qui
seraient ainsi fixés tout comme la
détermination du fonctionnement du fond
et les conditions dans lesquelles les
actions prévues pourraient être retenues
je veux dire aussi que cet amendement a
été suggéré nous l'avons promis prévu et
nous avons travaillé avec la CFDT parce
que c'est un site que nous avons
souhaité organisé notre travail pour
construire et intervenir à bon escient
pour cette ce projet de loin
l'abonnement 3372 madame pansement
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
amendement travaillé avec la
Confédération française démocratique du
travail
prévoir oui
dans un premier temps de laisser prier
retirement la main à la commission
ATMP pour proposer le montant de la
dotation du futur fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle
la commission ATP ATMP et gouverné par
terrement faut-il le rappeler le
financement de la branche à TMP s'appuie
sur la cotisation des employeurs
uniquement car et cela est issu du
compromis social historique et fondateur
de 1898 de la branche à TMP entre les
partenaires sociaux et l'État donc il
faut respecter ce qu'on a fait quand
même au 19e siècle les partenaires
sociaux en lien avec la Direction des
Risques Professionnels sont garants de
l'équilibre financier de la branche par
les actions menées en matière de
prévention et de réparation
c'est grâce à cette couverture
gouvernance paritaire que la branche
assure donc ses missions et aussi son
équilibre financier
par ailleurs
l'amendement prévoit que les modalités
de fonctionnement du fond et les
conditions dans lesquelles ils financent
les actions prévues sont déterminés par
les partenaires sociaux ces gens à la
commission ATMP la branche ATMP est en
financeur du fond de prévention de
l'usure professionnelle via une partie
de ces excédents il appartient
logiquement aux partenaires sociaux de
déterminer les financements accordés en
lien avec les politiques de prévention
primaire de désinsertion professionnelle
et de maintien en emploi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues alors je
sais pas ce qui est autorisé ou pas par
le 39-3 sénatorial mais j'ai une
question est-ce que au minimum le
ministre répondent je sais que je n'ai
plus le droit ensuite de d'avoir la
parole mais au moins d'avoir la réponse
à la question la première ministre a
annoncé le 10 janvier dernier donc cette
création d'un fond de prévention l'usure
professionnelle et de l'abonder à
hauteur de 1 milliard d'euros évidemment
elle est elle a plutôt raison parce que
allongé la durée légale et à 64 ans va
faire que un certain nombre de personnes
vont être encore plus usés par le
travail qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui et
donc c'est une mesure en quelque sorte
du gouvernement de justice sociale enfin
de justice sociale à leur sauce donc la
question
qui va le gérer parce que en même temps
dans l'annonce il a été dit que on
renvoyait la balle au patronat qui
devait se mettre d'accord avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est pas exactement
le paritarisme et le compromis social
que vient de dire ma collègue pose donc
nous nous posons un amendement parce que
nous souhaitons que si à ce fond d'usure
il puisse être géré de façon paritaire à
égalité entre le patronat et le syndicat
des salariés première question et
quels sont les critères qui vont être
retenus parce que la question de la
pénibilité n'est pas la question l'usure
vous pouvez avoir un travail très
pénible quelque temps mais pas forcément
vous usez sur le long de votre vie et
puis vous pouvez avoir un travail pas
très pénible au quotidien mais qui vous
Use tout au long de votre vie donc on
voudrait aussi savoir c'est ma deuxième
question quels seront les critères et
comment ils seront pris est-ce que par
décret ou pas on aura compris qu'on
n'aura pas le droit nous en tout cas de
donner
il me reste encore 2 secondes je vous
rends la parole monsieur le président
alors madame Pons ces Mons
merci monsieur le président
alors vraiment dans la continuité de mon
collègues communistes le présent
amendement vise
associé les partenaires sociaux à la
définition des moyens alloués au fond de
prévention de la pénibilité monsieur le
rapporteur je vous sais à l'écoute des
partenaires sociaux dont je rappelle qui
sont patronaux certes mais aussi
syndicaux
la Commission des accidents du travail
maladie professionnelle est parfaitement
paritaire avec cinq membres présentant
donc les employeurs et 5 membres
représentant les salariés
et bien entendu tout autant de
suppléance 5 suppléants 5
voilà elle se réunit 10 fois par an
afin de répondre véritablement aux
enjeux au plus proche du terrain les
organisations syndicales et patronales
doivent jouer un rôle primordial dans le
choix des montants alloués assez faux
par ce fond la Commission des accidents
du travail maladie professionnelle peut
alors rendre un avis au gouvernement
chaque année afin d'informer d'indiquer
et fléchir le montant nécessaire au fond
pour répondre au plus près de la réalité
du travail du travail concret pas du
travail prescrit et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut les organisations syndicales il
s'agit ici donc de réinvestir les corps
intermédiaires un peu malmené par depuis
2017 notamment enfin malmener c'est les
syndicats de salariés non écoutez lors
du quinquennat et dont le président
Macron parlait alors d'une forme de
dialogue social nouvelle qu'il allait
amorcer pour ce nouveau mandat voici une
proposition
monsieur le ministre que vous allez
soutenir afin de passer du discours aux
actes alors le vide la commission sur
ces quatre amendements et merci merci
monsieur le Président effectivement nous
avons été dans cette démarche de
consultation des partenaires sociaux qui
doivent jouer le rôle de même que la
Commission ATMP doit jouer son rôle en
ce qui concerne les orientations
également pourquoi pas sur le
fonctionnement mais en ce qui concerne
la gestion en direct du fond c'est un
fond de la CNAM la classe nationale
d'assurance maladie branche ATMP qui le
gère voyez-vous nous plaçons la position
en position plutôt avancée les
partenaires sociaux anticipant les
décisions qui peuvent éventuellement
être pris c'est là que nous avons
l'objet de le sujet de concertation en
ce qui concerne les partenaires sociaux
donc avis
défavorable puisque c'est pas le schéma
que vous nous proposez monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement
il a le même avis que le alors nous
avons 6 amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune d'abord 425
[Musique]
autant pour moi avec deux sous
amendements suite merci monsieur le
président
la conditionner
[Musique]
le investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle à une
concertation préalable avec les
organisations syndicales
représentatives amendement qui est fort
utilement à mes yeux sous amendé par nos
collègues
je crois que le fond en question pose
une première question qui a été
effleurée et que malheureusement
l'utilisation de l'article 44 3 ne va
pas permettre d'approfondir alors
qu'elle est majeure c'est la différence
entre l'usure professionnelle qui est le
propre de salarié qui sont usés par le
travail
qui est très différente à nos yeux de la
pénibilité des métiers qui ce qui est en
quelque sorte intrinsèque un certain
nombre de métiers et qui n'est pas prise
en compte comme nous pensons qu'elle le
devrait et qui va se doute se renforcer
du fait de l'allongement à 64 ans de
l'âge de la retraite l'autre sujet à
aborder nous semble-t-il sur ce fond ce
sont les montants accordés 200 millions
d'euros par an ça n'est pas tout à fait
de nature à engager de véritables et
ambitieuses politiques de prévention
enfin le risque est grand que ce fond
aux entreprises et en particulier alors
direction
a décidé de ce qu'elle considère du
ressort de la prévention qui n'est pas
forcément ce que les salariés eux-mêmes
jugent utile de mettre en œuvre voilà
pourquoi nous pensons que les
organisations syndicales représentatives
doivent être concertés je crois que
c'est encore plus important dans le
contexte que nous vivons aujourd'hui où
je le rappelle l'Inter syndical s'est
adressé de manière très solennelle aux
présidents de la République il n'a
toujours pas reçu de réponse ce qui est
très inquiétant dans le contexte social
que nous vivons merci
mon chat 1580
de nos collègues du groupe communiste
républicains citoyen et écologiste et le
bienvenu
ils vise effectivement je rappelle
l'objet à conditionner le décret
concernant le montant de la dotation de
la branche accident du travail et
maladie professionnelle du régime
général
au futur font professionnels de
prévention
à une concertation préalable avec les
organisations syndicales représentatives
nos collègues communistes seront très
certainement d'accord avec notre
sous-amendement
il s'agit de proposer de renforcer cette
amendement en remplaçant cette
concertation par une négociation
il est vrai que le gouvernement
en général
c'est ce que c'est qu'une concertation
mais rarement une négociation
Hubert tout ça professeur émérite de
psychologie sociale explique
l'étymologie du terme concertation il
faut
cela nous éclaire sur l'objectif visé
une concertation vient du vieux mot
concert accorde de personnes qui
poursuivent le même but
ce concerter s'entendre pour agir de
concert
ce qui apparaît au cœur de la définition
c'est bien l'action collective en vue
d'un accord d'un but commun
quant à la négociation selon ce même
auteur à la différence de la
concertation le conflit est à la source
de la négociation et le pouvoir des
acteurs fait partie intégrante des
processus en jeu dans les laboration
d'une solution
même s'ils ne sont pas radicalement à
bon très bien ben écoutez je vais
conclure
je passe le relais
l'amendement 55581
merci monsieur le Président et donc
Hubert touzar conclut même s'ils ne sont
pas radicalement opposés les objectifs
les intérêts des uns et des autres sont
très différents et ce sont ces
différences qui créent le conflit le
terme concertation je vais essayer de
l'illustrer concrètement il existe ici
deux concerts la majorité sénatoriale le
gouvernement de concert ont décidé ce
matin qu'il n'y aurait plus
véritablement de débats et là
effectivement c'est la même musique même
si cette musique est difficile à
entendre et ne plaider aux oreilles des
Français qui sont dans la rue la
négociation c'est un très joli mot
négociation camarades la négociation
c'est quand effectivement il y a des
intérêts contraires dans la société et
la négociation elle sert à apaiser la
société une société qui ne règle pas les
conflit mais qui en reste à la
concertation entre ceux qui sont
d'accord et qu'une société qui se
fragilise ce que nous vivons depuis
quelques semaines ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui au Sénat ce que nous allons
vivre dans les prochains jours c'est la
fragilisation de la société française et
cette fragilisation cette fracturation
dans un monde en plus particulièrement
difficile aujourd'hui faut-il rappeler
que par ailleurs nous avons la guerre en
Europe et que nous sommes en train de
passer énormément de temps de fracturer
sur 0,5% du PIB je crois monsieur le
ministre qu'il faut que vous nous
expliquiez votre refus de la négociation
votre refus de trouver des compromis
votre refus de respecter les partenaires
sociaux qui t'ont sont un des socles de
la démocratie française et je ne parle
pas du respect du Sénat donc je crois
que ce terme négociation il faut le
remettre au coeur et effectivement
il serait temps que vous entendiez
l'appel des syndicats
alors monsieur le rapporteur voilà on
s'attendait à des débats enflammés à une
suite de rappel au règlement sans doute
dans la droite linée de ce qu'il s'est
passé ce matin et samedi et ce midi
quand lorsque l'on a appris que le
gouvernement allait déclencher l'article
44-3 de la Constitution le vote unique
mieux connu sous le nom de votre bloqué
mais Audrey et bien c'est pas du tout à
ça que l'on assiste cet après-midi on
voit au contraire et bien la gauche qui
est en train de défendre ses amendements
les uns après les autres calmement et
cela alors qu'elle sait d'avance qu'il
ne seront même pas soumis au vote finale
et une petite précision tu as peut-être
que les téléspectateurs l'ont remarqué
depuis la reprise les amendements sont
défendus un à un pendant deux minutes
puis la commission donne son avis sur
ses amendements ensuite c'est au tour du
gouvernement mais il n'y a pas de vote
c'est tout à fait normal nous sommes
dans le de l'article 44 3 qui a été
déclenchée ce matin par le gouvernement
en fait ces amendements qu'on a entendu
être défendus n'ont pas été retenu par
le gouvernement dans le texte final ils
peuvent néanmoins être défendus pendant
2 minutes et c'est le choix qu'on fait
les sénateurs des groupes de gauche
défendre ses amendements restés jusqu'au
bout dans l'hémicycle nous devons bien
ça aux Français à déclarer Patrick
canard le président du groupe socialiste
il restait donc un millier d'amendements
le gouvernement n'en a retenu que 70
mais c'est ce millier d'amendements sera
donc défendu nous nous dirigeons donc
Tam vers une trentaine une trentaine
pardon d'heures de débats encore et oui
encore une trentaine d'heures de débats
le débat n'est pas si écourté que cela
en nous annonce la possibilité de
terminer le tag peut-être dans la nuit
de demain selon le rythme que cela
devrait prendre tout de suite et bien on
continue à suivre les débats dans le
sénateur socialiste Eric kerrouj qui
s'exprime à présent la Constitution en
matière de parlementarisme rationalisé
et ce qui sont ceux du Règlement du
Sénat en faisant ainsi vous avez fait en
sorte que l'ensemble des procédures se
rassemblent pour nous faire taire et
pour nous empêcher d'avoir du poids et
ici nous ne sommes plus aujourd'hui et
les Français vont le voir dans un
Parlement mais dans un théâtre d'ombre
de votre fête elle nous passons à
l'amendement
[Applaudissements]
qui le défend madame pensumonge
oui effectivement je vais le défendre
bien que ce que vient de dire notre
collègue est évident
je vais parler dans le vide et comme de
toute façon il n'y aura pas
d'explication de vote qu'il n'y aura pas
de conflictualité de vote oui de
conflitsualité vous savez ce qui donne
lieu aux négociations justement
bon on se prête à ce jeu de théâtre
d'ombre effectivement que vous nous avez
imposé je le vois pas là
le présent amendement vise à prioriser
les actions en faveur de la prévention
primaire et pourtant vous voyez ce sont
des débats importants des débats auprès
qui importe aux salariés et qui apporte
aux organisations syndicales de salariés
les actions de prévention au travail
souffrent d'une méconnaissance de la
part de nombreuses employeurs c'est un
fait il en résulte dans certains cas une
défaillance dans l'organisation générale
de la prévention parfois jugée par
certains employeurs optionnels bien que
pourtant ils ont l'obligation de
préserver la santé des travailleurs et
puis ils sont résulte aussi une absence
de mesure particulière adaptée aux
situations vécues par les salariés
le rapport de la Cour des comptes pour
améliorer l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de prévention des
risques professionnels mais en lumière
les défauts de l'action publique dans le
champ de la santé au travail monsieur le
ministre selon ce même rapport les
actions de prévention ne font pas partie
du quotidien de tous les salariés et de
nombreuses entreprises reconnaissent ne
pas se sentir impliqué de plus depuis
2013 la fréquence des accidents du
travail ne diminuent plus et le risque
des maladies professionnelles restent
stable alors je conclure
le président merci la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
la commission
n'a pas les actions de prévention parce
qu'on risquerait d'un oublier c'est la
raison pour laquelle je donnerai un avis
défavorable
bien monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie
nous passons à l'amendement 24-27 qui
représente monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est
amendement vise également à préciser les
actions en faveur de la prévention
primaire la santé est au travail est un
enjeu majeur avec Charles Canet près
d'un million d'accidents du travail
comptabilité donc plusieurs centaines
d'accidents mortels et près de 50 000
nouvelles reconnaissances de maladies
professionnelles les actions de
prévention au travail souffrent d'une
méconnaissance de la part de nombreux
employeurs il en résulte dans certains
cas une défaillance dans l'organisation
générale de la prévention parfois jugé
optionnel et l'absence de mesure
particulière adaptée aux situations
vécues par les salariés
le rapport de la Cour des comptes pour
améliorer l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de prévention des
risques professionnels mettent en
lumière les défauts de l'action publique
dans le champ de la santé au travail
selon ce même rapport les actions de
prévention ne font pas partie du
quotidien de tous les salariés et de
nombreuses entreprises reconnaissent ne
pas être impliqués les progrès observés
dans certains secteurs en particulier le
BTP coexiste avec des dégradations
significatives dans d'autres par exemple
ceux du soin et de l'aide à la personne
du nettoyage et de l'intérim
de plus depuis 2013 la fréquence des
accidents du travail ne diminuent plus
et le risque de maladies
professionnelles reste stable les
données disponibles riches et détaillées
permettent à cet égard d'identifier
clairement où se situe les priorités
d'une politique de prévention en termes
de risques
la question du sens et travail et la
question des conditions de travail sont
essentielles et ont toutes leurs places
dans les présentations sur cette loi je
parle bien de présentation car le 49-3
sénatorial nous prive du débat
rapporteur
oui merci même esprit même résultat donc
à visiter favorable
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie ensuite
le demandement 21 33 qui est présenté au
nom de la commission des affaires
sociales par monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre c'est favorable
alors deux amendements
qui
vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune parce qu'ils sont identiques un
amendement 31 13 monsieur Assouline le
présente
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement
vise à ce que en complément du Conseil
national d'orientation des conditions de
travail le Comité national consultatif
des personnes handicapées puissent
également donner un avis sur cette
réforme injuste et injustifiée comme
dans les autres parties de la loi les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
les grandes oubliées et il est
nécessaire que le comité consultatif des
personnes handicapées puissent donner un
avis à femme intégrer les problématiques
particulières qu'il les régissent
l'étude d'impact de cette réforme est
restée confidentielle et les
associations alertent fortement sur les
effets imprévus et négatifs de cette loi
sur les personnes en situation de
handicap quand nous savons que le taux
de pauvreté des retraités en situation
de handicap et de 12,7% en 2022 contre 8
pour la moyenne selon l'adresse nous
sommes en droit de nous inquiéter de
l'impact de votre réforme sur
quand nous savons que l'ancienne
témoigne de l'inscription au chômage des
personnes handicapées de 900 jours
compte 695 jours pour la moyenne
nationale nous sommes en droit de nous
inquiéter de l'impact de cette réforme
sur eux vous avez trop peu pris en
compte dans ce texte les personnes en
situation de handicap il est possible de
rectifier il est possible de donner des
signes en votant cet amendement mais
nous ne pourrons pas avoir le débat sur
cette question car vous avez
décidé à votre bloqué qui évitera que
nous puissions échanger plus de façon
plus approfondie sur ces situations
oubliées dans votre toit
madame présente l'amendement 38 72
oui merci monsieur le Président
la séance car je suis avec le président
du groupe socialiste au Sénat Patrick
Kanner bonjour
Patrick canard et votre réaction bien
sûr au recours à l'article 44-3 de la
Constitution le vote unique ou votre
bloqué vous l'aviez même prédit ce matin
en séance n'était pas une surprise mais
vous dites tout de même que c'est un
coup de force ça reste un coup de force
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
le parlementarisme rationalisé
les deux plus gros si vous les outils de
ce parlementarisme qui vise à empêcher
le débat parlementaire à l'Assemblée ça
s'appelle le 49.3 qui est un vote bloqué
avec engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement donc c'est le texte est
terminé il est considéré comme adopté
ce que j'ai appelé le petit frère chez
nous le 44.3 c'est un vote bloqué qui
permet quand même un petit peu de débat
vous l'avez vu et c'est le cas
actuellement on peut tu vas défendre
nous amendements mais le gouvernement
fait passer son texte et il choisit les
amendements qu'il estime favorable vu de
son point de vue et vous remarquerez que
sur les 70 amendements qui ont été
retenus aucun ne viennent à gauche
mais vous n'avez pas choisi de
multiplier les rappels règlement en
reprenant la séance vous n'avez pas
choisi et bien de faire ce que vous
aviez fait le calmer en quelque sorte
revenus pour quelle raison nous ne
perdons pas de vue que le
rappelleraiment si c'est nécessaire sera
utilisé et nous ne l'avons fait à chaque
fois que parce qu'il y avait eu des
agressions de la part de la droite
sanatoriale potentiellement donc nous
garderons cette outil-là mais nous
voulons montrer en français parce que
nous aurions pu merci mais le retour
d'une logique de boycott en disant
puisqu'il y a plus de débats nous ne
sommes plus dans le débat nous sommes
dans monologue on aurait pu dire bah
écoutez on vous laisse entre vous et
bien cette fois-ci nous avons voulu
montrer aux français et notamment ceux
qui vont défiler demain dans cette
manifestation du 11 mars que nous sommes
toujours à leurs côtés qu'il y a d'un
côté la droite sénatorial et la droite
Elyséenne qui veut du mal aux Français
parce que c'est comme ça que nous nous
l'interprétons travailler des gens de
plus c'est une régression sociale et que
à gauche au Sénat les trois groupes de
gauche socialistes écologistes et
les communistes et bien nous sommes là
pour les défendre jusqu'au bout quel que
soit les mauvaises manœuvres du
gouvernement et de la droite de
sonatoriale l'une des questions qui se
posent c'est effectivement la
mobilisation de demain comme on la rue
va interpréter bien la façon dont ça se
déroule au Sénat alors que on a eu bien
le recours à l'article 38 il y a un
nombre de procédures sur l'article 7
aujourd'hui et bien on a donc la le vote
unique le vote bloqué à la veille de la
manifestation du 11 qu'elle emmené la
signification et qu'est-ce que ça doit
dire à la rue pour vous je pense que la
la rue ils ne font jamais les Français
qui vont les manifestants qui vont
défiler avec leur famille etc parce que
je rappelle que cette réforme va toucher
18 millions de personnes potentiellement
10 millions de personnes qui
appartiennent du 1er septembre c'était
promulgué et bien vont commencer à
réfléchir à travailler 2 ans de plus
dans leur vie active donc c'est
manifestants ils doivent savoir
effectivement qu'il y a eu un choix de
société que je souhaite société nous le
combattons et nous continuerons à le
combattre aujourd'hui la droite
sénatoriale et la droite et l'hygiène
sont peut-être majoritaires dans les
muscles du Sénat mais ils sont
minoritaires dans le pays qu'est-ce qui
va vous rester vous allez parler d'un
recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel de quelle façon et sur
quoi exactement nous on a dénoncé
plusieurs failles je pense dans le
système sanatorial le fait que on
privilégie tel amendement en disant
c'est la commission des affaires
sociales mais elle ne s'est pas réunit
elle ne s'est jamais réunie pendant tout
le débat alors que il de prendre un
quart d'heure de pause pour réunir la
commission de l'affaire sociale donc
nous allons avoir même puisque
effectivement c'est la droite qui était
majoritaire donc il y aura eu un débat
donc nous avons nous allons contester
aussi bien sûr l'utilisation du 47,1
pour un texte qui n'est pas finalement
que budgétaire il est éminemment
politique et nous allons utiliser les
arguments que je ne vous donne pas pour
l'instant parce que bien évidemment vous
avez encore ce sera pour le Conseil
constitutionnel
un mot bien sûr sur aussi la ce que vous
dit la droite la droite qui estime que
vous vous êtes les responsables de cette
situation par l'obstruction que vous
avez manifesté depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte on multipliant des
amendements identiques ou des
amendements que vous ne défendiez pas
mais que vous prenez simplement pour
vraiment prendre la parole sur le texte
qu'est-ce que vous voulez obstruction
c'est d'abord celle du gouvernement
qui utilise un 47 ans qui crée une
limite dans le temps l'obstruction de la
droite sanatoriale en utilisant toutes
les arguments du Règlement du Sénat
c'est tout à fait légal j'ai aucun
problème pour le dire mais tout ceci a
contribué à créer effectivement un
climat qui fait que nous avons riposter
oui nous avons riposter parce que comme
j'ai pu le dire tout à l'heure je crois
dans les musiques nous ne viendrons pas
dans ce débat avec une robe de bure et
la corde au cou nous voulons défendre
nos concitoyens contre cette droite et
contre cette réforme réactionnaire au
final est-ce que vous estimez il y a eu
un débat digne sur la réforme des
retraites pour les Français dans
l'émancipation pas suffisant on aurait
pu aller beaucoup plus loin notamment
sur les articles dit sucrés de la de la
réforme lors de la réforme c'est le
bâton le bâton c'est vous allez
travailler deux ans de plus et je
demande aucun effort au plus riche dans
cette dans ce pays c'est ça le bâton
mais autour de ça il y avait
effectivement des petites sucrettes ici
ou là on aurait pu en débattre beaucoup
plus sur le fond ce sera malheureusement
pas passé c'est mon c'est mon regret
mais globalement cette réforme est
sûrement la plus dure depuis la réforme
Fillon de 2010 merci merci beaucoup
Patrick d'avoir répondu à mes questions
je laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle ou bien
les discussions se poursuivent toujours
autour de l'article 9 l'article sur la
pénibilité alors que c'est maintenant le
rapporteur René Paul Savary qui est en
train de répondre sur les différents
amendements qui ont été présentés
essentiellement pour la gauche Cap
Emploi les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie qui bien sûr peuvent
m'amener une valeur ajoutée mais mais
les services de renseignement en droit
du travail ou même la caisse d'assurance
vieillesse véhicules voyez-vous vous
avez fait une longue liste de
consultations peut-être pour
la volonté commune d'avancer dans le
débat et pouvoir véritablement aborder
les sujets les plus profonds qui
intéressent les français plutôt qu'une
liste longue de consultation nous
pouvons si vous le souhaitez si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à retirer ces amendements
en tout cas avis défavorable pour
l'ensemble merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président sans vouloir
être dans avec l'amendement précédent
c'est un avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons et cette cette refuse en tout
cas sa vie défavorable au fait de lister
tous les organismes d'ailleurs qui
risqueraient de créer une forme de
compétence à contrario vos pour tous les
amendements analogues qui vont venir
merci
l'abonnement suivant qui décline donc
l'Association nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
qui le défend
il est défendu
il est défendu le 3835 qui parle de Cap
emploi chez Julias
non merci monsieur le Président mais
monsieur les ministres chers collègues
j'ai parfaitement entendu votre réponse
monsieur le rapporteur mais je crois que
quand même ça aurait mérité une petite
discussion sur comment on peut organiser
la démocratie sociale il y a beaucoup
d'organismes qui font un travail de
terrain extrêmement important tout à
fait exemplaire et à un moment donné il
faut pouvoir les intégrer par le biais
de la concertation dans l'association à
toutes ces politiques et notamment la
l'amendement que je dépose c'est pour
Cap Emploi Cap Emploi à une mission
extrêmement importante pour les
personnes en situation de handicap il
faut pouvoir les intégrer donc
l'objectif général de nos amendements
c'est comment on peut faire vivre ces
corps intermédiaires et comment on peut
faire vivre la démocratie sociale merci
monsieur le Président il en est pas de
même pour le centre d'animation une
ressource d'information
merci monsieur le Président voilà encore
un débat pas qui serait fort utile à nos
yeux mais que le 44,3 et la brutalité
que de ce qui est infligé aujourd'hui va
nous empêcher de mener on a eu un débat
à l'initiative de notre collègue ça vole
des lits sur l'extrême pénibilité du
travail des égoutiers sur leur taux de
mortalité excessivement élevé et sur les
écarts considérables d'espérance de vie
qu'ils ont avec les autres salariés et à
l'occasion de se débat qui s'était
engagé et qui malheureusement a été
stoppé le ministre Guérini nous a dit
que parmi les pistes qu'il envisageait
d'explorer il y avait la piste donc
d'une exposition moins longue de ces
égoutiers
à leur condition de travail ce qu'il
traduisait par du temps partiel chacun
imagine ce qui reste de revenu à un
égoutier qui est travail à temps partiel
il nous a aussi dit que une autre piste
consistait en la réorientation
professionnelle donc avec des formations
qui vont avec ce qui valide la
proposition que nous voulons faire que
les centres d'animation de ressources
d'information sur la formation soit
consultée sur les orientations
stratégiques du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle et permet toi
permettez-moi monsieur le rapporteur qui
avait indiqué que vous pensiez que la
concertation était utile mais qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire de la mettre dans
la loi que ce que nous vivons
précisément actuellement montre qu'il
faudrait donner des garanties et donner
des garanties de concertation à
l'ensemble des corps intermédiaires et
des organisations syndicales qui
aujourd'hui souffre justement que leur
avis ne soit absolument pas entendu vous
nous avez aussi proposé de retirer ces
amendements dois-je vous rappeler que
vous les avez balayés merci pour les
chambres de commerce et d'industries
monsieur Bocquet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues on ne peut ignorer dans ce
débat la pénibilité du travail pas plus
que le rôle des chambres de découvert
cette industrie effectivement et en
particulier leur place d'importance dans
la formation via leur gestion des
centres de formation des apprentis vous
le savez nous ne sommes pas favorables à
ces multiplications de petits gages que
vous feignez d'accorder aux Français aux
françaises en échange de la privation de
deux ans de retraite mais votre passage
en force est en stylé nous vous
proposons d'associer des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie aux orientations
stratégiques du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure comme vous
dites nous savons que les jeunes voire
très jeunes travailleurs et travailleurs
sont sur représentés en matière
d'accident du travail et le seront
encore plus à l'avenir la loi de Madame
Pénicaud ajustement nommé choisir son
avenir professionnel à amoindri la
protection des apprentis en ouvrant la
possibilité d'une extension des horaires
de travail dans les secteurs déjà
extrêmement occidentogène 27% d'entre
elles et travaillent dans deux des cinq
domaines les plus exposés aux produits
chimiques le BTP et la mécanique et
travail des métaux en 19 se sont ainsi
10300 1 actions de travail qui ont été
recensés parmi les apprentis il et elle
subit 50% des accidents de travail des
salariés de moins de 20 ans il est
accumule les difficultés liées à l'orage
et à leur place dans l'entreprise
faisant de le dernier maillon le plus
corvéable le plus sensible ainsi aussi
au chantage eu égard à leur contrat qui
peut être rompu plus facilement et qui
engagent leurs études d'après la DARES
en 2013 leur place induit que les
activités confié aux apprentis comme le
nettoyage de zone en poussières ou de
dégraissage de pièces sont souvent à
risque merci pour les Chambres
d'agriculture ce bagi merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre le fond
que vous souhaitez créer a pour mission
de participer au financement par les
employeurs d'action de sensibilisation
et de prévention d'actions de formation
mentionnées à l'article
l6323-6 du code du travail et d'action
de reconversion une prévention de la
désinsertion professionnelle à des
salariés particulièrement exposés aux
manutention manuels de charge à des
postures pénibles définies comme
position forcées des articulations et à
des vibrations mécaniques les
agriculteurs sont la troisième
profession la plus touchée par la
pénibilité au travail après les
travailleurs et les travailleuses de la
construction et de l'industrie
manufacturière et extractive elle et ils
sont particulièrement imposés exposées
pardon et contraintes physiques marquées
au quotidien 79% portent des charges
lourdes 76% restent debout régulièrement
toute la journée 76% encore font des
mouvements douloureux et 76% sont
exposés à des vibrations par ailleurs
elle est du travail dans un
environnement physique particulièrement
agressif 74% sont exposées à des agents
chimiques dangereux 80% des fumées et
des poussières c'est un métier difficile
mais absolument nécessaire pour notre
quotidien or pour assurer une
utilisation efficace des financements du
fonds d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle il
est important de s'assurer que les
orientations stratégiques de ce fond
nouvellement créé soit en adéquation
avec les réalités du terrain et les
habitudes de ces travailleuses et
travailleurs de la terre qui exerce leur
métier avec passion certes mais aussi
avec beaucoup de souffrance je vous
remercie merci
les chambres de métiers de l'artisanat
judiciana dans la consultation sur les
orientations stratégiques du fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle la dotation de 1
milliard d'euros à destination de la
prévention concernant concerne des
casiers comme les contraintes physiques
marquées des environnements physiques
agressifs certains rythmes de travail
etc la diversité de ces situations
gagneraient être fléchées par les CMA
des structures qui sont reconnues comme
expertes des métiers manuels acteurs
clés de la formation est solidement créé
sur nos territoires il s'agit de
s'assurer que cette enveloppe de 1
milliard sur le quinquennat soit 250
millions d'euros par an soit fléchés
vers des projets adéquats aux métiers de
l'artisanat et qu'elle ne servent pas à
financer des opérations cosmétiques
comme de simples compagnons de
communication du type d'affichage dans
les usines ou la mise en place de
dispositifs de sécurité inapplicable en
pratique par les travailleurs par
exemple au vu de leurs cadence enfin
nous rappelons que si ce projet a le
mérite d'investir dans participation
afin de garantir la santé des actifs
malgré de fortes protections certains
métiers restent malgré tout pénibles
c'est constat appel à la réintroduction
de critères de pénibilité supprimer en
2017 pour rappel l'exposition a des
agents chimiques dangereux la
manutention manuelle de charge les
postures pénibles et les vibrations
mécaniques afin de véritablement
améliorer les conditions de travail des
salariés en prenant en compte et
reconnaissant en conclusion
professionnelle et puisque mon
amendement n'aura pas de suite dans
notre pays je voudrais rappeler parce
que ça me paraît important que c'est pas
moins de 3 millions de salariés qui sont
exposés à un ou plusieurs agents
chimiques cancérigènes près de 11
millions subissent des contraintes
physiques marquées 4 millions de travail
dans un environnement agressif près de 5
millions de rythmes de travail pour
conclure et près d'un salarié sur 10
travail de nuit
pour les directions départementales de
l'emploi du travail et des solidarités
monsieur laelec merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues et je suis avec le sénateur
écologiste d'Ille-et-Vilaine Daniel
salmon bonjour bonjour Daniel salmon
votre réaction déjà au recours à
l'article 44-3 de la Constitution qui
nous mène à la situation que nous voyons
en ce moment c'est-à-dire que la gauche
est en train de présenter c'est
amendement alors qu'il y a absolument
aucune chance pour qu'il y ait même ne
serait-ce qu'un vote dessus
je ne pensais pas arriver dans cette
situation je viens de défendre
anamendement j'appelle ça défende c'est
plutôt présenté je viens de présenter un
amendement parce que il n'y aura pas de
vote sur cet amendement donc on parle là
c'est vraiment un message qu'on envoie
aux Français on n'a pas voulu quitter
l'hémicycle parce qu'on pense que notre
place de parlementaire malgré tout reste
là
d'entre nous seront présents sur la
mobilisation demain mais nous restons
mobilisés là parce que nous voulons
prouver que les Solidaris que l'on
appelle ce que la droite veut appeler de
l'obstruction n'en est pas nous avons
des amendements qui sont construits qui
sont complètement en lien avec les
articles et qui apporte au débat ce
débat on essaye de nous confisquer
justement la droite a estimait que vous
aviez fait de l'obstruction assez ski
l'amener à utiliser bien les articles 38
par exemple ou à réécrire entièrement
une partie de la l'article 7 afin de
faire tomber 1000 amendements que vous
aviez que vous que vous aviez écrit que
lui répondez-vous lorsqu'elle vous dit
c'est vous qui avez commencé avec votre
obstruction
écoutez pour la refaire le film très
rapidement vous voyez ce projet de loi
qui arrive dans le cadre d'un PLFSS
rectificatif déjà là les dés sont pipés
un projet de loi de cette ampleur ça
mérite une loi à part entière et surtout
pas un PLFSS rectificatif ensuite le
gouvernement des gagne le 47 1 dans ce
cas ça veut dire temps contraint allez
on réduit encore le débat et puis là on
a bien vu qu'il y avait une stratégie
sénatoriale pour faire en sorte que
coûte que coûte ce soit voté avant
dimanche
voyez le coûte que coûte qu'employé
Macron et bien la droite sénatoriale se
les complètement approprié pour corseter
pour empêcher le débat effectivement
nous on a eu des réactions
professionnelles parce que face à une
stratégie il y a il y en a une autre
nous avions anticipé un certain nombre
de choses on ne pensait pas qu'il
déléguerait le 44 3 aussi rapidement
mais voilà nous sommes plutôt pour ce
week-end
que s'est-il passé selon vous on a vu ce
matin une demi-heure de débats sur la
pénibilité et c'est vrai que le débat a
ensuite vrillé est devenu un débat sur
les conditions du débat on a vu le
climat extrêmement inflammable de très
très compliqué dans les relations entre
la droite et la gauche nous on peut dire
que jusqu'à mardi ce que l'on avait
prévu on voulait étudier l'article 7 le
7 ça c'est plutôt passé correctement là
on était dans un vrai un vrai débat
serein respectueux au sein du Sénat
et puis le mardi soir voilà les choses
se sont déjà en venimeux
depuis on ne voit que de la stratégie
c'est à dire que la droite déplace des
amendements mais des priorités pour
faire tomber nos amendements enfin voilà
on voit bien on voit bien qu'ils ne
veulent plus débattre et qui veulent
avancer et vous le déplorez bien sûr
la droite et le gouvernement disent eux
leur objectif c'est de pouvoir avoir un
vote dimanche et on n'y serait pas
arrivé si on avait continué au rythme
auquel on était jusque là et qu'il
fallait avoir ce vote vous pouviez vous
que vous allez pouvoir vous prononcer
contre ce texte mais qu'il faut pouvoir
avoir un vote dimanche alors ça c'est
sur le principe c'est leur vision qu'on
allait pas y arriver on était à
l'article 7 le 7 il nous restait 13
articles à voir normalement au rythme où
on allait ça devait très bien se faire
simplement on aurait pu continuer bien
entendu
simplement avec ces stratégies
d'obstruction qu'ils ont mis en place
parce que l'obstruction vient de leur
place de leur de leur côté travail et
bien on a ça nous a amené à faire une
contrefosie au contre-offensive si on
veut parler dans ces termes-là et à
remettre des sous amendements et à
partir de là effectivement les choses se
sont on va dire en venimer et on a
vraiment eu de camps qui n'arrivaient
plus à se parler est-ce que vous estimez
ce débat aura été suffisant pour les
pour les Français qui en ont besoin il y
a pas eu de débat à l'Assemblée
nationale on peut le dire
arrêtez bien avant l'article 7 là au
Sénat on voit que c'est quand même
vraiment devenu très très compliqué au
final il y aura-t-il eu un vrai débat
parlementaire sur cette réforme des
retraites qui en a quand même besoin
écoutez c'est clairement dramatique pour
la démocratie pour Olivier du socle
lorsqu'on a posé la motion référendaire
à dis Non Non mais attaque de loi comme
ça ça ne peut pas être oui ou non ça
doit évoluer avec le Parlement c'est une
belle reconnaissance du Parlement et
c'était une belle reconnaissance déjà
que leur loi n'était pas aboutie
clairement
et bien là on a fait tout le contraire
on a fait tout le contraire et on prive
les Français et bien d'un véritable
débat et effectivement le rôle du
Parlement c'est bien d'amander et
d'essayer d'améliorer la loi nous nous
apportions beaucoup de d'articles
d'amendements de suppression bien
entendu parce que pour bien montrer nos
propositions à ce projet de loi unique
et qui arrive on ne sait trop pour qui
et pourquoi puisqu'il n'y a pas
d'urgence mais nous avions des
amendements qu'on appelle des
amendements de repli pour améliorer
chacun de ces articles qui auraient dont
certains d'ailleurs ont été votés très
rarement mais dans la première partie on
a eu quelques amendements qui sont qui
sont passés on a eu des moments
où on a retrouvé le Sénat le vrai Sénat
celui qui discute celui qui avance mais
depuis un certain temps depuis quelques
heures d'ailleurs et bien là il y a plus
de débats pour la suite ça
c'est quand même une séquence très forte
très blessantes assez mortifères quand
même pour le débat et le Sénat qui a
toujours eu une toute autre image en
ressortir forcément à moins de riz et
altérer et ce n'est pas du tout ce que
nous voulions pour cette institution que
nous que nous apprécions
d'avoir répondu à mes questions un
retour au débat dans l'hémicycle c'est
la Centris communiste Céline Brulin qui
s'exprime à présent peuvent être aux
côtés du Conseil d'orientation des
conditions de travail un acteur clé pour
que les orientations du fond soient les
mieux calibrés par rapport aux besoins
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues c'est
en effet un amendement d'appels sur les
missions locales pour l'insertion
professionnelle et sociale des jeunes et
je me permets ici de présenter mon
activité de conseiller départemental de
Bagneux je connais parfaitement ce le
travail que font ces missions locales et
notamment dans le cadre de la prévention
des des problèmes liés à la santé au
travail je pense qu'il faut trouver une
solution alors peut-être que celle-là
est pas la bonne les monsieur Miss il
faut trouver une solution pour leur
redonner des moyens et surtout de
l'importance dans le travail qui font
pour sensibiliser les jeunes à tous les
les risques qui sont liés pour leur
santé dans le domaine du travail merci
monsieur le président
Pôle emploi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre fait assez incroyable de ce
projet de réforme il introduit un fond
pour lutter contre un phénomène qu'il va
lui-même provoquer et aggravé se font
c'est celui qui financera des actions de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle si
votre projet de réforme réussit son
passage en force c'est tout de même
assez cynique reconnaissez-le vous
rajoutez au minimum deux ans aux
professions aux travailleuses et aux
travailleurs qui se cassent le dos au
quotidien où il cumul trouble
musculo-squelettique geste répétitif et
posture statique le cocktail passait un
certain âge peut infliger au corps des
dégâts irréversibles qui sont le
résultat d’années passés au travail
parfois des décennies mais pas de
panique le gouvernement a prévu la
solution 1 milliard d'euros il faudra
faire deux ans de plus dans ces mêmes
conditions ça fera mal au dos au genou
aux cervicales au doigt aux mains mais
il y aura un fonds de prévention de
l'usure quel soulagement il faut être
sérieux à l'instant vous pourrez mettre
les milliards que vous voudrez dans un
fond le problème
dans les corps et dans les esprits qui
n'en peuvent plus qui ne pourront pas
supporter deux ans de plus et vous le
verrez très rapidement cela étant dit le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste ne fera jamais obstacle à des
actions de prévention je souligne
simplement ici une certaine incohérence
chercher à prévenir des effets que l'on
a créé soi-même ce n'est probablement
pas le moyen le plus efficace de
répondre à un problème nous vous
demandons toutefois l'association aussi
de Pôle emploi à la définition des
orientations stratégiques de ce fond je
vous remercie merci le service de
renseignement droit du travail c'est
évoqué le président notre amendement
visa approfondie à les missions du faux
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle que vous
souhaitez créer en associant notamment
le service de renseignement en droit du
travail ce sera un premier gage de prise
en compte du droit du travail pour
éviter que ce fond ne soit dévoyé pour
finalement devenir une forme de gadget
de plus qui remplirait vos campagnes de
communication
les services de renseignement ont droit
du travail sont joignables autant par
les salariés que par les employeurs et
ils font preuve d'une neutralité propre
à tous les services publics leur mission
peut aussi être d'assurer le respect de
la protection des salariés en les
informant des droits en matière de
protection justement pour éviter ou du
moins pour limiter l'usure
professionnelle comme on l'appelle
désormais en ce qui concerne ce fond on
investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle comment
pourra-t-il être pertinent s'il ne se
préoccupe pas de l'existant et de la vie
de celle et de ceux qui côtoient au
quotidien la réalité des salariés et des
employeurs
France compétences
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues l'article 9 prétend
améliorer la prise en compte voilà la
sérénité est apparemment revenu dans
l'hémicycle où on voit qu'elle est
parlementaires de gauche pour
l'essentiel présenté Lisa après les
autres leurs amendements plutôt dans le
cas mais on entend parfois prendre et
bien le mécontentement de certains par
rapport à cette procédure qui fait que
et bien avec la l'article 44-3-2 la
Constitution et bien les sénateurs
présentent dans un moment mais il n'y
aura pas de vote dessus
Eric et rouge le sénateur socialiste a
même parlé tout à l'heure de théâtre
d'ombre et Audrey et bien il a même
aussi dans d'autres rangs de la gauche
certains qui se sont pleins de la
situation et qui ont à la fois parlé du
fond noir amendement et de cet article
de la Constitution qui les contraintes
vous l'avez précisé les sénateurs de
gauche ça s'enchaîne à tour de rôle pour
présenter leurs en ce moment c'est le
groupe communiste qui présente ses
amendements Anna pendant deux minutes et
ce même si c'est même amendements n'ont
pas été retenus par le gouvernement pour
figurer dans le vote final nous voulons
informer les Français leur montrer les
sujets sur lesquels nous aurions pu
débattre et sur lesquels nous ne
débattrons pas à ton pied entendre dans
l'hémicycle la gauche qui se défendent
avoir voulu faire de l'obstruction et
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
présente ses amendements pour montrer
qu'il y avait du fond c'est aussi ce
qu'on a entendu dans l'hémicycle même si
en filigrane on entend aussi dans
quelques prises de parole une critique
assez forte de l'utilisation de
l'article 44-3 par le gouvernement
écouté
voilà encore
d'une personnalité morale et de loi et
financier la brutalité de ce qui est
infligée aujourd'hui va nous empêcher de
mener on a eu un débat à l'initiative de
notre collègue ça vole d'Élie sur
l'extrême pénibilité du travail des
égoutiers
sur leur taux de mortalité excessivement
élevé et sur les écarts considérables
d'espérance de vie qu'ils ont avec les
autres salariés et à l'occasion de ce
débat qui s'était engagé et qui
malheureusement a été stoppé le ministre
Guérini nous a dit que parmi les pistes
qu'il envisageait d'explorer il y avait
la piste donc d'une exposition moins
longue de ces égoutiers
à leur condition de travail
comme il reste encore un millier
d'amendements à défendre les débats
devraient donc jurer jusqu'à demain
grande journée de mobilisation et c'est
aussi l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
la gauche reste dans l'hémicycle elle
veut montrer aux manifestants qu'elle
reste mobilisées elles aussi dans
l'hémicycle merci merci beaucoup Audrey
effectivement une trentaine d'heures de
débats et désormais on nous parle plutôt
du coup d'une fin pour dimanche donc
c'était bien la date qui était prévue
initialement comme quoi l'article 44-3
de la Constitution et bien ne raccourcis
pas tant que cela les débats mais en
revanche et bien il n'y aura pas de vote
sur eh bien la majeure partie la grande
l'extrême majorité de ces amendements
tout de suite et bien on reprend la
direction de l'hémicycle ou
un marché vient est en train de nous
donner de l'enfoncer de l'âge la parole
à Madame Cohen sénatrice communiste
mais chacun d'abord mais
je le redis devant vous monsieur le
Président j'aurais vraiment souhaité que
le ministre quand il a fait il a dégainé
le 44,3
avec donc le vote unique et le choix de
70 amendements il est fait en votre
présence voilà je vous le dis et vous
savez que nous avons des opinions
divergentes et des analyses divergentes
mais le moindre des choses c'est le
respect du Parlement et de l'institution
et je dis pas y compris au nom de
Monsieur du stop mais aussi à son
collègue qui est très silencieux qui
s'occupe des relations avec le Parlement
qui vient de temps en temps s'asseoir et
qui est d'un mutisme remarquable cela
étant dit j'en viens à l'amendement
avant de me faire gronder
cet amendement prévoit la consultation
du conseil national de politique de
lutte contre les pauvreté l'exclusion
sur les orientations stratégiques du
fonds d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
dans un délai de six mois suivant la
promulgation de cette loi ce conseil
national de la lutte contre les pauvreté
exclusion sociale et de fait charger
d'assister le gouvernement
par ses avis sur toutes les questions de
portée générale qui concernent la lutte
contre la pauvreté question qui nous
préoccupe quand même et de l'exclusion
sociale par des études et la formulation
des propositions donc son approche et
son expertise y compris qui est souvent
reconnu par les assemblées
parlementaires mais aussi par les
collectivités territoriales et j'irai
même dire par aussi la puissance
d'analyse qu'on des personnes morales
qui sont des personnes morales de droit
public ou de droit privé je pense qu'on
ne peut pas se priver cette expertise
voilà donc je demande évidemment que cet
amendement comme tous les autres
amendements soit pas balayés par un avis
défavorable tous azimut voiture balais
et rentrer chez vous d'accord allez
merci
le Défenseur des droits
merci monsieur le Président non c'est
juste pour bien comprendre parce que là
on n'est pas en discussion commune
monsieur le Président il me semble pas
nous avons eu la vie de la tout à
l'heure mais poursuivez d'accord non non
non non
mais c'était pour je savais que
attendez c'est moi c'est moi si si non
non
c'est sur les missions du Défenseur des
droits donc c'est moi face aux
difficultés que pour rencontrer un
usager avec une administration ou un
service public le Défenseur des droits
et les personnes à mieux comprendre
leurs droits et les oreillons dans leur
démarche en ce sens compte tenu de la
complexité des dispositifs et des règles
de droits le Défenseur des droits est en
mesure de veiller à ce que rien
n'empêche les usagers de bénéficier
pleinement de leurs droits encore plus
dans le cas de ce fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention et l'usure
professionnelle qui pour le moment pose
plus de questions qu'il apporte de
réponse concrètes aux salariés face à la
pénibilité de leur travail sur quelle à
l'année analyse repose la création de ce
fond et surtout son abonnement d'un
montant de 1 milliard d'euros sur cinq
ans quel objectif concret se donnera ce
fond d'investissement
s'agit s'agit-il d'une extension du
Front national de prévention de la
Caisse des dépôts ou d'un fond annexe
ces questions sont pour l'instant au
suspens la prévention l'usure
professionnelle figure déjà au cœur de
l'axe stratégique 2 du plan santé au
travail adopté pour la période 2021-2025
si certains progrès techniques
permettent effectivement d'améliorer les
conditions de travail il reste loin de
résoudre le problème je vous remercie
la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse des travailleurs salariés
même quand il voyait
bon toute façon vous inquiétez pas
monsieur le Président on va faire un duo
ça va très bien se passer donc
mon collègue Fabien gay vient de
défendre le 38 74 je défends le 38 69 et
tout va bien donc enfin c'est un moment
nous visons à ce que le Haut Conseil de
la famille de l'enfance et de l'âge soit
consulté sur les orientations
stratégiques du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle dans un délai de six
mois suivant la promulgation de la
présente loi en effet nous savons que
cette loi aura un impact social massif
pour les travailleurs et les
travailleuses de notre pays des ouvriers
des ouvrières seront impactés dans leur
vie professionnelle par l'usure
quotidienne de leur corps cela faisant
suite à des travaux pénibles et
répétitifs il convient donc chers
collègues de pouvoir mesurer d'ici 6
mois l'impact terrible pour des millions
de nos concitoyens et concitoyens de ces
décisions prises parfois dans des salons
dorés de la République loin du quotidien
de ces mêmes millions de Français et
français qui seront eux victimes de
cette loi dans leur quotidien il est
impératif monsieur le ministre de
pouvoir mesurer l'impact de faire
travailler deux années de plus
l'ensemble des travailleurs et des
travailleurs c'est ce que nous proposons
avec cet amendement car de nombreuses
études ont démontré l'usure des corps au
travail est déjà forte à 62 ans et le
sera encore plus à 64 ans les
conséquences seront nombreuses parmi
lesquelles pour certaines et certains
une incapacité totale de travail ce qui
augmentera les besoins financiers de la
sécurité sociale un nouvel exemple
monsieur le ministre et mes chers
collègues de droite puisque vos projets
sont identiques qui démontent combien
cette réforme est
inutile et particulièrement dangereuse
je vous remercie
38 77 puisque
faut que vous regardiez en même temps
que moi 38 77 Monsieur laelec Merci
monsieur le Président agricole très bien
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
qu'il me soit permis tout d'abord de
saluer ici
l'engagement exemplaire est particulier
qui est celui des mutualités sociales
agricoles tant en matière de diagnostic
d'accompagnement des mutualistes et ici
devant notre Haute Assemblée peut-être
avons-nous une raison supplémentaire de
souligner encore plus le rôle de cette
MSA
il est bon également de rappeler que
dans le monde agricole la notion de
pénibilité du travail
est plus prégnante et plus spécifiques
encore que dans bien d'autres
professions qu'on soit éleveur c'est
réalisé viticulteurs arboriculteurs et
donc parfois aussi exposé à l'usage de
pesticides le métier d'agriculteur est
un métier exposé à une forme
particulière de pénibilité et il est
donc légitime et bien que les situations
spécifiques qui en découlent puissent
être complètement appréciée
alors la MRC intervient en outre pour la
santé et la sécurité au travail des
exploitants salariés employeur et chef
d'entreprises agricoles et l'agit pour
améliorer les conditions de travail et
prévenir les risques en agriculture et
de ce fait de mieux placer la MSA dans
le rôle de concertation et d'association
à la décision ne serait que légitime
merci monsieur le Président
l'Association générale des institutions
bretonnes des cadres
monsieur gay alors c'est Monsieur
Président c'est moi qui me suis trompé
donc je m'en excuse auprès de ma
collègue tout à l'heure donc celui-là il
est défendu voilà très bien
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
on en a beaucoup parlé du corps
monsieur Bocquet oui merci monsieur le
Président la rédaction actuelle de
l'article 9 évoque la possibilité pour
les branches professionnelles d'établir
des listes de métiers ou d'activités
particulièrement exposées à la
pénibilité et aux risques professionnels
l'attention est certes loi mais sans
caractère obligatoire et sans agenda
nous craignons que cette bonne volonté
ne reste un peu pieux c'est le sens de
cette amendement donné six mois aux
branches professionnelles pour établir
ces listes la seule possibilité offerte
n'a aucune valeur contraignante depuis
la loi el khomri les branches
professionnelles ont acquis une place
prépondérante dans l'organisation du
travail et du droit des travailleurs il
est donc selon nous légitime qu'elle se
saisisse de façon paritaire de cette
problématique les branches
professionnelles négocient les
conventions collectives et les accords
collectifs qui sont applicables salariés
qu'elles regroupe c'est donc selon nous
l'échelons essentiel pour promouvoir
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
le comité suivi des retraites monsieur
Julias
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre c'est le Président j'ai un
petit regret c'est dommage qu'on vote
plus parce que la gauche est largement
majoritaire là on aurait pu faire passer
des amendements c'est dommage oui donc
bien évidemment le comité de suivi des
retraites il est fondamental dans
dans le dispositif actuel donc c'est
pour ça que nous nous demandons qui soit
consultés de façon institutionnelle
structurelle parce qu'il est au coeur de
la présente-toi je remercie monsieur le
Président
1897 le fond de solidarité vieille
merci merci monsieur le Président
200 millions d'euros donc par année
alors que 97% des 25 millions de
travailleurs sont exposés à plusieurs
risques au 31 décembre 2019 le secteur
des transports et de l'entreposage
employés un million 426000 salariés hors
intérim dans ce secteur 94% 95% des
maladies professionnelles sont des TMS
plus de 860 000 jours d'arrêt de travail
des salariés sont déposés par des
travailleurs exposés chaque année ce
sont donc
147 euros par travailleur promis aux
entreprises si chaque année l'ensemble
du fond elle est intégralement à ce
secteur qui ne représente que 12% de
l'emploi tertiaire marchand nous voulons
bien que vous payez avec des mots à des
fautes payer des solutions aux
travailleurs qui ont dos cassé mais ne
nous demand pas de soutenir ce fond j'en
reviens très spécifiquement à l'objet de
cet amendement qui propose que le fond
de solidarité vieillesse souhaite
associé aux orientations du fond d'usure
professionnelle c'est assez simple parce
que 61% des salariés qui sont au minimum
vieillesse la SPA ou l'ASV sont partis
pour inaptitude ou invalidité ils sont
donc trois fois plus que ceux qui ont
des pensions de droit commun c'est
travailleurs sont pleinement concernés
même sur représentés face aux risques de
pénibilité et d'usure professionnelle
pour rappel l'usure professionnelle est
un processus d'altération de la santé du
fait de l'exposition à des contraintes
de travail physique
cognitives durant le parcours
professionnel dès lors que le fond de
solidarité vieillesse dispose d'une
connaissance fine de ces pensionnés et
donc de ces travailleuses et
travailleurs en fait carrière notamment
qui se rapproche de ses services il
apparaît nécessaire de l'associer aux
orientations stratégiques du fond
d'usure mais pour réserve des retraites
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bon il y a un truc qu'on sait
tous c'est qu'on va augmenter le temps
de travail hebdomadaire
on va augmenter le temps de travail
nécessaire pour obtenir le droit au
chômage et on va et on va allonger
seulement deux ans allez hop le droit à
la retraite bon en gros allez pour
parler simple offensif travailler plus
pour produire plus et surtout qu'on
s'aimait plus en dehors évidemment d'un
productivisme dépassé point de salut
alors aujourd'hui je nous pensons que
nous la réforme est à rebours les
employeurs vont exiger une disponibilité
permanente on va avoir un élargissement
des amplitudes horaires étendues un
travail de nuit les week-ends
la cotisation des employeurs alors il a
ils ont été totalement absents nos
débats alors là les employeurs pour le
lendemain de faire un effort absent
depuis jeudi dernier mais bon allez
comment on va alimenter la branche
accident travail et maladie
professionnelle de la sécurité sociale
quand on regarde les chiffres vous nous
dites un milliard d'euros attendez pas
pour l'année 2023 un milliard d'euros
d'ici 2027 ça veut dire 250 millions par
an c'est largement inférieur à ce que va
coûter le relèvement de l'âge légal de
départ la retraite de 62 à 64 ans en
rente d'invilliers on rentre
d'invalidité et là c'est pas le groupe
communiste qui dit ça mes chers
collègues et ça ça mérite débat j'ai les
chiffres c'est l'adresse il va y avoir
250 millions on nous dit un milliard et
l'adresse nous dit à minima 1,8
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires
voilà ce qui va se passer réellement on
va laisser combien de jeunes combien de
gens sur la touche combien de gens
écartés donc les dépenses de prévention
vont être inférieures à la réparation
pénibilité et je vous le dis mes chers
collègues vous l'avez voté mais le CDI
va accélérer cette difficulté
la caisse de prévisions c'est de
retraite de la SNCF monsieur Laennec
il est défendu
il est défendu la cage de retraite du
personnel de la région autonome des
transports parisiens un brûlant merci
monsieur le Président c'est amendement
vise à prévoir la consultation
obligatoire de la caisse de retraite du
personnel de la RATP concernant les
orientations stratégiques du fond
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle vous connaissez
les critiques que nous perd que nous
portons depuis quelques instants
maintenant à l'insuffisance de ce fond
sur le financement et les montants qui
lui seront affectés comme sur la
démarche vous savez aussi que nous
reconsidérons qu'en repoussant l'âge
légal à 64 ans le gouvernement génère
infiniment plus d'usure professionnelle
nous nous appelons ça et nous
continuerons d'appeler ça la pénibilité
pour les raisons que là aussi nous avons
évoqué qu'il ne pourra en compenser à
posteriorer avec ce dispositif Pascal ça
vole des vies vient de le montrer
efficacement
outre notre désaccord de principe nous
considérons essentiels que ce fond soit
géré démocratiquement en associant
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés la
caisse de retraite du personnel de la
RATP qui gère aujourd'hui et qui
continuera à gérer demain les carrières
les départs en retraite et les pensions
de dizaines de milliers de travailleurs
du secteur des transports étant ce sens
incontournable c'est pourquoi nous
présentons cet amendement
l'établissement national des invalides
de la marine
très grand département côtier avec
Bobigny plage Aubervilliers plage
La Courneuve Flage on vous invitera cet
été avec la présidente assassin à venir
découvrir
nos plages
cet amendement de repli vise à prévoir
la consultation de l'établissement
national des Invalides la marine sur les
orientations stratégiques du fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle dans un délai de
six mois suivant la promulgation de la
loi pourquoi on demande ça un des
métiers les plus accidentogènes c'est
celui de marin est-ce que vous savez sur
les à peu près 38 900 marins c'est 42
accidents sur 1000 marins donc il y a
une vraie question autour de ce métier
et tant d'autres que nous venons de dire
mais nous pensons qu'au minimum seront
ces questions là sur les marins ils
doivent
être associés sur cette question de
prévention des risques des usures et je
vous repose la question monsieur le
ministre il va falloir un minimum un
moment donné je ne sais pas quand on
viendra le temps de la réponse de la
Commission du rapporteur et de vous-même
mais nous répondre sur les critères
parce que je vous le redis la pénibilité
n'est pas l'usure
la pénibilité n'est pas l'usure mais
c'est un métier extrêmement pénible
marin et qui use très rapidement puisque
là vous savez que aussi l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé et moindre pour un
marin que pour un ouvrier ou un salarié
en moyenne je vous remercie monsieur le
Président la Caisse nationale des
industries électriques et gazières
il est défendu
il est défendu non il faut suivre
moi je suis
madame Cohen
les critères de pénibilité et vous voyez
moi c'est des critères pour descendre là
des
IEG est plus importantes que celles du
régime général en ce sens la suppression
des régimes spéciaux va à rebours
complet de la reconnaissance de la
pénibilité dans ce secteur et remet en
cause l'attractivité des métiers
pourtant aujourd'hui en manque chronique
de personnel ce que vous remettez en
cause avec la fin des régimes spéciaux
voté à l'article 1 c'est bien la
pénibilité de certains postes on a parlé
le problème des astreinte travail de
nuit charge lourde environnement de
travail bruyant risque de contracter des
maladies professionnelles nous vous
parlons d'efforts physiques importants
de posture non naturelle et pénible
comme par exemple l'ascension de support
sans nacelle le port et ou la
manipulation de charge lourdes le tirage
de câbles
et tout ça se fait dans un espace clos à
des températures souvent extrêmes un
travail donc difficile manuel et
contraint exposé aussi
intempéries et voici quelques-uns des
exemples et j'aurais pu continuer ma
liste n'est pas exhaustive bref ce que
vous détruisez c'est bien la juste
contribution sociale due aux agents qui
assure le service public de l'énergie
365 jours par an 24 heures sur 24 par
tous les temps pour la nation et les
usagers c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons
que la consultation de la Caisse
nationale des industries électriques et
gazières sur les orientations
stratégiques du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle que les syndicalistes
préfèrent appeler pénibilité dans un
délai de six mois suivant la
promulgation de la présente loi donc se
fasse tel est l'objet de notre
amendement je vous remercie merci la
Caisse d'Assurance vieillir ces maladies
des cultes
monsieur zoulias
merci monsieur le Président de le faire
donc il s'agit de mes chers collègues il
s'agit de la quasimak donc la caisse
d'assurance vieillesse et maladie des
cultes c'est une c'est une caisse très
intéressante je pense qu'il faut que
vous soyez attentif parce que les
pensions gérées par cette DS par cette
caisse sont les plus basses de France
entre 387 euros et 697 euros ce sont les
pensions les plus basses de France par
ailleurs la quasimac c'est 100 millions
de déficit tous les ans pourquoi parce
qu'il y a 38 000 bénéficiaires et
aujourd'hui 19000 cotisants il y a deux
bénéficiaires pour un seul cotisant
aujourd'hui elle est largement
déficitaire et pourquoi elle subsiste
encore parce que la solidarité nationale
s'exerce à son profit et que l'équilibre
financier de la quasimaque et assuré par
une compensation générale ce qui ne pose
aucun problème et bien au contraire je
trouve que c'est tout à fait naturel
mais Mac montre bien que là le problème
structurel du déficit de ces caisses ne
sera pas réglé par cette réforme il y a
un déficit structurel et malheureusement
les ministres du culte il s'arrêtent pas
62 ans ils vont largement au-delà à 70
voire beaucoup plus donc le problème
structurel de financement de cette
caisse va subsister après votre effort
je pense que c'est vraiment un exemple
intéressant sur lequel il faudra revenir
quand notre hémicycle sera un peu plus
intéressé par la question merci monsieur
le Président et la Caisse des dépôts est
consignation
la meilleure santé clic là on y va
si monsieur le Président cet article 9
créé un fond spécifique pour l'usure
professionnelle nous déposons cet
amendement pour comprendre
l'articulation finalement du fond
d'usure avec le compte personnel gérer
lui-même par la Caisse des Dépôts ce
fond d'usure servirait par exemple à
financer France compétences au titre des
financements de projet de reconversion
professionnelle
c'est incompréhensible d'ajouter des
nouveaux fonds à France compétences qui
de tout évidence ne fonctionne pas je
cite le titre des échos du 7 novembre
2022 qui disait que France compétence le
très coûteux en même temps du
gouvernement et pour cause entre 2020 et
2022 inclus France compétences aura
cumulé 11,2 milliards d'euros de déficit
monsieur le ministre pourquoi invoquer
une nouvelle recette en trompe l'oeil
pour France compétences quel est
l'article l'action entre le CPF et les
crédits du d'usure à France compétences
au titre de la reconversion tout cela ne
nous paraît pour l'heure pas vraiment
très clair plus largement nous nous
demandons de là de ces prérogatives
comment va fonctionner le fond pour le
moment le fonctionnement du fond les
conditions de sa participation
financière et ses modalités de gestion
et d'affectation de ces ressources sont
renvoyées à un décret en Conseil d'État
nous demandons des précisions car nous
pensons que ce fond est une diversion
pour éviter que le débat sur le retrait
des quatre critères de pénibilité décidé
sous le précédent quand quinquennat soit
réouvert je vous remercie le Conseil
Économique Social est environnemental
ce ministre mes chers collègues avec le
cesé nous avons une instance unique en
son genre de par sa pluralité d'acteurs
qui la composent et de par la qualité de
ses travaux cette instance nous le
savons à l'avantage de ne pas être aux
ordres de l'exécutif
le saiser et après l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat de la troisième assemblée
cité dans la Constitution il assure le
lien entre les pouvoirs publics et nous
les citoyens sa mission est de
conseiller le gouvernement et le
Parlement dans l'élaboration des lois et
des politiques publiques plus récemment
c'est aussi devenu la chambre de la
participation citoyenne il est le trait
d'union entre les pouvoirs publics et la
société ce sont des femmes et des hommes
de terrain qui travaillent dans des
entreprises des syndicats des
organisations patronales aussi des
associations des ONG et ils sont ce
conseil il accueille 175 conseillères et
conseillers
je pense qu'il est très utile pour le
gouvernement d'écouter ses avis et je me
permettrai de dire d'ailleurs que vous
allez être contraint de recevoir leur
avis puisque la pétition contre votre
réforme des retraites un thème plus d'un
million de signataires quand il en faut
seulement 150 000 pour saisir le saiser
merci au conseil à l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes oui merci monsieur
le Président la consultation du Haut
Conseil et l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes sur les orientations
stratégiques du fond on investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle et un élément crucial
pour garantir l'égalité entre les sexes
dans le domaine de la santé au travail
en effet il est incontestable que les
femmes sont souvent plus exposées que
les hommes au risque professionnels liés
d'une part à la précarité de l'emploi
elle a discrimination sexiste et aux
violences sexuelles et sexistes y
compris c'est pourquoi il est selon nous
plus que nécessaire que le Haut Conseil
à l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes soient consultés pour assurer que
les orientations stratégiques du fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle prenne en compte
les besoins spécifiques des femmes en
matière de santé et de sécurité au
travail
j'avais compris monsieur le rapporteur
que vous aviez donné un avis général sur
l'ensemble de ces amendements nous nous
confirmer il est défavorable et vous en
avez donné les motifs le gouvernement le
confirme bien nous passons ensuite un
amendement à l'article 9 qui porte le
numéro 2134 il est présenté par Monsieur
Savary au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le président
coordination
c'est un amendement de coordination
ensuite un amendement 429 monsieur
benaroche le présente
le président monsieur le ministre
nous l'avons dit depuis tout à l'heure
la pénibilité au travail aurait dû être
le sujet central ou un sujet central de
ce projet de loi gouvernement a décidé
de nicoter que seul article et encore
largement est suffisant et là je vais
sur le folle largement édulcorer en
utilisant le terme d'usure
professionnelle avec toutes les
différences d'acceptations qu'a expliqué
tout à l'heure ma collègue vraiment de
passer pourtant
la question de la PAX sanitaire négative
du travail aurait dû être pris en compte
vous ne souhaitez peut-être pas
l'entendre venant de nous vous
n'acceptez pas vraisemblablement de
l'entendre tout simplement venant des
syndicats de travailleurs alors je vous
dis monsieur le ministre soyez attentifs
au moins au collectif des responsables
de la société française de travail
et bien la gauche qui présente ces
amendements les uns après les autres des
amendements qu'elle peut présenter mais
sur laquelle il n'y aura pas de vote car
ils n'ont pas été retenus par le
gouvernement mais il y a aussi quelques
amendements qui au contraire ont été
retenus par le gouvernement et qui sont
présentés cet après-midi Audrey oui et
ce sera dans les toutes prochaines
minutes on va assister sûrement un
changement de rythme car on va arriver à
des amendements qui ont été retenus dans
le vote final par le gouvernement
notamment l'un de la commission des
affaires sociales qui évoquent la
création d'un nouveau fond
d'investissement pour la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle amendement
amender justement par le gouvernement
qui précise qu'il veut laisser le soin
aux partenaires sociaux de fixer
l'orientation de ce fond et qu'il ne
souhaite pas restreindre les entreprises
qui pourraient bénéficier de ce fond
vous voyez des amendements qui
figureront normalement dans le vote
final
merci merci beaucoup Audrey on va être
donc être attentif à ses amendements qui
vont être présentés amendement de René
Paul Savary donc sous amender par le
gouvernement et donc premièrement qui
serait étudié et adopter sans doute à la
fin de ce texte ce Président nous
pensions que l'intention de l'église
législateur sera respectée donc avis
défavorable par rapport à cette
proposition
je vais la roche le 427
bien sûr je vais le présenter monsieur
le Président mais j'en profite suite au
repas ce que je viens d'avoir sur 400
mètres je ne peux pas répondre puisque
les formes de de processus que vous avez
adopté gouvernement à majorité ensemble
nous empêche en fait à la fois d'avoir
un débat sur nos propositions je vous le
fais remarquer sur amis de droite qui
absorbent absolument pas de
l'obstruction au débat mais qui sont un
enrichissement de scoré dû être l'autre
débat et en plus de toute façon on
pourra pas les voter puisque vous avez
décidé quand de votre épingle donc
l'idée bas ni votre nous sommes dans un
effet de leur nous sommes dans un effet
de trompe l'oeil comme on le dit
c'est-à-dire en nous présente un
magnifique gâteau mais en fait derrière
il s'agit peut-être de d'une soupe à la
grimace donc en ce qui concerne
l'explication de vote sur enfin
l'explication de votre la défense de cet
amendement 427 je dirais simplement que
l'efforts qui sont prévus ne financeront
des actions de prévention à destination
des salariés exposés à moins seulement
de trois critères de pénibilité
uniquement cela manutention manuelle de
charge
vibration mécanique et donc les 10
facteurs existants par ailleurs
l'exposition des agences civiques
dangereux le travail en équipe
successives alternante l'exposition au
bruit les températures extrêmes ou
d'autres d'ailleurs comme la pénibilité
psychique qui a été demandé par la CAF
CGC ne sont pas pris en compte là encore
aussi le gouvernement aurait pu
réintégrer les quatre critères de
pénibilité supprimés en 2017 par les
ordonnances médicaux mais il est clair
que d'un point de vue général ce
gouvernement poste toujours faire mieux
que les autres pourtant l'écoute et le
dialogue avec les institutions devraient
rester des passages obligés pour arriver
à des dispositifs équilibrés juste et
acceptables le président semble avoir
dit en disant que en fait ils
recevraient pas les syndicats tant que
la période parlementaire serait pas
terminé en fait la période par le
volontaire elle est terminée chers amis
donc je pense que le président va
décider de recevoir les syndicats
puisqu'elle est terminée ça aura au
moins servi à ça peut-être
les décisions que vous avez prises à
faire que le président reçoivent les
syndicats plus rapidement merci
l'abonnement 427 monsieur président
Gontard 4680
et la vie de la commission oui
il y a la vie de la Commission et il
sera défavorable notamment parce que
nous pensions qu'il va y avoir une
négociation nationale
interprofessionnelle donc c'est pas
nécessaire que cette négociation soit
réunie pour les décrets nous pensons
qu'elle a un rôle beaucoup plus utile
que ça à ce moment là je voudrais vous
faire une précision que les choses
soient claires revenant aux agents
chimiques nous ne les avons pas rajouté
dans le C2P nous les avons
ouvert à la prévention par le biais du
fipu et notamment pour prendre en compte
ceux qui sont exposés à la fois des
troubles ergonomiques et à des
expositions agents chimiques c'est la
cohérence qui nous a conduit à fait de
cette proposition mais il faut bien
dissucocier cela donc avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre même avis que la
Commission alors nous passons maintenant
à l'avendement
4680 monsieur le Président guitare
merci monsieur le Président donc comme
je le disais cette amendement du groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire a
été travaillé par ma collègue Mélanie
fagel vise à assurer une perspective
genre et des listes de métiers ou
d'activités exposaient à des facteurs de
risque professionnel dressés par les
branches Emmanuel Macron déclaré qu'il
n'aimait pas le terme de pénibilité du
travail parce que ça donnait le
sentiment que le travail serait pénible
minimiser la pénibilité du travail et
dangereux car cela induit aussi de
minimiser les risques auxquels les
travailleuses et les travailleurs sont
exposés au lieu de rendre le travail
plus dangereux il faut qu'on protège
davantage les travailleuses et les
travailleurs cette protection passe
aussi par une prise en compte du fait
que les risques sont genre c'est
précisément l'objectif de cet amendement
qui vise à assurer que les listes de
métiers ou d'activités exposées à des
facteurs de risque professionnel dressés
par les branches prennent en compte ces
risques différenciés par le genre la
nécessité de cette prise en compte
découle en première ligne de la
ségrégation Jean persistante des
professions les femmes exercent souvent
des professions intermédiaires sont
davantage au contact du public par
exemple dans les soins médicaux et
paramédicaux où la prise en charge des
enfants des aides à domicile et des
assistantes et assistants maternelles
des aides-soignantes et aide-soignants
des infirmières et infirmiers et des
enseignantes et enseignants dans ce
cadre s'inscrivent des constats
préoccupants de riches professionnelles
pour les femmes les femmes sont
surexposées aux troubles
muscosquelettiques car parmi les cas
reconnus cumulant un certain nombre de
facteurs de risque de TMS dans leur
travail se trouvent 58% des femmes de
plus les femmes sont plus fréquemment
exposées à certains facteurs de risque
psychosociaux elles sont plus nombreuses
à subir de pression et à devoir se
dépêcher elle manque d'autonomie et de
marge de manœuvre enfin 33% des flammes
déclarent de voir cacher leur émotion ou
faire semblant d'être de bonne humeur
contre 22% des hommes pour ces raisons
il convient d'intégrer une perspective
genrée de la pénibilité point de départ
pour assurer une meilleure prise en
compte des métiers souvent exercés par
des femmes un amendement important qui
est là ce ne pourra pas être ni discuté
ni voté
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur des favorable parce que nous
pensons qu'il faut prendre l'exposition
aux risques qu'elle est traitée de façon
identique ce soit des hommes ou des
femmes en tout cas merci d'avoir exposé
la pénibilité particulière pour les
femmes nous y avons également réfléchi
sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'était
favorable pour une raison un peu
différente celle évoquée par Monsieur
rapporteur nous considérons qu'il n'y a
pas lieu de l'inscrire dans la loi dès
lors que les critères de mesure de la
pénibilité et la déclinaison au-delà de
ce qui est déjà inscrit sur les quelques
items des indicateurs pénibilités
relèvent du dialogue social et des
branches les branches sont habitude
montent beaucoup de branches de gens
examiner
un amendement et 3 sous amendements qui
vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune d'abord un amendement présenté
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur
cet amendement prévoit que les carsats
interviendront en identifiant les
entreprises auxquelles pourront être
allouées les ressources de ce fond
d'investissement de plus il élargit le
champ des destinataires des ressources
du fond aux institutions concombres à
l'organisation de la prévention afin de
pouvoir y inclure des acteurs tels que
l'anacle ou le réseau des Arabes
la vie du gouvernement
alors je vais d'abord voir les sous
abondants pardonnez-moi non non
celui du gouvernement merci Michel
Président c'est un amendement de
précision rédactionnel le gouvernement
considère que la clarification du champ
apporté par la commission est utile et
propose simplement cette pression
rédactionnelle
et un sous-amendement que présente
monsieur Fernique et merci monsieur le
Président je suis particulièrement
heureux de présenter surtout ces
amendements puisque dans cette morne
phase de de vacuité parlementaire
engendré par le 49-3 de la Constitution
et le 42 9 de notre règlement et bien
c'est un moment précieux puisque ce sous
amendement et oui figure dans la fameuse
lipste des amendements et sous
amendements acceptés par le gouvernement
et donc je suis ravi de vous le
présenter il propose que les fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention
levure professionnelle puisse bénéficier
à d'autres entreprises que celles
identifiées par les CARSAT donc
l'amendement visa agrandir le périmètre
des entreprises pouvant bénéficier des
financements du fond et en permettant
ainsi de laisser les partenaires sociaux
au partenaires sociaux la liberté de
fixer les orientations du fond par
ailleurs cette amendement propose que le
fond puisse également financer les
organismes de prévention de branche qui
ont conventionné avec des organismes
nationaux de prévention en effet les
organismes de prévention par branche
sont spécialisées dans leur domaine
d'activité ce qui leur permet de fournir
des conseils et des formations adaptées
aux risques et aux enjeux spécifiques à
chaque profession voilà je crois vous
avoir expliqué ce qu'il fallait savoir
pour que vous puissiez voter en
connaissance de cause si vous le
souhaitez sur ce sous amendement qui
figure dans la liste
relevant du vote unique
5741 monsieur Fichet
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
voilà sous amendement qui aurait pu
assez rapidement obtenir un vote
consensuel mais voilà votre refus du
débat nous prive d'un vote important en
effet ce sous amendement c'est
amendement propose que les fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle puisse
bénéficier à d'autres entreprises que
c'est identifiées par les carsattes
l'amendement visa agrandir le périmètre
des entreprises pouvant bénéficier de
financement du fond en permettant ainsi
de laisser les partenaires sociaux la
liberté de fixer les orientations du
fond par ailleurs cet amendement propose
que le fond puisse également financer
les organismes de prévention de branches
qui ont conventionné avec des organismes
nationaux de prévention en effet les
organismes de prévention par branche
sont spécialisés dans leur domaine
d'activité ce qui leur permet de fournir
des conseils et des formations adaptées
aux risques et aux enjeux spécifiques à
chaque profession les organismes de
prévention par branche ont également une
meilleure compréhension des pratiques et
des évolutions de chaque secteur ainsi
que des contraintes auxquelles ils sont
confrontés il peut donc proposer des
solutions pratiques et adaptées aux
réalités de chaque branche ce qui peut
améliorer leur acceptabilité et leur
efficacité
permettre de les financer directement
permet d'agir au plus près du terrain je
vous remercie merci alors l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
commençons par le sous amendement du
Gouvernement à vie favorable ou
sous-emmenons du gouvernement voilà donc
favorable aux autres pour les autres
sous abondements
il me paraissent identique mais la
Commission n'a pas eu le temps des
examiner parce qu'ils étaient très loin
je viens des sont
identiques
la Commission a suivi les propositions
de du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président sur les sous
amendements dans la mesure où
dans la mesure où le 54 96 57 41 sont
identiques à l'amendement du
Gouvernement par construction bien
évidemment la vie est favorable ainsi
que sur le 21 36 comme sur le rapporteur
merci
sont identiques les autres
ensuite un amendement de Monsieur Savary
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales
le numéro 2135 monsieur le président
la vie du gouvernement
merci un amendement de 21 37
rédactionnel le gouvernement favorable
ensuite à l'amendement 2104 rectifiés le
président requier le présente oui merci
monsieur le Président de monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'était
l'avant de lambiothèque qui vise à
intégrer les travailleurs indépendants
dans les dispositifs de prévention et de
réparation de l'usure professionnelle
elle parle notamment aux professionnels
de santé libéraux qui connaissent aussi
leur dire professionnelle et appelle
tout leurre des mécanismes de
compensation plusieurs études font état
de niveau de pénibilité physique et
psychologique importante il y a
notamment aux impératifs du mode libéral
et de la participation au service de
santé publique qui sont plus nombreux
que moyenne nationale à mettre en avant
la pénibilité physique de leur métier
jusqu'à 70% des infirmiers et 50% des
kinés ils révèle aussi un peu important
d'hyperfraisses de Berlan notamment ses
infirmiers il y a une charge mentale
importante le manque de temps et la
difficulté à conseiller vie personnelle
et vie professionnelle aussi les
proposer ici de permettre aux
travailleurs nos salariés de financer
leur affiliation grand service de
prévention et le santé au travail grâce
au fond d'investissement prévu à
l'article 9
sur salle bon pour le alors l'avis de la
commission d'abord
merci monsieur le Président pour
l'instant le fipu effectivement n'est
pas ouvert au profession indépendantes
puisqu'ils ne le cotise pas à la branche
ATMP donc avis défavorable et on verra
ensuite l'avenir je suis le ministre
même ma vie monsieur salon
merci merci monsieur le Président le
présente amendement seulement présenté
mais n'ont voté à cause du 49-3
sénatoriales vise à mettre en place des
modalités de contrôle de l'utilisation
de ce fonds de prévention de la
pénibilité à ce sujet la cour des
contrats dans son rapport sur les
politiques publiques de prévention en
santé au travail dans les entreprises
que les enveloppes budgétaires
consacrées aux différents programmes et
consommer très tôt dans l'année au fil
de la demande de facto un budget
constant cela ne permet pas d'assurer
que ce sont des entreprises qui en ont
le plus besoin qui en bénéficient à la
différence d'un appel à projet la cour
incite par ailleurs à mettre en oeuvre
sans tarder un programme de contrôle du
respect par les employeurs de leurs
obligations relatives en matière de
prévention de la pénibilité ces
modalités sont définies par le décret en
Conseil d'État aussi il est important
que l'utilisation par les entreprises
des moyens à louer dans le cadre de ce
fond face l'objet d'un contrôle afin de
s'assurer qu'ils ont bien été utilisés
conformément à leur objet initial
vous le savez chers collègues la Cour
des comptes multiplie les études et les
alertes sur de nombreux pans des
politiques publiques de ce gouvernement
mais ici comme ailleurs et je pense aux
questions de rénovation thermique nous
constatons des fins de non-recevoir on
pourrait parler de politique de
l'autruche mais je voudrais profiter de
cet instant pour réhabiliter pour
réhabiliter ce brave animal qui
contrairement à ce gouvernement ne
s'enfuit pas la tête dans le sable
si la vie de la Commission
pensons qu'il est effectivement
important de définir des modalités de
d'utilisation des ressources de FIP
humain mais il en existe déjà c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons pensé
que cette précision n'était pas utile à
être inscrit directement dans la loi
donc avis défavorable mais ma vie
un amendement qui porte ensuite
le numéro
3525 qui le présente Madame pour simonge
ou monsieur benaroche
madame ponce
oui merci monsieur le Président le
président amendement vise à mettre en
place des modalités de supervision de
l'utilisation du fond de prévention de
la pénibilité dont on discutons à
l'instant ces modalités sont définies
par décret en Conseil d'État il est
important que l'utilisation par les
entreprises des moyens alloués dans le
cadre de ce fond fasse l'objet d'une
supervision avant de s'assurer qu'ils
ont été bien été utilisés conformément à
leur objet initial
d'autant que nous avons voté avec
enthousiasme hier que les risques
chimiques faisaient partie avec les
trois risques
ergonomiques des risques pouvant donner
lieu à pouvant mobiliser le fond et
donner lieu donc à des actions de
prévention
ce risque vous les laviez exclu ce
risque chimique des agents chimiques
vous l'aviez exclu du C2P sous des
prétextes de la difficulté à les suivre
à les évaluer nous pensons que c'est
possible nous et qu'il convient donc de
superviser l'utilisation de ce fond de
prévention de la pénibilité notamment
concernant ces risques chimiques si peu
considérer
j'en profite pour rappeler que les
Françaises ne doivent rien comprendre à
ce qui est au facteur de pénibilité qui
sont qui sont dans le C2P à ceux qui
peuvent mobiliser les actions de
prévention du fond du fonds de
prévention de la pénibilité donc
effectivement il y en a un qui a
désormais quatre facteurs mais ces
quatre facteurs sont pas dans le C2P et
le CDP en ont 6 mais le CDP n'est pas
éligible au fond donc je renouvelle que
il faut clarifier tout ça il faut un peu
de transparence et mettre les 10 dans
les deux dans le C2P et dans le fond
merci
l'amendement la vie de la commission
avis
défavorisons quelques instants c'est
débats car je suis avec le sénateur
socialiste de la SAM Rémi Cardon bonjour
votre réaction à la façon dont se
déroule les débat des débats très calmes
comme si on avait mis presque un nez de
Redon sur et bien toute la colère
pourtant ce qu'on a ressenti ce matin
après le déclenchement de l'article 44-3
de la Constitution le vote unique ou
votre bloqué alors déjà je vais
peut-être vous reprendre je n'ai plus un
débat puisque un débat normalement il y
a une contradiction donc là on présente
les amants on fait une présentation un
point d'information d'un amendement
qu'on devait défendre à la base mais
depuis la l'activation du 44-3 ça nous a
ça nous oblige en tout cas à présenter
un amendement et de de pas offrir en
tout cas à la fois des rêves parfois des
réponses parce que le gouvernement ne
répond pas forcément à nos questions
mais leur importance comme le rapporteur
qui qui propose du temps c'est
défavorable et puis
emballer c'est peser quoi donc si vous
voulez là c'est un peu dérangeant parce
que on va tenir jusqu'à dimanche 23h59
vous avez choisi pas boycotter et de
rester je pense que c'est un moment
important il y a une mobilisation quand
même dans la rue demain après-midi à 14h
donc moi je pense que au bout d'un
moment nous on a de notre responsabilité
de jouer le jeu de d'opposants dans un
esprit plutôt voilà assez calme apaisé
en débutant un centre d'amendement et de
d'essayer de provoquer en tout cas un
débat et bon apparemment en face il ne
veut pas de débat parce que ils activent
moi ce que je retiens quand même dans
tout ça c'est que on est au début
c'était effectivement il y avait des
histoires de mots croisés pour Monsieur
du soft maintenant c'est des procédures
croisées c'est-à-dire qu'on croise avec
des articles de la Constitution et du
Règlement du Sénat donc c'est
malheureusement dommageable deux frères
ça comme débat aux Français oui c'est ça
que vous retenez aussi de cette séquence
c'est pour vous je connaissais pas grand
chose du règlement en termes de
d'articles
les grands classiques mais là non on en
a même découvert la couleur ce livre
vert que l'on a vu actuellement
il y avait essentiellement jean-Pierre
Sueur qui avait l'art d'utiliser le
règlement du Sénat parfois mais comme il
connaît lui-même les articles en réalité
il avait pas besoin de sortir le le le
règlement donc si vous voulez si on au
moins on a appris des choses dans ce
débat même si je pense que on devait
offrir plutôt un débat de fond plutôt
qu'un débat de procédure qui a été lancé
par les LR et le gouvernement alors le
LR bien sûr disque bien c'est
l'obstruction de la gauche qui les a
amenés et bien à dégainer ses armes de
la procédure parlementaire la gauche qui
avait aussi multiplié les amendements
identiques des amendements de
suppression tous tous les mêmes par
exemple ce genre de choses est-ce que
vous est-ce que vous n'avez pas poussé
le bouchon un petit peu loin aussi non
je pense pas je pense surtout qu'ils ont
paniqué en fait ils ont paniqué quand
vous voyez quand on change les règles du
jeu à chaque fois c'est qu'on ne sait
même plus comment faire
enfin c'est ce que j'ai remarqué je
disais d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours
sur sur l'antenne public que j'ai
l'impression qu'il paniquait à vouloir
changer les règles tout le temps avoir
créé un amendement de du rapporteur la
commission pour nous faire sauter nous
amendements etc
on le rappelle avec
l'article 7 qui a fait tomber à peu près
1000 amendements de la gauche et qui
donc amené notamment au début
le problème numéro 1 quand même c'est
l'article 47-1 lancé par le gouvernement
je pense que on impose aux Français
travailler deux ans de plus est-ce que
pourquoi le gouvernement nous impose de
travailler en quelques jours un texte
d'une importance primordiale pour les
français pour la vie des français on
voit à votre opposition inquiet toujours
là mais ce que l'on voit aussi bien
c'est que le texte d'évidence il va il
va avancer ici il va finir par être
adopté on a déjà une commission mixte
paritaire conclusive c'est quand même
vraiment compliqué pour la pour la
gauche sur cette c'est que la
responsabilité de faire ça entre copains
parce que pour l'instant là moi
la majorité sénatoriale avec le
gouvernement entre copains en tout cas
on a vu des sanitaires très drôles ou
discuter il faut quand même la
présidence de la président du Sénat qui
devait être impartial et descendu pour
discuter pour les aménagements donc si
vous voulez on tout ça et gérer un peu
lamentable maintenant ce qui va se
passer c'est qu'effectivement ils vont
décider l'avenir des Français sur la
réforme des retraites à quelques-uns
dans une CMP entre quelques sénateurs et
quelques députés
vous estimez moi je trouve ça
absurde parce que c'est des millions
français qui sont touchés et ce sont
quelques sénateurs et députés
donc moins de 15 que qui vont devoirs
qui vont décider en fait Rémi Cardon
c'est quelque chose de très fréquent que
les textes parviennent à un accord
finalement en commission mixte paritaire
ça c'est pas du tout
vous estimez que tous ces textes là et
bien ces problématiques que ça se
termine en CMP non c'est pas
problématique mais ce qui problématique
c'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on vit
actuellement
c'est qu'en fait il y a pas de débat le
gouvernement a décidé d'arrêter le débat
avec cet article 44-
les seuls peut-être sur la mobilisation
quand même que l'on attend demain qui
sera que l'on attend demain donc samedi
et puis on aura aussi une d'ailleurs le
jour de la Commission à mixte paritaire
mercredi prochain qu'est-ce que vous
dites aux manifestants depuis le Sénat
aujourd'hui de non lâche rien pour aller
jusqu'au bout de ce texte et je leur
demande effectivement d'en faire autant
et je pense je suis convaincu qu'ils
arrivent en faire autant et qu'il faut
maintenant amplifier le mouvement il
faut passer un autre cap il faut
dépasser les 4 millions de Françaises et
de Français qui seront dans la rue pour
dire non à cette réforme
Rémi Cardon d'avoir répondu à mes
questions rejoins et bien tout de suite
l'hémicycle ou c'est Laurence Cohen qui
est en train de s'exprimer avec
pertinence quand on parle d'usure au
travail on pense souvent aux salariés
exposés aux intempéries à des produits
dangereux des travailleurs et des
travailleurs qui doivent assumer des
charges lourdes nous en avons beaucoup
parlé ici au niveau du groupe communiste
républicain vous voyez un écologiste
mais il existe aussi d'autres catégories
qui sont impactées auxquelles on ne
pense pas obligatoirement de la même
façon je veux parler des cadres eux
aussi avec les nouvelles méthodes de
management connaissent l'usure au
travail eux aussi et elles aussi
d'ailleurs sont confrontées à l'absence
de perspective ou de reconnaissance
professionnelle au manque d'autonomie il
est elles sont souvent les premiers les
premières à être exposées au facteurs de
risque psychosociaux la moitié des
cadres affirme avoir fait un burn out
dans leur vie voilà pourquoi nous
demandons par cet amendement que
l'association pour l'emploi des cadres
puis cette consulté avant qu'un décret
ne précise le fonctionnement de ce fond
d'investissement cela nous semble être
la moindre des choses que les
représentants des principaux intéressés
soient sollicités pour nous c'est un
gage de réussite pour ce fond mais je
dis bien pour nous puisque on voit bien
que ici la représentation parlementaire
quand elle est dans l'opposition et bien
maltraitée qu'on n'a pas envie non plus
de nous solliciter
merci la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur
3904 monsieur le rapporteur
sur la vie de l'association pour
l'emploi des cadres
oui 3904
sur le rapporteur
nous pensons que ce ne sont pas des
instances consultatives de la tech il a
que c'est le même que même
à vie du gouvernement
identique
ensuite je vais passer à l'examen d'un
amendement et de deux sous amendements
qui vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune un amendement pour chacun repère
bien qu'il porte le numéro
3907 et Madame varias le présente
merci monsieur le Président
je souhaite appeler en préambule que
l'employeur en ce qui concerne la santé
la sécurité au travail à une obligation
de résultats nous avons parfois pris
l'habitude de parler de prévention comme
d'un synonyme de bonne posture de
dispositifs situés à la marche du
travail de petits ajustements or le
concept de prévention désigne
précisément la prévention primaire qui
vise à supprimer et j'insiste supprimer
la source du risque voir la réduire la
prévention secondaire qui vise à réduire
les atteintes aux individus exposés
enfin la prévention tertiaire curative
qui vise à réduire l'impact consécutif à
une exposition
c'est pour ça que c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous parlons bien ici de
révolutionner l'ensemble de notre
appareil productif nous parlons de
révolution organisation orgasme
organisationnel autant que matériel la
réforme des retraites de 2010 à
inévitablement conduit à des dépenses en
hausse de l'ordre de 1,8 milliards
d'après la direction de la recherche des
études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques 1,2 milliards pour les
pensions d'invalidité 600 millions pour
la vie du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques du 18 janvier 2023 qui
soutient que votre réforme n'entraînera
qu'un coup caché si l'on peut dire de
400 millions d'euros nous jugeons cette
réforme d'une violence inouïe elle le
sera d'autant plus que les dispositifs
que vous proposez comme des garde-fous
ou des solutions à même d'apporter des
de régler des problèmes dont vous êtes
responsables apparaissent doté de
moyenne dérisoires pour ces raisons nous
demandons l'avis de l'Association
nationale pour l'amélioration des
conditions de travail avant la rédaction
du décret qui fixe les conditions de
financement du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle
alors
sous amendement numéro
5494 madame pensumonge
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
amendement de notre de nos collègues du
groupe communiste République citoyen et
écologique et bienvenu et accueillir
avec satisfaction par le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire qui
si vous nous le permettez puisque c'est
un peu un dialogue entre nous seulement
va être sous-amendée
donc il s'agit vous l'avez dit
mes collègues de prévoir la consultation
de l'Association nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
avant qu'un décret ne précise le
fonctionnement du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévision de l'usure
professionnelle c'est bien mais nous
soutarons souhaitons également nous les
écologistes que les négociations avec
les partenaires sociaux
participent à l'édiction du
fonctionnement du fond
et des modalités aussi d'identification
des métiers et activités exposants au
facteurs pénibles
si le Gouvernement entend faire de la
concertation pour l'instant on n'a pas
bien vu mais si il entend toujours faire
de la concertation le grand principe qui
devra guider la construction de ces
politiques publiques
le droit du travail ne peut entrer dans
cette philosophie
qui déséquilibre le dialogue social
aussi les partenaires sociaux ne sont
pas des instances à seulement consulter
nous l'avons dit précédemment ce sont
les interlocuteurs privilégiés de la
négociation collective
garante du paritarisme et d'une
connexion réelle avec les personnes
concernées et la
protection des droits des travailleurs
et travailleuses
je vous remercie de votre écoute
attentive
alors nous avons de -5494 Monsieur
ferdin
et merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le mini chers collègues donc c'est
initiative de ma collègue Mélanie Vogel
avec un certain nombre de membres de
notre groupe que nous proposons ce sous
amendement donc qui sous-amand de
l'amendement de nos collègues du groupe
communiste
amendement que nous saluons à défaut de
pouvoir le voter tout à l'heure cet
amendement vise à prévoir la
consultation de l'Association nationale
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
travail avant qu'un décret ne précise le
fonctionnement du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention d'usure
professionnelle nous souhaiterions
également que les négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux participent à
l'édiction du fonctionnement du fond et
des modalités d'identification des
métiers et activités exposant aux
facteurs pénibles je crois que en
s'autorisant à définir par décret sans
réel négociation avec les partenaires
sociaux les modalités de fonctionnement
du fond le gouvernement peut facilement
out passer les oppositions à sa lettre
de cadrage ou à son support de
concertation et imposer une réforme qui
ne respecte pas les principes du débat
démocratique et du dialogue social donc
la prise en compte de la voie des
travailleurs et des travailleurs et
pourtant primordial pour garantir qu'une
mesure soit en phase avec le terrain et
protectrice il est donc pertinent de
compléter l'alinéa 3 de l'amendement
3907 par la phrase suivante et après
négociation avec les organisations
syndicales et les organisations
patronales je vous remercie de votre
attention
le 4600
cette séance car je suis avec le
sénateur communiste Pascal savold Deli
bonjour bonjour Pascal ça vole des lits
et bien il y a eu ce matin et bien ce
coup de théâtre mais que tout le monde
attendait un petit peu quand même
peut-être pas aussitôt le recours par le
gouvernement à l'article 44-3 de la
Constitution le vote unique ou le vote
bloqué qui nous amène à la situation à
laquelle nous assistons actuellement
c'est à dire que la gauche présente ses
amendements mais il n'y aura même pas de
vote sur ces amendements qu'est-ce que
vous inspire cette situation qui est à
la fois un coup de force mais un coup de
force prévu
je vous remercie de m'aider parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un coup de force
le Président j'ai utilisé une expression
pas par ces références historiques mais
là on est on est déjà dans les prémices
d'un nouveau régime politique
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
cet article vote unique le déroulait
papier une expression en amendement pas
d'explication de vote pas de défense
un gouvernement qui présente 70 âmes en
manque il a choisi en fonction de
évidemment ça sa réforme après avoir
écrit en duo avec la majorité
sanitoriale l'article 7 vous l'avez vu
dans le cadre de la Nuit mardi à
mercredi
qu'est-ce que je vous dise là on a un
régime politique et à bout de souffle
qui est et qui heurte l'opinion
l'opinion des Français ce matin je
regardais je n'ai pas connu cette
situation vous avez bien 82 % des
Français et les Français sont en colère
51-13 en colère vis-à-vis de la
politique économique et sociale du
gouvernement si ça c'est pas une alerte
parce qu'elle s'envole des lits mais cet
article 44-3 ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il est utilisé il a même été
utilisé en 2010 en 2013 sur chaque
réforme des retraites il avait été
utilisé au Sénat en 2010 au bout de
trois semaines de débat il avait été
utilisé en deuxième lecture en 2013
alors ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas complètement inhabituel quand même
et ce n'est pas un changement de régime
en tout cas c'était déjà inscrit dans
nos institutions ouais mais vous savez
quand on parle de d'origine politique il
faut regarder évidemment ce qui relève
de notre réglementation en termes
d'institutions
une juridique et puis après il y a dans
quel contexte on est vous pouvez pas
isoler un article du règlement d'une
institution d'un contexte social et
démocratique vous avez aujourd'hui une
énorme majorité de Français de Français
qui ne veulent pas travailler jusqu'à 64
ans et avoir autant d'annulités de
travail voilà la question donc on peut
pas la question c'est pas de surfer tout
le temps a rien à l'aspect procédurier
vous voyez ce que je veux dire la
démocratie ça se remplace pas voyez ce
que je veux dire la démocratie c'est
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui aussi émane de
tous ces hommes et ces femmes qui
travaillent actuellement ou ceux qui
sont privés de travail d'ailleurs voilà
qui vous disent on ne veut pas de cette
réforme on ne veut pas de ce projet de
société d'ailleurs quand même on peut
s'interroger comment ça se fait qu'on a
cette réforme
sur les retraites après on a la réforme
sur l'immigration après on a une loi
travail pourquoi d'abord la loi travail
est pas passée avant
il fait les choses à l'envers il fallait
discuter du travail c'est très important
pourquoi on travaille pour qui on
travaille et comment on travaille ça
c'est intéressant fortement les Français
et les Françaises ça vous voyez bien car
une crise de sens c'était ça qu'il
fallait ramener alimenter dans notre
société non là il y a une sorte de
un fond écoutez mon collègue Roger
carochi je l'ai écouté tout à l'heure
dans un rappel au règlement il nous dit
il y a des il y a des idées de réformes
constitutionnelles vous pouvez reprendre
le texte analytique du débat je suis pas
quelqu'un qui polémique avec les
personnes il l'a dit donc il y a de
manière sous-jacente oui une réforme à
venir une réforme des comptes de la
Constitution pour avoir un régime qui
fait que un régime qui aujourd'hui au
stade où on se parle là maintenant pense
que les Français ont tort et que les
oppositions ont tort même quand les
oppositions sont le même sensibilité si
vous avez vu comme moi article 7 115
voix contre donc il y a des
parlementaires ici des scénatrices et
sénateurs qui appartiennent à la
majorité
sénatoriale qui soit se sont abstenus
soit en voté contre l'article 7 c'est à
dire les de plus de travaux vous sentez
que la façon dont cette réforme est
ressentie de façon très impopulaire
commence à gagner la façon dont votre
les parlementaires on voit d'ailleurs
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
actuellement très tangent pour trouver
une majorité et que c'est vraiment à
quelques voix près
que dire si on a aboutit à devoir
également imposer cette réforme par un
49-3 à l'Assemblée mais là enfin moi je
pense qu'on est à la fin d'un cycle
madame je vous le dis je pense pour la
fin d'un cycle et cette fin de cycle moi
je l'ai vécu douloureusement en 2002
quand la gauche a été écartée au
deuxième tour on s'est retrouvé avec
deux candidatures Jacques Chirac et
Jean-Marie Le Pen vous devez donc
repartir on a fait le quinquennat on a
versant le cambriant mettant
législatives après la présidentielle et
en réduisant à de 7 à 5 ans mais là on a
on organisé un vrai désordre politique
et compris des questions très
discutables sur la
représentativité d'un certain nombre
d'élus là vous avez une Assemblée
nationale on a le gouvernement prend la
responsabilité donne une responsabilité
aux députés du rassemblement national et
organise un désordre me dites pas que
c'est pas un désordre voulu pourquoi
l'avoir mis dans une loi de finance une
loi sur les retraites tout ça c'est un
désordre qui est organisé franchement je
vous le dis c'est et je pense que c'est
extrêmement dangereux pour la cohésion
de notre société la cohésion sociale la
cohésion unitaire des Français
monsieur le Président et bien merci
beaucoup
on va tout de suite te rejoindre la
séance c'est la spécialiste Michel
meunier qui s'exprime à présent à
réintroduire les critères de pénibilité
tels qui sont définis à l'origine dans
le conte personnel de pénibilité je ne
reviens pas sur la description on en a
beaucoup parlé nous estimons que les
branches professionnelles doivent
établir des listes de métiers et
d'activités particulièrement exposée au
risque professionnel et nous ne
souhaitons pas simplement en laisser la
faculté à un horizon indéfini mais bien
inscrire ces listes établies dans les
six mois suivant la promulgation de la
loi permettez-moi monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre un aparté parce
qu'en l'état actuel de nos débats ou de
ce qu'il en reste choisissant de la
promulgation de cette loi nous la
souhaitons pas ou à ce moment là nous la
souhaitons repousser cinédier comme l'a
fait Jacques Chirac en 2006 concernant
le Contrat Première Embauche il vous
reviendra monsieur le ministre dans les
prochains jours de trouver une porte de
sortie à ce conflit social massif que la
France assiste en ce moment pour revenir
à l'effectivité de cette de ces critères
de pénibilité par les biais de
convention il nous semblait déterminant
d'appuyer le dialogue social en le
rendant obligatoire et sans délai de
prescription
j'ai un amendement qui est identique
présentée par le groupe communiste un
varias
le président notre amendement oui il
propose de donner un objectif calendaire
aux branches professionnelles pour
établir les listes de métiers
d'activités exposés aux facteurs de
risque professionnels la santé et la
sécurité des travailleurs doivent être
des préoccupations majeures bien sûr
pour toute société les facteurs de
risque professionnels tels que
l'exposition produit chimiques le bruit
les vibrations les postures
contraignantes ou encore le travail en
hauteur peuvent avoir des conséquences
graves sur la santé et la qualité de vie
des travailleurs il est donc crucial que
nous travaillons tous ensemble pour
identifier ces facteurs de risque
professionnels et mettre en place des
mesures préventives efficaces dans ce
contexte les branches professionnelles
bien évidemment un rôle clé à jouer
elles connaissent mieux que quiconque
les risques spécifiques aux différents
métiers et activités de leur secteur
elles sont donc les mieux placés pour
établir des listes de métiers et
d'activités exposées aux facteurs de
risque professionnels et pour proposer
mesures préventives adaptées cependant
bien évidemment il est important que je
travaille soit fait de manière proactive
et transparente c'est pourquoi nous
proposons de donner un objectif
calendaire aux branches professionnelles
pour établir ses listes et pour les
rendre publics cela permettra aux
travailleurs aux employeurs et aux
autorités compétentes de mieux
comprendre les risques liés aux
différents métiers et activités et de
travailler ensemble pour mettre en place
des mesures de prévention efficaces je
vous invite cette amendement
vient donc contribuer à améliorer la
santé la sécurité des travailleurs en
favorisant une meilleure identification
et une meilleure prévention des facteurs
des risques
la ville de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements identiques oui monsieur le
Président effectivement
la liste des métiers et des activités
exposés est établies par les branches
professionnelles et on ne peut on peut
contraindre effectivement les
partenaires sociaux à négocier mais on
peut pas les contraindre à conclure
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous le
souhaitons pas fixer un délai comme ça
contraint de 6 mois donc avis
défavorable pour ces deux amendements
un amendement vous vouliez faire un
rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président de l'article
44 bis en fait je souhaitais comprendre
vous venez d'annoncer la suppression
d'un amendement qui n'avait pas été
annoncé et qui faisait tomber une
trentaine bon je vois bien qu'on est en
train d'accélérer les débats peut-être
pour permettre nous permettre demain de
manifester mais je voulais savoir s'il
était possible dès lors que ce n'est pas
annoncé par les porteurs de l'amendement
d'avoir la liste des amendements qui
vont être supprimés dans la suite de la
discussion ce qui nous permettrait de
savoir lesquels devront être défendues
et lesquels n'auront pas à être défendus
d'autant plus ces amendements d'un temps
pas soumis au vote pour la plupart
d'entre eux ce serait bien qu'on le
sache qu'on puisse anticiper tout le
monde gagnerait du temps oui
pour la clarté de nos débats
l'amendement peut être retiré à tout
moment
alors nous passerons
un amendement et 5 sous amendements
donc j'ai un amendement 2142 qui est
retiré
et donc les sous amendements de fait
puis nous passons à un amendement
2143 il est présenté par monsieur le
rapporteur au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales c'est également un
amendement rédactionnel monsieur le
président
trois amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
le 3815 monsieur Julias merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mais
mes chers collègues sauf mieux informés
il nous semble que les années Léa 32 et
33 sont déjà satisfaits le par l'article
du Code du travail est le
4163-7 je vous en donne une lecture très
rapide le titulaire du compte
professionnel de prévention peut décider
d'affecter en toute ou partie les points
inscrits sur son compte à une ou
plusieurs des trois utilisations
suivantes etc il me semble que la mesure
que vous proposez monsieur le ministre
et soir au-delà de soi superfétatoire
merci monsieur le Président merci le
sous-abondement qui le présente 5300
93 il est Madame Libin et n'est pas
soutenu
l'amendement 2145 est retiré
et les sous amendements qui vont avec le
Son aussi
un amendement
qui porte le numéro 3912
et il est présenté par Monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en effet
nous proposons par cet amendement
d'inscrire dans le texte dans le texte
pardonnez-moi que les conditions départ
pour carrière longue et les conditions
départ anticipées en retraite sur
l'objet d'une négociation préalable avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronales et permettez-moi de citer
la loi de modernisation du dialogue
social dites-loi du président de Larcher
je me permets d'en citer trois lignes
ben oui ben oui quand même
vous voulez que je vous les souffle vous
auriez pu tout projet de réforme
envisagée par le gouvernement qui porte
sur les relations individuelles et
collectives de travail l'emploi et la
formation professionnelle et qui relève
du champ de la négociation nationale et
interprofessionnelle fait l'objet d'une
concertation préalable avec les
organisations syndicales de salariés et
d'employeurs représentative je dis ça
pourquoi
Monsieur le Ministre parce que vous
savez qui est un débat sur les
négociations qui ont
conduit à ce projet loi et les deux
principaux secrétaires généraux de la
CFDT puis de la CGT on dit que le
dialogue social avait été quasiment
inexistant et que seulement il y a
quelques semaines ils avaient eu la
première ministre 5 minutes au téléphone
et nous nous pensons pas sur ces bancs
que c'est un dialogue social
satisfaisant et je vous refais une
demande
l'Inter syndical a demandé à être reçu
par le Président de la République le
président de la République a répondu
c'est le temps du débat parlementaire
bon depuis que vous avez activé le 49-3
je pense qu'on ne peut plus dire que
nous sommes dans le temps du débat
parlementaire donc s'il vous plaît seul
ministre refaite passer le message à
l'Elysée et recevez l'intersyndicale je
vous remercie
sous amendement
5486 madame ponce
avec Martin lévrier sénateur renaissance
des Yvelines sénateurs RDPI c'est le nom
du groupe Renaissance ici au Sénat votre
réaction recours à l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution on est en a entendu la
gauche qui était vent debout qui a
dénoncé un coup de force contre et bien
contre contre contre la démocratie
parlementaire aujourd'hui et vous savez
je suis passé quelques fois votre micro
et j'ai jusqu'à avant-hier j'ai essayé
de ne jamais prononcer le mot
obstruction en me disant peut-être que
peut-être que on va avancer peut-être
que finalement ils ont besoin de plus de
temps peut-être que à travers les
amendements qu'il déposent ces derniers
temps ces retours c'est recours au
Règlement il y a un besoin de d'un petit
peu de temps encore et je ne pensais pas
le mot truc sur je ne voulais pas je
leur laissais je vous les croire encore
à la chance et puis j'ai prononcé le mot
struction hier ou avant-hier en disant
cette fois-ci les choses sont claires il
y a une véritable volonté d'obstruction
elle s'est avérée vraiment
particulièrement hier et aujourd'hui et
ce matin en particulier avec des recours
aigrement aux règlements par temps dans
tous les sens
je voulais dire que vous dire ce matin
la Commission propose place en un
amendement plutôt consensuel qui qui
allait dans le bon sens où chacun prouve
pouvait trouver un une capacité de
négocier et de trouver une solution
commune alors que nous étions sur le
point de trouver une solution et de
voter cet amendement la gauche a jugé
utile de déposer de mémoire une
vingtaine de sous-amendements qui
étaient je ne dirais pas ridicule parce
que je ne l'ai pas apporté jugement sur
ce que d'autres mais qui n'apportait
aucun intérêt aucune plus-value à cet
amendement voilà une fois qu'on voit ce
genre de façon de faire on comprend très
bien que l'objet et ils l'ont dit
plusieurs fois ils ne veulent pas voter
cette loi ils feront tout pour aller
jusqu'à l'obstruction il fallait
malheureusement passer au 49-3 ans
mais du coup vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne chose qui est en train de se
passer la gauche qui présente des
amendements sur lequel il n'y aura même
pas de vote on a entendu Raymond de
penser manger à l'instant qui vient de
parler d'un simulacre de débat car c'est
vrai ça ce n'est pas un débat ignorable
chacun doit prendre sa responsabilité
madame pensait manger qui je pense à le
record de temps de parole
haut la main de cette hémistique depuis
plus d'une semaine devrait s'interroger
sur le tout le temps qu'elle a passé à
parler pour ne pas dire grand-chose
puisque les arguments qu'elle développe
depuis plus d'une semaine pourraient se
résumer à 6 arguments que voire 7 grands
maximum donc s'il vous plaît quand vous
avez si peu de choses à dire pourquoi
prenez-vous autant de temps et la
volonté elle est claire elle est de
bloquer on a parlé hier la gauche à
parler ailleurs d'une vis sans fin
c'était la qu'à chaque fois qu'un aimant
de monstre déposé le déposerait des sous
amendements on a passé je crois depuis
trois jours à être à la limite de la
barre des 1000 amendements encore à
examiner on descendait à 980 on
remontait à 1100 parce qu'il rajoutait
des sous amendements avec cette volonté
claire de ne jamais aboutir ils l'ont
dit hier soir c'est une vie sans fin et
nous continuons ils l'ont redit ce matin
plusieurs fois le président l'archet de
la même a même repris leur mot voilà
donc ils ont une volonté de ne pas aller
au bout mais il ne l'assume pas parce
que j'appelle de l'hypocrisie et
l'hypocrisie en politique c'est ce qu'il
y a de pire et c'est ce qui conduit le
plus rapidement possible aux populistes
et donc aux extrêmes mais aujourd'hui on
sent qu'ils sont nups et que donc les
extrémistes sont déjà très très proches
aussi parlé de mélenchonisation de de la
gauche vous trouvez vraiment c'est quand
même pas la tonalité qu'on ressentielle
c'est une autre façon de faire mais
l'hypocrisie est totale et l'obsession
de ne pas vouloir aboutir de ne pas
vouloir aller au vote c'est de dénier
même le rôle du parlementaire le rôle du
Parlement et quelque part de vouloir
dire le Parlement de sert à rien donnant
la parole à la rue quand on donne la
parole à la rue on sait où on va on le
sait parfaitement on va la révolution
ces gens-là ne veulent pas du Parlement
ils sont entrés dans le Parlement non
pas pour être des parlementaires mais
pour détruire le Parlement de
manifestations sont d'ailleurs prévues
une encore demain une également mercredi
qui doit être le jour de la commission
mixte paritaire est-ce que vous croyez
bien que la façon dont se termine ce
débat avec un 44-3 kill petit frère du
49 3 disait le cousin c'est pas tout à
fait pareil quand même la preuve en est
c'est qu'on continue on continue le
débat on ira au bout des bas et
qu'est-ce que ça peut avoir comme impact
sur les manifestants demain est-ce que
ça peut pas un peu plus attisé et bien
leur colère contre une réforme qui vous
le savez très peu populaire je crois que
c'est un droit aucun impact sur le sur
la population le sol impact que peut ça
peut avoir c'est que ceux qui sont
persuadés que ils rendent service au
peuple en faisant de l'obstruction
arriveront aux résultats exactement à
verser c'est simplement ça les personnes
qui vont manifester et qui ont les
hommes manifestées je les entends je les
écoute et je ne j'ai toujours respecté
le droit de manifester donc je n'ai pas
discuté de ce sujet là je comprends
l'inquiétude des gens je pense qu'on a
pas suffisamment expliqué la demande
d'effort que nous faisions et surtout
les paramètres que nous mettons autour
pour protéger les plus faibles et les
plus fragiles nous avons raté cet
épisode là nous avons mal réussi passé
cette nouvelle réforme très complexe
mais les gens comprendront à terme que
c'était indispensable
inutile et dont on parle de solidarité
ça demande des efforts à certains pour
que les autres puissent s'en sortir
c'est ça la solidarité à la française
c'est ce qui est notre système de
retraite je le redis et je demande aux
Français de bien regarder ce qu'ils font
et de bien comprendre ce qu'est le mot
solidarité donc oui vous avez le droit
manifester oui c'est important mais
n'écoutez pas toujours ce qui vont dans
votre sens parce que souvent ils
voudront un dernier mot sur le fait que
les syndicats ont demandé en vain à être
reçu par Emmanuel Macron le président de
la République
ça donne aussi l'impression que le
dialogue en tout cas tu as le plus
demande les syndicats il n'est pas
installé mais ça voudrait dire si le
président de la République répondait
tout de suite qu'on le que se qu'il
deviendrait Jupiter installé à chaque
fois qu'il y a un problème quelque part
il faut il faudrait en finir au présent
même pas en finir commencer par le
Président de la République aujourd'hui
c'est le rôle du Parlement c'est le
travail du Parlement on l'oublie une
fois de plus on veut oublier le on est
pourtant dans la salle l'essentiel quasi
essentielle du Sénat ou
le Parlement c'est l'élément c'est un
élément essentiel de notre démocratie le
temps parlementaire n'est pas fini il
finit dimanche soir tant que ce temps
n'est pas fini je ne vois pas à quel
titre les syndicats demanderaient
audience à Monsieur Dupont à Monsieur
Durand au président de la République ils
ont la porte ouverte du ministère du
travail ce qui est tout à fait naturel
en cette période là qu'ils en profitent
mais demandez systématiquement d'aller
le plus haut possible avant même de
commencer me paraît mal venu et surtout
mettre au mauvais endroit le bon
curseurs
d'avoir répondu à mes questions rejoint
tout de suite l'hémicyclos s'exprime
actuellement René Paul Savary le
rapporteur de la réforme des retraites
amendement merci
ensuite il y a deux sous amendements
5491 madame ponce
merci monsieur le président
et merci monsieur le rapporteur de ne
pas avoir retiré cette amendement qui me
permet de présenter mon sous amende
ce sous amendement renforce
effectivement les dispositions établies
par le rapporteur concernant le C2P le
C2P est un dispositif extrêmement
important permettant aux employés de
faire valoir un départ en retraite
anticipée un passage en temps partiel ou
la validation d'une formation
à ce propos je veux dire que vous voyez
qu'il y a trois modalités pour faire
valoir les points qu'on a accumulé soit
un départ en retraite anticipée soit un
passage en temps partiel ou la
validation d'une formation dans les
faits dans les faits les gens sont
tellement usés qui ne demandent pas du
tout la formation ce qui demande encore
presque pas Epsilon un passage à temps
partiel à 80%, il demande un départ
anticipé et ce simple choix devrait
quand même nous éclairer sur la qualité
des conditions de travail en France qui
font que voilà il préfère ça et
puisqu'on parle du CDP je voudrais dire
aussi que le C2P est essentiellement
utiliser par les hommes
4/5 des bénéficiaires sont des hommes et
cela revient à ce qui était dit avec
l'amendement de notre collègue Mélanie
Vogel sur le fait que les critères de
pénibilité qui donne droit à des points
dans le C2P sont des critères de
l'industrie de l'industrie
manufacturière où les hommes sont
surprenés par contre aucune étude aucun
travail n'est fait sur les facteurs de
pénibilité des services et comme par
hasard enfin comme par hasard les
services c'est là où les femmes sont sur
représentées et vous avez des pays au
Québec ailleurs qui ont regardé les les
facteurs de pénibilité et quand mis en
regard des métiers il faut conclure de
femmes à Bahamas alors enfin donc voilà
c'est pour que l'employeur ne possède se
poser à la demande je dirais la Suisse à
1492 monsieur ferdenic le présente
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue les écarts entre
les travailleurs entre les travailleurs
effectivement déclarés par les
employeurs et les travailleurs soumis à
des facteurs de pénibilité laisse la
Cour des comptes il faut le dire
dubitatif sur l'usage qui est faite du
dispositif par certains employeurs selon
la Cour je cite son rapport l'ampleur
des écarts au moins en ce qui concerne
certains critères montrent une
appropriation très en deçà des objectifs
du dispositif par les employeurs
concernés malgré l'absence de coûts pour
ces derniers rendant nécessaire la mise
en oeuvre d'actions de sensibilisation
et de contrôle la cours à joute je cite
toujours le dispositif n'a plus aucune
vertu de prévention il n'est pas à la
hauteur des objectifs qui lui étaient
assignés dans un contexte où l'âge de
départ en retraite recule par ailleurs
fermer les guillemets selon les chiffres
de l'assurance vieillesse seul 3300
personnes ont ainsi pu partir plus tôt
grâce au compte professionnel de
prévention c'est de paix incapacité
permanente en 2021 soit 0,5 % des
départs quand par ailleurs plus de
100000 nouveaux retraités continuent
chaque année de liquider leur retraite
au titre de l'invalidité et de
l'inaptitude ce faible taux de départ
est potentiellement imputable en partie
à l'augmentation en parallèle des
ruptures de contrat à l'approche de la
soixantaine laissant ainsi à penser que
certains employeurs préfèrent se séparer
de leurs salariés plutôt que de leur
permettre d'activer leur C2P il est
important de lutter contre ce phénomène
et c'est précisément ce que tente de
faire l'amendement du rapporteur que
nous saluons et que nous sous-amendons
mais il semble important d'ajouter une
protection supplémentaire au
bénéficiaire en empêchant les employeurs
de refuser ou de contourner l'activation
du C2P d'où le rajout de cette phrase
l'employeur ne peut s'opposer à cette
demande cet amendement tente de proposer
une solution en actant que l'employeur
ne peut opposer un refus alors l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
ces deux évavorables parce qu'il ne me
semble pas utile d'ajouter cette
précision à mon amendement
sur le deuxième mais donc de doublement
défavorable monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président de la vie du
Gouvernement est favorable sur
l'amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
et défavorable sur les deux sous
amendements pour les raisons qu'il a
évoqué merci
monsieur Savary un amendement qui porte
le numéro
2146 un moment de coordination au sein
du Code du travail monsieur le président
de favorable un amendement 21 47
monsieur le rapporterait d'actionnel
celui-là
un amendement
4685 qui le présente monsieur benaroche
je me suis fait
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ce projet de
loi vise donc à mettre en place un fond
pour faciliter la reconversion
professionnelle des travailleuses et
travailleurs qui sont particulièrement
exposés au risque du jour professionnel
je me permets de résumer les deux
critiques les plus importantes de mon
groupe à l'encontre de ce dispositif
premièrement ce dispositif est largement
insuffisant pour répondre aux problèmes
de l'usure professionnelle qui se
trouverait encore aggraver si l'âge des
légal de départ était reporté comme le
prévoit la réforme ceci dit il
conviendra rappeler que la procédure
prévue et plus que floue le projet de
loi prévoit que les conditions de sa
mise en œuvre seront définies par décret
serait donc à la discrétion du
gouvernement c'est pourquoi nous avons
déposé des amendements pour concrétiser
la procédure et pour nous assurer
qu'elle soit au plus près des réalités
du terrain dans l'unique objectif de
garantir l'accès des personnes victimes
de l'usure professionnelle à ce
dispositif de reconversion par exemple
nous avions déposé un amendement pour
permettre aux syndicats et aux
organisations patronales de négocier les
conditions de la procédure d'instruction
et de prise en charge administrative et
financière en complément le présent
amendement vise à ce que les conditions
ne soient pas définies par décret
ensuite mais par des crayons conseils
d'État alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur l'amendement
4685 c'est toujours le même type
d'amendement donc défavorable
un amendement
4683 monsieur benaroche merci monsieur
le président
ce projet de loi vise à mettre en place
un Ford investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle de
dotée d'un milliard d'euros sur sur 4
ans tandis que ce fort comprendrait
plusieurs volets un de ses volets
permettrait le coût financement des
projets de reconversion professionnelle
d'une part cette mesure n'est qu'une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan puisqu'il
faudrait faire beaucoup plus pour
réellement tenir code de la pénibilité
du travail on l'a démontré tout à
l'heure il faudrait par exemple remettre
les quatre critères de pénibilité au
travail supprimés en 2019 sous la
pulsion d'Emmanuel Macron cette réforme
d'ailleurs aurait pu être l'occasion de
les réintroduire mais on les cherche en
vain dans le projet de loi monsieur le
ministre
d'autre part ce gouvernement semble
avoir oublié l'existence des syndicats
qu'en est-il des manifestations
qu'en est-il de la rencontre avec
Emmanuel Macron mais au lieu de remettre
en cause cette réforme le gouvernement
semble au mieux vouloir minimiser leur
ampleur et au pire vouloir contester le
bien frotter durant des syndicats le
projet de réforme est maintenu comme si
de rien n'était comme s'il n'y avait
personne qui s'y opposé ni même
d'ailleurs les parlementaires de gauche
ici présents pire le rôle central des
syndicats est oublié tout au long du
texte le dispositif visé par cet
amendement est un des exemples de cet
oubli la réforme confit en effet à des
commissions paritaires et terre
professionnelles l'instruction et la
prise en charge administrative et
financière des projets de reconversion
professionnelle mais prévoit que le
déroulé précis de cette procédure
destruction et de prise en charge soit
définie par décret or
si l'on veut réellement mettre en place
une procédure adaptée aux réalités de
terrain si l'on veut vraiment faciliter
les reconversions professionnelles on ne
peut pas planifier une telle procédure
sans une quelconque consultation du mode
du travail c'est pourquoi cette
amendement de mode à ce que les
syndicats les organisations pas trop
dans le représentatives puissent
négocier cette procédure ce sont eux qui
connaissent au mieux les réalités du
terrain
monsieur le rapporteur quelle est la vie
de la Commission
dans un calme relatif avec la gauche qui
présente de nombreux amendements mais
avec et bien bien sûr derrière soi au
fond du tableau on voit toujours et bien
l'article 44-3 de la Constitution qui
revient en Espa Audrey la normalité
n'est pas tout à fait là à 100%. oui Tam
est tout à l'heure on a assisté à un
moment de flottement que vous n'avez
peut-être pas perçu à l'antenne alors je
vais vous l'expliquer la Commission a
décidé un petit peu par surprise de
retirer l'un de ses amendements ce qui a
donné lieu à la chute d'une trentaine
d'amendements qui lui était relié des
amendements des groupes de gauche
notamment ça a donné lieu à un rappel au
règlement du sénateur écologiste Daniel
Bruyer qui dénonce une manœuvre pour
accélérer encore plus les débats écoutez
vous venez d'annoncer la suppression
d'un amendement qui n'avait pas été
annoncé et qui faisait tomber une
trentaine bon je vois bien qu'on est en
train d'accélérer les débats peut-être
pour permettre nous permettre demain de
manifester mais je voulais savoir s'il
était possible dès lors que ça n'est pas
annoncé par les porteurs de l'amendement
d'avoir la liste des amendements qui
vont être supprimés dans la suite de la
discussion ce qui nous permettrait de
savoir lesquels devront être défendues
et lesquels n'auront pas à être défendus
d'autant plus ces amendements d'un temps
pas soumis au vote pour la plupart
d'entre eux ce serait bien qu'on le
sache qu'on puisse anticiper tout le
monde gagnerait du temps
il a été rejoint par sa collègue
écologiste Raymonde pontsmonge qui a
dénoncé un simulacre de débat petit
point d'étape thème d'après le dérouleur
situé derrière moi il reste encore plus
de 900 amendements examinés merci merci
beaucoup Audrey et oui comme quoi Thomas
dessus bonjour vous êtes également
sénateur écologiste ce que l'on constate
c'est que malgré le recours à l'article
44-3 ça n'avance pas si vite que cela
parce que la gauche présente des
amendements des amendements sur lesquels
il n'y aura aucun vote exactement oui on
voit ce qu'on ce qu'on avait demandé
c'est-à-dire pouvoir présenter un centre
d'amendement après on n'arrive pas à les
débattre donc là ce dont on se rend
compte c'est que la gauche ça va
travailler ce texte jusqu'au bout sur
tous les articles qu'il y aura des
amendements donc nous on n'a pas baissé
pavillon on n'a pas baissé les armes on
continue les défendre on est déçus parce
que pour débattre il faut être deux là
il y a plus personne qui débat avec nous
même la droite la commission retire ses
amendements c'est à dire que même eux
ils partent avec armé bagages avec le
gouvernement il reste plus que la gauche
ils ont déserté l'hémicycle quasiment à
la il reste plus que la gauche les
écologistes dans les mystique continuent
de mener le combat contre ce projet mais
avec des arguments avec des amendements
qu'on défend dont on aurait aimé
débattre mais on n'y arrive pas si
différent de la première phase qu'il y a
eu sur cette réforme de retraite où on a
vu la gauche qui monopolisée la parole
et puis et bien la droite qui refusait
de s'exprimer car elle ne voulait pas
faire perdre du temps finalement
avec l'article 44-3 on arrive presque à
la même chose si ce n'est qu'il n'y aura
pas de vote on a même plus de réponse
sur nos amendements et parfois la droite
reprenait la parole les centresistes
avaient aussi quelques amendements il y
a même des débats parfois à l'intérieur
de la gauche on l'a vu au moment de la
taxe robot lundi ou la gauche n'est pas
unanime sur ce sujet il y a eu des
débats entre nous à gauche là il y a
même plus de débats il y a plus que la
présentation d'un moment la présentation
de notre travail c'est plus de 1000
amendements qui restent qui restaient à
étudier au moment le 44 3 a été dégainé
donc on a encore du boulot nous on est
là on est on est responsable donc on
fait notre travail ici mais
effectivement il y a en face il y a plus
personne vous avez choisi néanmoins par
exemple de ne pas en multiplier les
rappels aux règlements comme ça avait pu
être le cas dans la matinée etc là ce
qu'on veut démontrer aujourd'hui ce
week-end on va démontrer que on ne
faisait pas de l'obstruction ce qu'on ne
faisait pas c'était pas c'est pas des
amendements de solution on les défend il
y a à chaque fois une fois au moins 2
minutes pour les présenter donc on les
défend c'était pas notre truc
en fait ce qu'on veut démontrer aussi
c'est que le véhicule est législatif
choisi par le gouvernement est mauvais
le temps contraint les la semaine de
débat qu'on avait ne suffira ne
suffisait pas c'est ça qu'on veut
démontrer et donc ils ont été obligés
d'activer un certain nombre de
dispositif contraignant qui nous ont
corseté le débat au fur et à mesure et
qui maintenant ont anni les toutes
formes de débat que dites-vous à ce qui
est bien du côté soit de la majorité
présidentielle soit de la majorité
sénatoriale estime qui a une
mélenchonisation aujourd'hui de la
gauche sénatoriale qui estime voilà qui
qui voit une radicalité
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait l'air de
manquer au Sénat il a fait deux mandat
ici peut-être qu'il faut se demander si
c'est pas le Sénat qui a radicalisé
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et que là s'il leur
manque moi ce que je leur dis c'est
qu'il y a des sénatoriales en septembre
si l'on s'ils veulent qu'ils ont qu'à
lui proposer une une place sur leur
liste et puis qui reviennent ici parce
que en fait il est pas chez nous donc
Mélenchon il est pas sur les sièges de
la gauche la gauche est unie ici
écologiste socialiste communiste on est
unis et on n'a pas besoin de figure
tutélaire pour s'opposer à ce projet
vous inspire la façon en train de se
terminer ce débat cet article 44-3 il
faut le préciser ce n'est pas
très étrange sur une réforme des
retraites ça a été utilisé en 2010 ça a
été utilisé en 2013 qu'à chaque fois ces
réformes termine en quelque sorte un
petit peu tronqué quand même
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire non mais
ce qui s'est passé ici c'est surtout
l'accélération de la mobilisation avec
une mobilisation qui s'est massifiée
mardi les grèves qui commencent les
blocages qui commencent il y en a une
autre demain le gouvernement ce sang
minoritaire il avait besoin de
brutaliser le débat pour provoquer la
résignation de la part des gens qui se
mobilisent nous on veut vaincre cette
résignation c'est pour ça qu'on est
toujours là donc moi c'est ça qui ça
m'inspire ça m'inspire que maintenant ça
se fera ça se passera plus au Sénat ici
nous on tiendra nos lignes on sera là
encore tout le weekend et tout ce qui va
se passer maintenant c'est la
négociation faut que le président Macron
reçoit l'interd syndical il faut que les
mobilisations soient massives il faut
que les griffes s'amplifient est-ce que
vous attendez c'est ce que vous dites
aux manifestants de demain et de
mercredi le jour de la commission mixte
paritaire oui il faut pas qu'il baisse
les bras je pense que ici effectivement
le débat n'a pas eu lieu le débat a été
corseté et complètement bloqué donc
maintenant il faut que le débat il se
fasse ailleurs qu'ici beaucoup Thomas
dessus d'avoir répondu à mes questions
en retour à l'hémicycle ou le débat se
poursuit
de 900 amendements à débattre à raison
de 2 minutes par amendement il y en a
trop rouge
fonctionne bien et vous le savez on en a
discuté lors de la loi et sécurité au
travail combien la médecine du travail
est en difficulté et combien il nous
manque et de médecins du travail et
comme il nous manque d'infirmiers
spécialistes de la santé au travail donc
l'amendement de nos collègues
communistes et écologiques qui veulent
remettre en piste la nécessité d'une
usite médicale nous paraît très justifié
le risque de maladie professionnelle n'a
pas diminué bien au contraire et nous
pouvons nous pouvons nous satisfaire de
cet état de fait nous vous devons tout
faire pour limiter les conséquences de
ces facteurs de pénibilité que vous avez
en 2017 supprimer je n'y reviens pas de
façon plus générale je dis la prévention
et la grande oubliée de nos politiques
publiques il nous faut changer de
paradigme non plus être dans le soin le
curatif en permanence mais dans la santé
c'est à dire réunir toutes les
conditions pour vivre en bonne santé
aujourd'hui le budget de la Sécurité
sociale c'est 97% du soin et à peine 3%
pour la prévention
que je dirais même que si on parle de
percrétion primaire celle qui la plus
importante c'est à dire c'est elle qui
favorise le sport la diététique la
qualité de l'air la qualité de l'eau etc
tous ces facteurs exogènes qui sont en
facteur en fait responsable de 90% des
maladies chroniques ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'exposant tous ces
facteurs-là ne sont pas pris en compte
dans le business de la sécurité sociale
donc nous demandons effectivement que la
visite soit régulièrement organisée et
nous le demandons à ce qu'elle soit
portée à tous les 18 mois
merci monsieur le Président
je trouve qu'il est dommage que
fonctionne l'article 44 3 de a
constitution et le règlement intérieur
en sont l'article 46 vis sont on ne
puisse pas débattre de cette question
dans l'hémicycle parce que vraiment sur
la question de la médecine du travail
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important et contrairement à ce que
viennent nous dire le rapporteur qui lui
préconise plutôt la disparition de la
médecine et bien vous pourrez nous
l'expliquer après oui voilà et bien moi
je dis simplement que c'est un élément
essentiel du monde du travail et c'est
également un élément essentiel de dans
le cas de la santé publique la médecine
du travail on le sait elle est gérée par
des organisations paritaires de type
associ et peut-être que c'est ça qui
vous gêne c'est parce que là on y
retrouve bien entendu les représentants
du salarié les syndicats qui qui aussi
participent à cette gestion la médecine
du travail est souvent le seul lieu que
consulte les salariés et très souvent ni
détecte des maladies qui sont éliées à
l'exercice de la profession mais aussi
des maladies
graves cachées voire sournoise et que ça
participe à la détection effectivement
il a la prévention malheureusement
également les employeurs souvent ne
respectent pas les périodicités des
visites médicales qui sont pourtant
obligatoires et par rapport à cela et
bien aujourd'hui la périodicité est à 24
mois moi j'irai beaucoup plus loin que
ce qui a été proposé précédemment je
propose que nous ayons une périodicité à
12 mois parce qu'effectivement c'est
important merci beaucoup le monument
monsieur monsieur le Président
l'amendement du CRCE vise à rétablir une
visite médicale obligatoire dans les
deux mois suivant l'embauche il nous
semble préférable de prévoir la première
visite dès le premier mois suivant
l'embauche afin de s'assurer que le
nouvel embauché peut assumer les tâches
qui lui sont confiées en toute sécurité
et sans exposer sa santé ou risquer un
accident
il s'agit d'amendement concernant au
premier chef la santé des salariés et je
déplore comme mon collègue l'annonce
tout à l'heure de notre rapporteur qui
veut supprimer purement et simplement la
médecine du travail
mes chers collègues nous sommes en train
de présenter des abonnements qui ne
seront ni discutés ni voter c'est bien
dommage concernant la santé de nos
concitoyens et des travailleurs
chacun comprendra ici le caractère
inédit de la situation mais c'est ainsi
nous représentation nationale somme
bridées et contraint à l'expression
minimum et à ne pas pouvoir faire notre
travail de parlementaire et ce de votre
faute monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les collègues de la droite
sénatoriale cependant quand bien même
vous nous empêchez de débattre avec ce
49-3 sénatoriales que vous avez dégainé
comme une dernière arme contre nous les
français ont compris que nous nous
opposons absolument au projet de réforme
que leur prépare le gouvernement avec
l'intime complicité de la droite
sénatoriale
un amendement 5719 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors je
veux dire que notre sous amendement
je considère notre sous amendement comme
un amendement de repli du groupe
communiste et aussi du groupe socialiste
je veux dire aucun de nos trois groupes
n'est mieux 10 ans sur cette question
simplement il y a un effet cliquet si
vous voulez moi j'ai connu la médecine
du travail avec une visite annuelle elle
est passée à tous les deux ans elle est
passée à tous les cinq ans je vois que
tous les 10 ans il irait bien sur ses
bancs et donc effectivement quand on
demande de revenir à la visite annuelle
c'est difficile c'est l'effet cliquet
quoi on a l'impression de demander des
choses extraordinaires alors qu'elles
ont existé moi je l'ai connu vous voyez
donc il y a pas je suis pas très jeune
mais je n'ai pas 100 ans non plus donc
voilà ce que je voudrais dire c'est
tous les tous les ans tous les deux ans
vous voyez actuellement c'est tous les 5
ans maintenant et tous les deux ans il
faut avoir une surveillance médicale
particulière
c'est noté renforcer une surveillance
médicale renforcée alors dans la branche
de l'aide et du soin à domicile ça fait
que les soignants les aides-soignantes
comme elles sont confrontées à des
produits biologiques c'est tous les deux
ans parce qu'elles ont un risque
biologique et les aides à domicile c'est
tous les 5 ans mais excusez-moi au
niveau de assumant des métiers à la
pénibilité avérée je peux vous dire que
les deux métiers ont exactement la même
pénibilité donc il y en a un qui parce
que en plus il est du milieu social et
l'autre du milieu médico-social et
médico-social c'est un peu mieux c'est
plus proche du médecin plus proche du
sanitaire il y en a un qui passe tous
les deux ans quand même à la médecine du
travail et l'autre tous les 5 ans donc
il est temps de ne pas se ne pas se
soumettre à l'effet cliquet et de
redemander ce qu'on a connu il n'y a pas
si longtemps la visite annuelle tous les
ans
un sous amendement 5720 monsieur Ferrier
le Président chers collègues monsieur le
ministre je rebondis sur ce que disait
le sur observation tout à l'heure de
notre collègue Lucien stanzone je crois
qu'il y a effectivement un débat
nécessaire qui pourra pas véritablement
se déployer dans cette mort ne phase
parlementaire sans échange et son vote
parce que le raisonnement au terme
duquel seule une liste limitative
d'emplois spécifiques exposés à un
risque particulier justifierait le
maintien d'un examen obligatoire
d'aptitude ce raisonnement il tient
aucun compte des réalités sociales et
médicales il y a des millions d'employés
qui se trouvent ainsi livrés à des
risques médicaux et psychosociaux que
seule la compétence médicale est à même
de prévenir ces dispositions donc
menaces la santé les travailleuses et
travailleurs de ce pays en même temps
qu'elles exposent
inutilement les employeurs à méconnaître
les risques encourus par leurs employés
je rappelle j'en parlais tout à l'heure
le rapport de la Cour des comptes sur
les politiques de prévention en santé au
travail dans les entreprises
en décembre 2022 et qui critique le
manque d'ambition de la politique
publique en matière de santé au travail
et de prévention des risques
professionnels et l'absence de
contraintes qui pèsent sur les
entreprises hors période covid les
accidents du travail se maintiennent
ainsi à un niveau très élevé ne pas
mettre en œuvre tous les moyens
disponibles pour enrayer ce phénomène
massif et à notre avis simplement
inacceptable donc l'amendement des du
groupe communiste républicains citoyen
écologiste visa remettre en vigueur une
visite médicale imposée à l'embauche et
ensuite à une période d'icité de deux
ans cette périodicité nous paraît trop
importante particulièrement pour les
salariés assumant des métiers à la
pénibilité incontestable ou exposées à
des tâches mauvaises pour leur santé
mais la niveau gel avec la signataires
de son amendement propose que ça soit
une visite médicale tous les ans c'est à
dire tous les 12 mois
merci l'amendement
3910 madame varia
le président le dispositif du suivi
individuel spécifique créé à l'article
40 et défini aux alinéas 41 et 43 n'est
qu'une mec aux consolation pour les
salariés exclus des nouveaux critères du
camp de pénibilité mais plus encore dans
sa rédaction actuelle la linea 40 ne se
réfère qu'aux petits un du Grand tain de
l'article
l4161 1 en faisant le choix de cette
restriction le dispositif de suivi
individualisé spécifique qui n'est déjà
pas la panacée se limite au facteurs de
pénibilité suivant la manutention
manuelle de charge les postures pénibles
définies comme position forcée des
articulations vibrations mécanique par
notre amendement qui vise à simplifier
le texte finalement tous les cas de
pénibilité si tu es au grand thym
seraient couvert c'est-à-dire
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux y compris les poussières et
les fumées des activités exercées en
milieu hyperbère celle exercée à des
températures extrêmes dans le bruit de
nuit on travaille posté et les tâches
mécaniques répétitives nous demandons
donc nous avons proposions cet
amendement pour que tous les
travailleurs soumis à la pénibilité
disposent d'un suivi lors d'une
rencontre d'ailleurs avec les
syndicalistes de mon territoire conduite
il y a seulement quelques semaines je
puis vous assurer que la pénibilité ne
se limite pas de se limite pas aux
risques ergonomiques il est donc
indispensable d'élargir cette prise en
charge
alors un abonnement qui porte du numéro
2000 103 rectifiés monsieur fialer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je me réjouis de pouvoir
m'exprimer et de profiter un peu de
cette liberté qu'on a quand même de
d'enrichir un débat contrairement à ce
que je peux entendre sur certains côtés
donc dans l'esprit de l'amendement de
notre collègue Véronique Guillotin qui a
été présenté par notre président
Jean-Claude Roquier un peu plus tôt il
est proposé de faire bénéficier les
travailleurs non salariés du suivi
individuel de prévention d'usure
professionnelle on sait que les
soignants sont souvent les plus mal
soignés et pourtant leurs conditions de
travail qui se dégradent d'année en
année nécessite qu'on s'intéresse aussi
à leur santé compte tenu du niveau de
pénibilité des missions des
professionnels de santé libéraux il est
indispensable de mieux les intégrer aux
différents dispositifs de prévention de
l'article 9
nous devons aussi penser à
l'attractivité de ces métiers qui
souffrent d'une désaffection en témoigne
les fortes difficultés de recrutement
donc en regain d'intérêt pour leur santé
physique et mentale pourraient permettre
d'améliorer les conditions de travail et
donc de retrouver de l'attractivité
alors il est possible qu'il puisse
participer justement à ces à cette
prévention simplement les tâches
administratives et qu'ils connaissent
pas forcément
ne favorise pas cette existence
merci d'amendement
37,99 qui le présente monsieur volley
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues pour
vous dire vraiment notre contribution
constructive au débat puisque là on
faisait un amendement de repli
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu bizarre de
faire un amendement de repli à un moment
où on a un vote unique et éclat
discussion est floquée mais on y va
quand même vous voyez ça c'est notre
esprit républicain les communistes si ça
peut aussi aider le président de la
République à recevoir les organisations
syndicales qui se lâchent puisque notre
groupe propose d'associer les
organisations syndicales et patronales
vous avez bien entendu syndical et
patronal à la définition d'une durée de
travail minimal ouvrant droit un suivi
individuel spécifique en matière de
santé au travail
je vois que vous avez compris tout à
fait la pertinence et le bien-fondé de
l'amendement merci
alors un abonnement 3137
oui merci monsieur le Président dans
notre groupe c'est la diversité et je ne
trouve donc aucun intérêt à défendre un
amendement dans le sort et je vais vous
faire gagner du temps je le retire
alors pardonnez-moi le 3137
madame poncemonge merci monsieur le
Président alors l'article 9 demande que
les branches professionnelles engagent
des négociations permettant un
recensement des métiers les plus exposés
au facteurs de risque retenus par le
Code du travail depuis les modifications
2017 et que c'est négociations servent
de base ont renforcement de la visite
médicale de mi carrière
cet engagement des négociations nous on
le demandera au plus vite je crois que
c'est un autre amendement ou du moins
lui donner un temps un temps contraint
ces dispositions sont en effet bienvenue
contenu de l'intensification très
importante du travail depuis plus de 30
ans ou la souvent dit mais il faut le
répéter selon la Dares l'exposition à au
moins trois contraintes physiques
concernent 34% des salariés contre 12%
en 1984 et pendant retenir qu'une parmi
toutes ces contraintes parce que là ce
sont des nombres des chiffres on les dit
mais derrière il y a des hommes et des
hommes cassés et des femmes en 2019
71,5 presque 72% des salariés de tous
les secteurs étaient soumis à des
contraintes posturales posturales et
articulaire se maintenir dans l'emploi
en fin de carrière se prépare en amont
c'est pourquoi l'objet de cet amendement
est de systématiser le rendez-vous
professionnel des 45 ans prévu par le
présent projet de loi en créant un
entretien professionnel renforcé devant
avoir lieu entre le 45e et le 47e
anniversaire du salarié mais ce que nous
demandons c'est que la réalisation d'un
bilan de compétences soit de droit
c'est une demande d'ailleurs des
organisations syndicales je sais plus
laquelle du moins d'une des cinq
organisations six organisations
syndicales que nous avons rencontrées
il faut conclure bientôt monsieur j'ai
dit principal monsieur le Président un
bilan de compétence de droit
alors
le quittez pas pour le moment 3368
monsieur Guy
alors c'est amendement
vise à
supprimer l'expression visite médicale
et la remplacer par le terme visite
d'inaptitude la visite médicale
organisée entre le 60e et 61e
anniversaire du salarié dans le cadre du
contrôle médical dire renforcer n'en est
en réalité pas une il s'agit d'un
aiguillage qui permet d'identifier si
les travailleurs et travailleuses ne
sont plus aptes à travailler le cas
échéant cela permettrait le 3 d'une
pension pour inaptitude
selon la Dares à 61 ans aux portes aux
portes de la retraite
seulement 42,3% des seniors sont en
emploi à temps plein un petit dixième
aussi à temps partiel moins d'un sur
deux quand même les proportions
diffèrent selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles mais pour les
ouvriers c'est 28% en emploi à 61 ans
alors c'est 28% en emploi qui auront la
visite la fameuse visite entre 60 et 61e
anniversaire je pense que il ferait
mieux on ferait mieux de la renommée une
visite d'inaptitude
l'adresse chiffe 1,4 millions le nombre
d'individus âgé de 53 à 69 ans qui ne
sont ni en emploi ni en retraite dont
une majorité de femmes plus de 60% sont
des anciens ouvriers et employés 60%
dans cette catégorie
socio-professionnelle et un tiers est en
situation désormais de pauvreté
âgé de 58 ans en moyenne 29% déclare un
mauvais ou très mauvais état de santé
contre 11% de cette tranche d'âge 29%
contre 11% dans ces catégories
socio-professionnelles si les personnes
se retrouvent dans cette situation c'est
que le travail et les conditions de
travail ne cessent de s'intensifier et
qui sont la cause principale de cette
sur-représentation des catégories
socio-professionnelles que j'ai évoqué
voilà donc merci monsieur le Président
alors un amendement 3918
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
nous pensons que cet amendement parce
qu'il crée pas une dépense
supplémentaires il aurait pu être retenu
dans le vote bloqué retenu avait les 70
autres amendements pourquoi parce qu'on
parle de la question on a mis une du
travail et vraiment c'est un sujet
extrêmement sérieux je pense que tout le
monde y attentif surtout les bancs qui
dit médecine du travail dit que c'est
pas du curatif on est bien d'accord
c'est du préventif donc si on le fait à
partir de 61 ans sérieusement je vois
pas beaucoup sur le préventif qu'on va
pouvoir agir pourquoi parce que c'est
les ceux qu'on ait carrières pénibles
usant
qui ont les métiers avec
les heures de nuit et car il arraché
enfin bref c'est bien avant 61 ans qu'il
faut prévenir on peut se mettre au moins
d'accord sur ça donc on s'était dit que
à partir de mi parcours
il faut le décider ensemble 40-45 ans on
propose qu'il y ait une visite tous les
deux ans parce que là on peut en faire
de la prévention et là la médecine du
travail peut agir voilà donc c'est je le
dis alors on n'aura pas le temps d'avoir
le débat comme on le souhaitait peu
importe mais je voudrais vraiment au
minimum monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le ministre nous disent au moins sur
cette question là on pourrait se mettre
d'accord parce que c'est pas une dépense
supplémentaire ça demande peut-être de
renforcer les moyens pour la médecine du
travail je pense bien évidemment
monsieur le rapporteur et il faut et
donc nous sommes d'accord et
bon ben essayons de trouver un compromis
au moins sur cette question là je vous
remercie merci sous amendement
4957 madame meunier
président
si vous acceptez je peux vous présenter
le 49 57 et le 49 58 dans la foulée
puisque il y a une simplement une
contrainte voilà donc les auteurs de cet
amendement donc il vient de que vient
présenter Fabien get très bien nous le
soutenons et donc cette amendement
transforme la visite médicale des 60 et
un an en visite périodique organisée
donc tous les deux ans et que à mi
carrière pour les salariés concernés par
des contraintes et nous interrompons
quelques instants c'est débat aussi
plutôt cette présentation
d'amendement de la gauche et qui est lié
au fait que désormais nous sommes sous
le coup de l'article 44-3 de la
Constitution le vote unique ou mieux
connu sous le nom de vote bloqué je suis
avec la signatrice communiste Cathy à
poursu poli bonjour bonjour Katia
poursoit poli qu'est-ce que vous inspire
cette drôle de séquence quand même après
le feu dans article cet après-midi on a
une espèce de calme qui est revenue dans
dans l'hémicycle avec cette présentation
d'amendements tout ça apparaîtrait
normal si ce n'est qu'il n'y aura pas de
vote et quand c'était d'abord vous le
dites fort bien le 44 3 au Sénat il faut
repréciser ce que c'est le 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale avec comme vous
l'avez dit un vote bloqué mais on a le
cuir dur et on a décidé la gauche et
nous les communistes le rester dans la
cycle parce que nous avons encore des
choses à dire parce qu'il y a encore des
débats importants qu'ils vont arriver
comme cette histoire des 1200 euros
qui finalement ou le gouvernement nous a
donné dans un premier temps des chiffres
est revenu après sur ces chiffres et
revenu encore une fois sur les chiffres
donc nous voulons être là pour
finalement continuer à défendre nos
amendements parce que nous avons des
propositions alternatives et puis il ne
nous a pas comme ça quoi nous irons
jusqu'au bout même si effectivement dès
que nous présentons un amendement
maintenant et bien
les les rapporteurs et le ministre sont
quand même assez muet ne nous répondent
pas pour ne pas perdre de temps et puis
nous n'avons pas le droit de défendre
nos amendements donc il n'y a forcément
plus de débats mais en tous les cas nous
devons aux salariés en le précise sur
deux minutes c'est ça nous avons le
droit de les présenter sur deux minutes
et de faire une intervention sur article
voilà donc nous allons le faire jusqu'au
bout il nous reste plusieurs centaines
d'amendements et nous sommes déterminés
à le faire parce que nous devons ça et
nous devons les campagnes d'explication
parce que finalement cette campagne ce
que nous faisons avec ces amendements
c'est expliquer aussi c'est une campagne
d'explication aussi pour les salariés de
ce pays parce que quand on va parler des
12 euros et bien quand même voilà on va
expliquer les choses on va donner des
arguments et je pense que ça peut
nourrir aussi ce qui se passe dans le
pays vous allez pouvoir parler de ce
sujet des 1200 euros c'est un ça a été
un slogan du gouvernement que l'on a
entendu un très très tôt lorsqu'elle a
été présenté cette réforme des retraites
et puis on a compris que les 1200 euros
ça serait vraiment pas du tout pour tout
le monde et d'ailleurs
désormais la assez bien expliqué même si
c'est assez complexe qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire que et
bien on
fait partie d'un slogan si simple à
cette situation je pense que c'est un
mensonge d'État c'est 1200 euros on nous
a baladé on a essayé de balader les gens
mais au fur et à mesure que nous avons
expliqué les choses
et au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que ça va venir ici au Sénat mais
à l'Assemblée nationale cette question
des 1200 euros même nous ne sommes pas
arrivés à l'article a quand même été
largement débattus et dénoncé par la
gauche donc je pense que les gens se
sont rendus compte que et bien oui
c'était un mensonge et qu'on avait
essayé de les balader c'est pas ils
avaient quand même dit au début 1200
euros c'était tout le monde pour des
carrières pour des carrières complètes
quand même oui et au début c'était tout
le monde après on est dans descendu à
40000 après on est arrivé entre 20000 et
10000 finalement nous n'avons même pas
les véritables chiffres vous ce n'est
pas une maladresse de communication
c'est un mensonge absolument pas c'est
un mensonge oui c'est un mensonge on a
essayé d'appâter finalement les Français
pour leur dire vous allez travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans mais vous aurez des
compensations et on a essayé de se
servir de ces 1200 euros en leur disant
vous voyez finalement vous travaillerez
plus longtemps mais vous aurez 1200
euros et ce n'est pas vrai parce qu'il
faut pour toucher les 1200 euros de
toute façon 64 ans et 43 à nuités et
nous savons très bien que les femmes
notamment vont être victimes et n'auront
pas ces 1200 euros parce qu'elles ont
des carrières hachées est-ce qu'il va y
avoir quand même du mieux dans cette
réforme après ce passage pour par le
Sénat pour vous non il n'y aura pas de
mieux parce que d'abord s'ils ont
utilisé le vote bloqué et bien
finalement c'est parce qu'ils ont
compris qu'ils n'auraient pas et bien la
valse du Sénat parce que nous avions
encore des des amendements à à défendre
même si je ne me fais aucun souci
là-dessus si nous étions allés jusqu'au
bout du texte les républicains ont révé
des deux mains avec le gouvernement mais
forcément nous aurions débattu et puis
comme nous avions encore de nombreux
arguments à débattre et bien ils avaient
peur que nous n'arrivions pas à la fin
du texte
voilà et maintenant et bien ils vont
réunir la CMP et finalement à
quelques-uns et bien ils vont se mettre
d'accord en CMP pour autour de ces 64
ans pour les Français et les Français
c'est quand même un abus un abus
vis-à-vis du Parlement français et
notamment du Sénat qu'est-ce que vous
dites manifestement aujourd'hui écoutez
moi je les encourage à continuer les
manifestants et dès la semaine prochaine
je serai rentrée chez moi dans le
Pas-de-Calais ce que ça fait une
douzaine de jours que je suis là je
serai à leur côté et je les encourage à
poursuivre le combat parce que rien
n'est jamais perdu d'avance on l'a bien
vu avec le CPE le CPE il y a eu un
retour en arrière du gouvernement et là
je demande solennellement quand même au
président de la République
d'atterrir de revenir un peu la réalité
des choses et de rencontrer les
organisations syndicales comme elles le
demandent pour qu'il puisse y avoir une
véritable discussion elle est entendue
merci beaucoup beaucoup
à mes questions tout de suite direction
les missile ou s'exprime le sénateur
René Paul Savary ensemble et on va pas
faire une visite spécifique là 59 entre
59 60 pour les troubles ergonomiques non
la personne elle a peut-être des
troubles ergonomiques mais elle est
peut-être exposée à des agents chimiques
et peut-être qu'elle a travaillé nuit
également et puis là on prend pas en
compte de façon identique la pénibilité
parce qu'on est ça va bien je pense
qu'il faut une vraie réflexion sur la
santé au travail et vous n'avez tous dit
il faut des moyens supplémentaires c'est
pour ça que c'est pas chaque loi qu'il
faut rajouter ça sûrement pas dans un
PLFSS mais plutôt dans une loi travail
monsieur le ministre et nous attendons
des dispositions effectivement dans la
loi travail c'est pour ça que la
Commission on en a discuté chers
confrères c'est pour ça que la
Commission à la commission nous avons
choisi de dire ça va bien faut une
réflexion on entend la loi travail la
consultation des partenaires sociaux
à la fois les salariaux et patronaux
pour définir une meilleure politique de
médecine de santé au travail voilà que
les choses soient claires entre nous
merci donc je confirme la vie des
favorable en attendant une discussion
plus riche lors d'une loi travail lui
les
quel est le sens de ce que nous faisons
d'abord la loi telle qu'elle est
proposée là ne règle pas tout et nous
avons des briques pardon sur lesquels
nous pouvons nous appuyer vous avez en
2021 à l'été 2021 adopté une loi santé
au travail à la suite d'un accord
national interprofessionnel cette loi
santé au travail prévoit une visite
médicale de mi carrière entre 43 et 45
ans je dis 43 à 45 ans parce que là
j'exagacte est renvoyé un dialogue de
branche ce que nous prévoyons avec cette
loi c'est que les médecins du travail
puissent déterminer le rythme de suivi
des salariés exposés aux métiers
eux-mêmes exposés exerçant les métiers
pardon exposés aux trois critères
ergonomiques et que les médecins du
travail puissent déterminer le la
régularité du suivi entre cette première
visite de mi carrière qui commencera
entre 43 et 45 ans et une nouvelle
visite de fin de carrière que nous
créons par le texte à 61 ans pourquoi 61
ans
parce que à 61 ans si un salarié
malheureusement
usé par l'activité qu'il a exercé et que
cette usure l'autorise si je puis dire à
bénéficier d'un départ anticipés il est
encore temps d'une certaine manière de
bénéficier de des parents anticipé alors
qu'une retraite une visite pardon
spontanée à 63 ans 63 ans et demi c'est
pour qu'il s'entende de dire vous auriez
pu partir 2 ans avant c'est trop tard et
donc la loi santé au travail de 2021 à
acté cette première visite entre 43 et
45 ans en fonction de dialogue social
nous voulons acter une visite à 61 ans
et permettre à la médecine du travail au
médecin du travail de décider de la
régularité des visites entre les deux
est-ce que ça signifie que lorsque je
dis ça tout est réglé pour la médecine
du travail non bien évidemment non il y
a un gros travail un gros chantier à
ouvrir pour revaloriser ce métier là il
y a un second chantier qui est ouvert et
qui s'est déjà traduit par un certain
nombre de décret d'application c'est la
mise en oeuvre de la loi santé au
travail de 2021 qui elle-même s'appuie
sur un accord national
interprofessionnel et parmi les décrets
que nous préparons sur lesquels nos de
travail en lien avec le ministère de la
santé il y a par exemple la possibilité
de mettre en oeuvre des et de de nous
appuyer pardon sur des infirmiers des
infirmières en pratique avancées comme
ça se fait dans d'autres secteurs
médicaux de même qu'il y a possibilité
en appui à la médecine du travail
d'avoir un cours à d'autres secteurs
médicaux comme la médecine de ville pour
un certain nombre de visites et donc
nous pouvons avancer cette manière là
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement est très attaché à ce
dispositif de suivi médical pour les
salariés qui exercent un des métiers
défini par la branche ATMP comme étant
exposé aux trois critères ergonomiques
je termine pour donner la vie vous avez
compris monsieur le Président que la vie
du Gouvernement est défavorable sinon
nous l'aurions signalé lorsque j'ai
évoqué l'article 44 alinéa 3 la vie du
gouvernement sur les autres amendements
ou sous amendements est aussi
défavorable pour une raison qui est plus
une raison de méthode qu'une raison de
fond pour certains d'entre eux nous
avons une opposition de fond pour
d'autres le gouvernement aurait pu les
soutenir mais
les sous abondements mais nous avons un
amendement
2150 monsieur le rapporteur merci c'est
un de mon moment rédactionnel monsieur
le président
avis favorable
ensuite nous avons deux amendements
identiques de 24 25
qui le présente monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le Président nous voyons
tout à coup que un désaccord l'un des
premiers entre la droite sénatorial et
le gouvernement et bien ça aurait été
l'occasion d'avoir un vrai débat au sein
de tous les mystiques bien dommage sur
ce projet gouvernement il a refusé
d'écouter les organisations syndicales
le gouvernement a décidé d'utiliser la
procédure d'examen contraint dans le
temps qu'implique l'article 47 1 de la
Constitution le Gouvernement a à de
multiples reprises recours à des décrets
tout cela pour masquer toutes les
incohérences de cette de cette loi ce
projet de loi en raison de l'importance
du décret mentionné ici et des
difficultés de prise en compte des
points de vue des acteurs concernés il
nous semble indispensable que le Conseil
d'État soit associé à l'écriture de ce
de ces décret ainsi par cet amendement
le Conseil d'État serait amené à
préparer avec le gouvernement un avis
qui devrait être cue après une
consultation des organismes dont la vie
est souhaitée enfin je dis sera car
lorsque j'avais écrit la défense de cet
amendement je pensais qu'il serait
débattu et soumis à vote donc je disais
ce rage j'avais confiance en quelque
sorte mais bon revenons quelques
instants sur cette séquence en ce moment
vous nous avez accusé de faire de
l'obstruction mais vous vous faites de
la déconstruction il faut le reconnaître
vous avez une belle stratégie mais elle
est bien peu démocratique vous avez
positionné dès leur avec des amendements
du rapporteur qui sont parsemés ici et
là dans le texte les uns pour être
déplacés les autres pour être supprimés
retirer on voit là que vous avez une
belle anticipation vous nous parlez
d'obstruction mais tout était préparé il
y a du métier ça c'est indéniable
mais au bout qui est gagnant
vous peut-être avec cette stratégie
cette stratégie mais le perdant au bout
du compte c'est le débat démocratique et
ici c'est terminé
on a pensé
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
amendement visait à s'assurer que
l'intention du législateur serait
respectée car sur ce projet après avoir
refusé non pas d'écouter mais d'entendre
et de tenir compte des avis des
organisations syndicales après avoir
décidé d'utiliser la procédure d'examen
contraint dans le temps qu'implique
l'article 47 1 de la Constitution après
l'usage 44.3 de la Constitution et le 42
l'usage du 42 9 de notre règlement
du Sénat bref dans ce contexte il
libéral je le répète le gouvernement a
il fait encore de multiples recours à
des décrets en raison notamment de
l'importance du décret mentionné ici et
des difficultés de prise en compte des
points de vue des acteurs concernés il
semble indispensable aux yeux du groupe
écologiste que cet amendement que le
Conseil d'État soit associé à l'écriture
de ce décret vous me répondrez très
certainement monsieur le ministre ou
monsieur le rapporteur mais pourquoi
nous répondre puisque nous n'avons pas
le droit après de reprendre la parole
sur vos réponses ça si c'est une
légalité si c'est vous avez le droit
c'est légal c'est mais en attendant sur
le plan intellectuel quand même
intellectuelle alors
la vie de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements
identiques oui effectivement là aussi
c'est par rapport au décret
avoir la vie du Conseil d'État nous
apparus forcément nécessaire c'est
toujours le même type d'amendement donc
vous êtes n'est pas je donne un avis
défavorable bien entendu
du gouvernement
défavorable
nous allons examiner un abonnement qui
porte le numéro
4687 monsieur ferdin dit que présente
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'instance ce
gouvernementale France compétences créé
en 2019 permet d'ores et déjà de
financer la formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage ce projet de loi prévoit
d'élargir les possibilités de dotation
versées par France compétences afin que
celle-ci puisse également financer des
projets de transition professionnelle
des salariés exposés à certains risques
aux professionnels qui pourraient alors
se reconvertir pour accéder à un emploi
non exposé aux facteur d'usure
professionnelle alors que l'idée pour
être bonne la mise en oeuvre par contre
risque de s'annoncer compliqué et risque
de ne pas répondre aux besoins des
travailleuses et travailleurs qui sont
exposés tous les jours à des risques
professionnels en cause là encore le
manque de considération du rôle central
des syndicats dans le monde du travail
en effet le projet de loi prévoit que le
financement peut que le financement
pardon peut uniquement être accordé par
France compétences si certaines
conditions sont remplies des conditions
qui seront définies
ultérieurement par décret sans
consultation quelconque des syndicats
donc dans de telles conditions le risque
est grand que les conditions soient trop
restrictives et que les travailleuses et
travailleurs exposés à l'usure
professionnelle ne puisse pas bénéficier
de tels financement par France
compétences par conséquent le risque est
grand qui ne pourront pas bénéficier une
transition professionnelle tout court à
défaut de financement approprié c'est la
raison pour laquelle cet amendement vise
à ce que le décret soit uniquement pris
après des négociations avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
représentatives au niveau national et
interprofessionnel c'est pourquoi il se
propose de compléter l'alinéa 53 par les
mots qui permettront d'assurer ces
négociations
alors l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur effectivement cet
amendement souligne la participation du
flipper au projet de transition
professionnelle
mais nous ne pensons pas que la
négociation doit être faite pour avec
les avec les organisations syndicales
doit être faite au niveau des décrets je
vous le rappelle nous pensons que ces
négociations doivent venir par
anticipation c'est trop tard au niveau
des décrets parce que c'est fort
important compte tenu de ces nouvelles
circonstances qu'elles soient associées
mais vraiment au départ donc avis bien
sûr défavorable du gouvernement
mais ma vie un amendement 21 52
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai compris
qu'il était rédactionnel le gouvernement
il est favorable
et un abonnement
3523 madame poncer mon
bon merci monsieur le Président donc le
projet de transition professionnelle est
un outil précieux pour les salariés
souhaitant se reconvertir
professionnellement ou acquérir de
nouvelles compétences nous avions
souhaité un rapport bien sûr déclaré et
recevable qui allait dans ce sens un
rapport sur la possibilité pour les
assurer de jouir d'un droit anticipé à
un congé sabbatique financé par ses
droits à la retraite d'une durée maximum
d'un an et à usage unique ainsi ce droit
est né sabbatique permettrait une
nouvelle conceptualisation heureuse du
droit au temps libéré de la
subordination nombre de travaux nombre
d'activités plutôt ne sont pas
marchandes mais elles sont porteuses de
sens elles sont dévalorisées dans cette
marchandisation du monde et devrait être
permis par ce droit anticiper à la
retraite pourtant car beaucoup hésitent
à se lancer dans ce projet de peur des
conséquences professionnelles que cela
pourrait engendrer de plus un congé
sabbatique
permettant de mettre son contrat de
travail en suspens allant de six mois à
11 mois est possible mais la
rémunération est aussi suspendue aussi
l'employeur par ailleurs est en droit de
différer le départ voire de le refuser
autant de fois que nécessaire donc le
nouveau droit anticipé que nous
proposons ne proposons absolu ne serait
être contrainte car fonder sur le
salaire socialisé cotisé par l'actif
pris sur ses droits à la retraite et
l'actorait les droits à la retraite
comme un horizon heureux de temps
libérer et d'activité pour soi pour ses
proches la société une possibilité tout
au long de la vie plutôt que
l'achèvement du vide travail et d'usure
dans un sens dans un travail de plus en
plus en crise de sens la bataille pour
du temps libérée de la contrainte de la
subordination et bien celle du progrès
social c'est une nécessité écologique je
vous remercie merci la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
ça m'étonne de Madame pansement j'ai mes
impressions qu'elle s'est trompée
d'amendement puisque il concerne
celui-là un avis du Conseil d'État sur
le décret fiction la durée minimale
d'activité pour bénéficier d'un projet
de transition professionnelle dans le
cadre du fipu donc c'est toujours la
même intention du législateur nous
pensons qu'elle sera respectée donc avis
défavorable
alors la vie du gouvernement défavorable
ensuite je voulais vous signaler que
l'amendement 21 53 de monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission a été retiré
avec lui les quatre sous amendements
mon rappeur règlement est fondé sur
l'article 4 de la Constitution il se
trouve que on vient de me signaler de
l'extérieur du Sénat d'ailleurs un tweet
reprenant les propos de notre collègue
lévrier qui à mon sens pose quelques
problèmes je vous le dis mais attendez
avant qu'on le qualifie laissez-moi le
temps de le lire la volonté même de ne
pas vouloir faire aboutir le texte c'est
daigner le rôle du Parlement jusque là
on peut discuter ces gens là j'imagine
que vous parlez de nous quand vous dites
ces gens là ne veulent pas du Parlement
ils y sont entrés pour le détruire alors
Monsieur lévrier je crois que vos propos
méritent quand même quelques rappels
historiques ou alors que visiblement
votre parole vous a totalement échappé
peut-être auriez-vous voulu dire que
nous étions là pour détruire le
parlementarisme déjà c'était un débat
nous aurions trouvé que c'était faux
mais ce n'était pas la même chose
détruire le Parlement alors dans
l'histoire du 20e siècle il y a quelques
précéd
l'incendie du Reichstag c'est la
destruction du Parlement dans l'histoire
récente du XXIe siècle il y a d'autres
références le Capitole là effectivement
la question était de détruire le
Parlement mais vous pensez sérieusement
cher collègue que nous avons été nous
sommes entrés au Parlement pour le
détruire nous sommes entre Parlement
pour représenter et défendre nos
électeurs pour représenter et défendre
l'intérêt national et la France et la
France c'est son parlement je vous
invite vraiment monsieur dévrier à nous
faire part de vos regrettes ou ses
propos et à nous dire que vous n'avez
pas maîtriser votre parole
[Applaudissements]
je renverrai à mes observations
conférences des présidents
l'amendement
4691 monsieur ferrique
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
miniche chers collègues donc je vais
essayer d'être constructif pour
contribuer à construire le débat
parlementaire il faut tenir compte de
l'impact de plus en plus dévastateur des
changements climatiques sur le monde du
travail en effet les conséquences des
changements climatiques sur les
travailleuses et travailleurs
particulièrement pour certains métiers
professions sont irréfutables et vont
malheureusement encore gagner en ampleur
dans le futur dans un rapport
exhaustif de 2018 lasses l'Agence
nationale de la sécurité sociale a
identifier trois principaux facteurs
augmentant les risques professionnels
premier facteur assez évident les
températures qui vont augmenter
aggravant les risques d'hyperthermie
deuxième facteur l'évolution de
l'environnement biologique et chimique
avec des risques plus fréquents et plus
graves et troisième facteur l'intensité
de certains aléas climatiques parmi ces
aléas climatiques figurent notamment les
canicules phénomènes observés avec une
fréquence et une intensité croissante en
France alors que la Confédération
européenne des syndicats rappelle que la
température optimale au travail se situe
entre 16 et 24 degrés en fonction des
activités les phénomènes de température
extrêmes renforcent la pénibilité du
travail et contribue à l'usure
professionnelle de plus les conséquences
du changement climatique ne sont pas
seulement dangereuses pour les
travailleuses et travailleurs mais
entraînent également des conséquences
néfastes pour l'ensemble de l'activité
économique une étude publiée dans le
journal scientifique zoland set a
démontré qu'à l'échec global
153 milliards d'heures de travail ont
été perdus en 2017 année avec un été
particulièrement chaud cette perte était
de 60% au-dessus du niveau de 2000 la
productivité au travail souffre des
impacts des changements climatiques au
delà des listes de métiers activités
exposés à des facteurs de risque
professionnels prévus dans le projet de
loi cette amendement vise donc à mettre
en place des listes de métiers ou d'ACT
exposé aux conséquences des changements
climatiques j'ai fini alors l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur bah
écoutez nous pensons qu' indirectement
mais même directement nous interrompons
à nouveau à quelques pendant quelques
instants les débats dans l'hémicycle car
je suis avec le sénateur Union centriste
du nord-olivier non bonjour bonjour
votre réaction au recours par le
gouvernement et bien votre unique au
vote bloqué ce matin afin et bien
qui est aboutit à ce que l'on voit cet
après-midi c'est à dire maintenant la
gauche qui présente ses amendements à
raison de deux minutes par amendement
mais il n'y aura aucun vote sur tous ces
amendements
alors les débats tout au long de ces
journées ont été
virils mais correct comme on dit au
rugby et c'est tout à l'honneur du Sénat
l'opposition a voulu faire de
l'obstruction mais la flibusterie
parlementaire ça existe alors j'ai dit
que c'était une obstruction un peu
honteuse parce qu'ils avaient du mal à
l'assumer le président dès le début et
c'est tout un son honneur dans la
transparence il affirmait sa volonté
pour le texte mais plus encore pour la
crédibilité du Sénat je parle du
président Larcher pour la crédibilité du
Sénat de la démocratie représentative
professionnel et même de notre rôle de
parlementaire il a exprimé sa volonté de
d'aboutir à non seulement des débats
organisés mais aussi un vote et une
délibération c'est ça le Parlement et
donc on s'en éloignait la vérité c'est
qu'on y arrivait pas on y arrivait pas
et donc on pouvait pas non plus moi je
suis pour l'expression des minorités des
oppositions c'est ça la démocratie mais
c'est pas non plus eux qui doivent
conduire le bal vous voyez c'est qu'il
soit présent mais conduire le bal non et
voilà et donc il était normal que on
dans le cadre de la Constitution on
utilise des procédures pour arriver
d'ici dimanche soir après plus de 120
heures de débats tout de même et où
d'ailleurs la preuve les oppositions
tiennent plus que leur place et bien on
arrive à un texte abruti situation très
curieuse parce que finalement là encore
on entend quasiment que l'opposition qui
vient présenter d'amendements sur
lesquels on sait déjà qu'il y aura même
pas de vote puisque rappelons le
principe du vote qui va avoir lieu
dimanche il va y avoir le vote sur le
texte et puis enfin sur cette partie où
a été annoncé ce vote unique et bien
seulement sur les 70 amendements que le
gouvernement a retenu alors la procédure
c'est la procédure on va arriver à un
texte et puis chacun va se déterminer en
fonction de ses convictions la
commission elle a fait son travail il y
a des des amendements du des rapporteurs
Elisabeth Doisneau René Paul Savary bon
voilà
on a fait notre travail pour le la
question de la pénibilité pour la
question des seniors la question des
femmes
les questions liées à l'amélioration de
notre système de retraite qui est
quelquefois injuste mais c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui c'était vrai lors de la
réforme Touraine c'était vrai lors des
dernières réformes je pense aussi au
carrières longues bon voilà je dire
aujourd'hui après on peut toujours
enrichir le texte mais il va y avoir
aussi une loi travail il faut que ça
s'équilibre nous on a appelé on en a
entendu la discussion
générale bon bah les choses elles sont
ce qu'elles sont dès la discussion
générale nous on a dit qu'on souhaitait
à la fois une loi travail et à la fois
une conférence sociale sur le sens du
travail sur la rémunération du travail
sur la formation sur le changement de
métier sur la pénibilité parce qu'elle
n'est plus tout à fait la même et elle
évolue sans cesse sur la question des
carrières longues on voit bien que tout
ça au lendemain du covid doit aussi être
remis mais
des petites retraites ça va être
l'occasion de parler de de ce slogan
dont on a beaucoup parlé au début de la
Réforme les 1200 euros pour tous
certains n'ont entendu pour tous les
retraités modestes certains ont bien
entendu pour les retraités avec une
carrière complète est-ce que pour vous
c'est quand même là le lieu du plus gros
cafouillage du gouvernement sur cette
réforme des retraites
je pense que
il y a une obligation de de précision de
la part du ministre de transparence et
de précision car il est vrai que sur
cette question
il faut un éclairage précis et absolu
voilà il faut pas laisser les gens dans
une espérance voilà on peut pas être
dans le flou là sur cette question je
crois que c'est le moment dans ce débat
comme vous venez de le dire de d'être
précis qui est concerné combien de
personnes sont concernées à partir de
quand donc on est concerné quelle
différence entre quelqu'un qui est
qui cotise au SMIC toute sa vie et
quelqu'un qui a une retraite hachée
voilà et quelle différence entre le
minimum retraite
contributif et le minimum retraite on va
tous surtout ça il faut des explications
assez claires du ministre c'est ce qu'on
attend je crois il y a pas que moi qui
attend ça nous c'est encore une chose
mais c'est surtout l'opinion je crois
que
le rôle du Parlement c'est c'est aussi
de permettre au gouvernement de
s'exprimer de contrôler d'ailleurs le
gouvernement et là je pense que c'est
nécessaire et indispensable et bien
merci merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS
Olivier nous d'avoir répondu à mes
questions nous allons rejoindre
l'hémicycle où nous attend Audrey Vita
fidèle au poste
Audrey ou les débats se poursuivent
toujours sur le fond de cet article 44-3
de la Constitution
Etam c'est vrai que l'on peut se
demander pourquoi elle est débats se
poursuivent pourquoi la gauche continue
de sierger alors même qu'elle sait
maintenant qu'elle n'a plus aucune
chance de voir ses amendements adopter
ni même voter mais elle a le droit de
les défendre chaque amendement pendant 2
minutes et ce droit est le prend d'abord
pour montrer qu'elle ne faisait pas de
l'obstruction c'est ce qu'on a entendu
dans l'hémicycle et qu'il y avait du
fond dans les amendements qu'elle avait
déposé mais qui n'ont pas été retenus
par le gouvernement c'est une manière
aussi lors de ses prises de parole de
dénoncer l'attitude du gouvernement et
la manière dont il a mené les débats
avec notamment l'utilisation de cet
article pour le vote bloqué ou vote
unique le 44 3 écoutez quand bien même
vous nous empêchez de débattre avec ce
49-3 sénatorial que vous avez dégainé
comme une dernière arme contre nous les
français ont compris que nous nous
opposons absolument au projet de réforme
que leur prépare le gouvernement avec
l'intime complicité de la droite
sénatoriale au stade provoqué par les
pesticides plusieurs prises de parole
ont servi aussi à fustiger le refus
d'Emmanuel Macron de recevoir les
partenaires sociaux vous le voyez donc
l'actualité qui s'invite dans
l'hémicycle mais si la gauche prolonge
les débats si elle n'a pas tout arrêter
cet après-midi c'est aussi pour que les
débats se prolongent demain grande
journée de manifestations et c'est aussi
une manière pour les sénateurs de
nourrir la manifestation qui aura lieu
demain écoutez que nous faisons avec ces
amendements c'est expliquer aussi c'est
une campagne d'explication aussi pour
les salariés de ce pays parce que quand
on va parler des 1200 euros et bien
quand même voilà on va expliquer les
choses on va donner des arguments et je
pense que ça peut nourrir aussi ce qui
se passe dans le pays
précisons aussi que lors de leur
conférence de presse tout à l'heure les
présidents des groupes de gauche ont
promis de tout faire pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de vote total sur le texte complet
dimanche soir à faire à suivre donc
merci merci
beaucoup Audrey pour toutes ces
explications en juin tout de suite
l'hémicycle pour la suite des débats sur
l'article 9 sur la pénibilité la famille
de ces personnes mais aussi les
riverains de ses activités vous voyez
non nombreuses sont les personnes
affectées par ces difficultés
de des conditions de travail en fait
tout le rapport a été abordé sous
l'angle de la santé qu'il s'agisse des
maladies causées par les pesticides du
cadre juridique de l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché de ces produits de
leur évaluation par les agences de leur
commercialisation et leur utilisation au
quotidien par les professionnels comme
parler
particulier donc dans le cadre de
rejet le 5424
merci monsieur le Président ben écoutez
moi je voulais compléter une très bonne
très bonne amendement de ma collègue
qu'on sait Monge pour le par les
vibrations et choc transmis au système
membra c'est aussi l'occasion de
rappeler que les conditions de travail
et la pmillibilité du travail que le
président Macron voudrait rayer du
vocabulaire sont un des angles morts de
la réforme qui nous est proposée elle
aurait dû être au fondement d'une loi
travail avant toute réforme des
retraites ce que nous n'avons cessé de
rappeler d'ailleurs le présent le
président Macron refuse tellement de
reconnaître la pénibilité du travail
qu'une de ces premières mesures de son
quinquennat était supprimé ces critères
dont les vibrations portant les maladies
provoquées par ces vibrations sont
particulièrement invalidantes en effet
ces maladies et choc transmis au système
membrane sont essentiellement des effets
ostéo-articulaires
transformé par des examens radiologiques
je pense à l'arthrose du coude
comportant des signes radiologiques
d'ostéophysodiose
l'ostéonécrose du semis luminaire
la fameuse maladie de kimbock mais aussi
l'ostéo des roses du scaphoïde carpien
la maladie de colère enfin les troubles
angios neurotiques de la main
prédominant à l'index et aux méduses
pouvant s'accompagner de crampes de la
main et de troupes allongés de la
sensibilité et confirmé par des épreuves
fonctionnelles objectivants le phénomène
de Raynaud enfin les travaux
exposants habituellement aux vibrations
sont transmis principalement par les
machines outils tenues à la main
notamment les machines percutantes
telles que les marteau-piqueurs les
burineurs les bouchardeuses et les
fouloirs
sans oublier les outils tenus à la main
associés à savoir conclure enfin nous
aurons la liste à la prochaine
alors
l'amendement 5425
qui le présente merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues moi je vais poursuivre parce
que mon collègue n'a pas eu le temps de
le faire pour introduire donc les
affections qui sont provoquées donc par
des vibrations et par des chocs ce que
je voudrais peut-être souligner et je
tiens à remercier d'ailleurs toute la
documentation que l'on reçoit en tant
que parlementaire et notamment moi je
fais référence emploi chômage et revenu
du travail et notamment à la page 138 et
139 et qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit page 138
et 139 que selon l'Insee et la DARES 54%
des ouvriers déclare être soumis à au
moins trois contraintes parmi les cinq
que sont restés longtemps debout
restaient longtemps dans une posture
pénible effectuer des déplacements à
pied long et fréquents de voir porter ou
déplacer des larges des des charges
lourdes et puis également subir des
secousses ou des vibrations et comme mon
collègue me le disait c'est vrai quand
on pense au secours c'est au vibrations
on a tout de suite en tête l'image de la
personne qui est avec son
marteau-piqueur en réalité la
mécanisation de la société a fait que
l'utilisation d'outils percutant ou
d'outils vibrant s'est étendu à de
nombreuses professions notamment les
travaux du martelage des travaux de
forges de tôlerie chaudronnerie de
travail du cuir bien évidemment ce que
je le disais les travaux de terrassement
mais aussi l'utilisation de plus en plus
fréquente de pistolets de scellement
l'utilisation de clouteuses de rifteuse
d'objets qui sont tenus à la main pour
le meulage le les tronçonneuses et de
plus en plus ces outils que l'on voit
sur le bord des routes que sont les
débroussailleuses et puis également ça
ne concerne pas uniquement que ceux qui
bricolent le dimanche mais c'est aussi
une profession ce qui utilisent les six
sauteuses et des ponceuses tout ça tout
ça pour dire que l'utilisation est comme
l'a dit notre collègue engendre des
maladies professionnelles il y a eu des
efforts il faut le souligner en ce qui
concerne les équipements de protection
individuelle notamment ce qui concerne
les yeux et les oreilles mais il
néanmoins tout cela génère des angoisses
merci l'amendement 50 5426
que Ferro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ce sous
amendement vise à compléter lui aussi
l'amendement de notre collègue Raymond
de poncemont j'ai faim que soit prise en
compte particulièrement une maladie liée
aux animaux d'élevage qui sont les
bruxelloses professionnels sont conserve
mais chez Harmonie cubain va être une
maladie que vous ne connaissiez pas mais
elles sont concernées les éleveurs les
bergers le personnel des abattoirs les
agriculteurs mais aussi les personnels
des laboratoires vétérinaires et des
laboratoires de diagnostic ces
conséquences sont importantes cette
maladie est encore mal connue et très
mal prévenu ce sous amendement a pour
but de la préciser dans l'amendement de
notre collègue Raymond de penser Monge
que
le suivant
on aimerait bien élargir et bonifier
davantage l'amendement de notre collègue
un l'ouvrant tenez-vous bien au
nématodes au petit verre rond mais oui
on l'ignore un peu trop souvent c'est
ces types de vers les nématodes qui ont
donné lieu à aux charançons du bananier
qui est une hématode et qui donne hélas
le traitement quand vous savez le
chlordé comme on vous avait supprimé 4
facteurs de pénibilité et d'insécurité
que sont l'exposition aux produits
chimiques au pesticides or les nématodes
sont responsables tenez-vous bien de
l'anémie ferriprive c'est pas mal et de
l'anémie
prurigineuse monsieur le Président on
voulait absolument élargir le périmètre
de cette amendement là pour en tenir
compte et les travailleurs agricoles en
sont particulièrement victimes entre ça
également dans les mines et donc on
avait bien raison hélas de le prévoir
comme ça mais comme vous avez privé
devrait débat démocratique bien bon on
l'expose et c'est un peu curieux comme
exercice démocratique d'exploser et de
ne pas voter
le président moi je vais vous parler des
affections causées par les ciment donc
ça c'est un susama en béton les ciment
représente des matériaux qui sont pas
sans risque pour les professionnels du
secteur de la construction des travaux
publics et de l'industrie qui les
manipule afin de fabriquer ou mettre en
œuvre des bétons comme et mortiers bien
que les chiffres soient honnêtes
diminution il s'agit toujours d'une des
principales causes d'eczéma de contact
pour les yeux et la peau les professions
les plus exposées sont celles ayant
appliqué d'une façon manuelle et
matériaux comme les carreleurs les
maçons les chapistes les risques liés
aussi mains peuvent provoquer des
maladies dans certaines se révèlent
invalidantes pour les travailleurs si
l'on ajoute les facteurs
environnementaux froids sueur
manipulation de parpaing lavage avec des
produits agressifs qui donc aggravent
les symptômes les pathologies provoquées
peuvent être reconnues comme maladie
professionnelle au titre du tableau 8
des maladies professionnelles du régime
général de la Sécurité sociale ou au
titre du tableau 14 du régime agricole
de la sécurité sociale en conséquence il
nous paraît important de compléter
l'amendement de nos collègues compte
tenu du nombre important de risques
causés par les cymes cet ajout permettra
d'inscrire la prévention des risques
qu'il y a ces matériaux pouvant conduire
à des syndromes d'épuisement pour
professionnels parmi les actions de
sensibilisation permise par le fond de
prévention vous voyez qu'il s'agit pas
d'un sous-amendement d'obstruction mais
d'un sous-amendement constructif et qui
grandit le Parlement qui est beaucoup
critiqué
ces heures-ci alors
merci monsieur le Président j'avoue
jusqu'à ce qu'on fasse ce travail pointu
et poussé sur les maladies
professionnelles et qui était nécessaire
dans l'examen de ce projet de loi
j'ignorais que les amis étaient
possibles ailleurs que dans les pays
exotiques tropicaux là où il y a des
autres choses je pensais que c'était une
maladie des pays tropicaux et en fait
grâce au travail qu'on a fait au lien
qu'on a avec les organisations
syndicales et avec la les spécialistes
des maladies professionnelles je vais
apprendre quelque chose j'imagine un
certain d'entre vous pas à nos collègues
médecins qui bien entendu le savent déjà
mais les amis sont simplement dans les
eaux chaudes et où y a-t-il des eaux
chaudes
dans la dans les centrales électriques
dans les centrales électriques c'est
comme ça que je reboucle sur toutes les
discussions qu'on a eu précédemment sur
le régime de retraite des personnels des
DF par exemple et donc les personnes DDF
sont particulièrement exposés à toutes
les maladies que provoquent les amis et
comme je suis très généreuse avec vous
et que par ailleurs on vit des moments
difficiles je ne vous en ferai pas la
liste mais sachez qu'elles sont graves
et là je ne plaisante pas du tout je ne
plaisantais pas d'ailleurs à aucun
moment de mon propos elles peuvent être
mortes et donc c'est pour ça que il
serait bon de compléter l'excellente
avant de mon âme penser Monge par ce
sous amendement
alors
l'abonnement 50 le 4 30
merci monsieur le Président c'était un
sous amendement donc de l'amendement 33
14 effectivement je trouvais que ma
collègue avait
déjà bien amendé sauf que il manquait
quelques précisions en particulier c'est
la raison pour laquelle je propose
d'ajouter l'émo suivant donc notamment
sur les affections liées aux travaux en
pression supérieure à la pression
atmosphérique alors je ne vais pas faire
de commentaires sur la pression
atmosphérique de ce débat puisque depuis
l'article
44-3 tout va mieux pour la le Pacte des
droites sénatoriale et du gouvernement
puisqu'il y a plus de débat et oui ce
que le rôle du confrontation c'est une
rencontre entre l'air chaud et l'air
froid c'est l'objet d'un débat en tout
cas ce qu'on remarque c'est que ce n'est
plus le cas
sachez quand même mes chers collègues
que il faut savoir que la pression
supérieure à la pression atmosphérique
peut entraîner une perte de vue de la
vue pardon une insuffisance rénale mais
aussi des problèmes de circulation de
sang dans le cerveau il peut aussi
engendrer aussi une perte d'audition et
des lésions donc c'est vraiment des
dangers donc le but du jeu c'était quand
même de donner des précisions puisque
certains salariés effectuent des travaux
dans des milieux où la pression est
supérieure à la pression atmosphérique
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
voulais apporter ces précisions qui
méritaient à mon avis un débat mais vous
le refusez apparemment
l'amendement 54 31 madame Libin merci
monsieur le Président le glycol et le
glycérol peuvent être à l'origine de
nombreux problèmes de santé causés aux
salariés dès lors qu'il travaille
quotidiennement avec les dérivés nitrées
de ces produits par exemple dans le
cadre de la fabrication et du
conditionnement de la nitroglycérine et
du nitroglicole dans l'industrie des
explosifs l'effet indésirable principal
fréquent et la survenue de céphalées et
d'hypotension artérielle nous souhaitons
compléter cette amendement afin de
renforcer les actions de sensibilisation
et de prévention des pathologies
professionnelles quand on fait le compte
nous passons un nombre d'heures colossal
de notre vie au travail c'est pourquoi
nous sommes conduits à nous intéresser à
ce qui se passe dans notre vie
professionnelle afin de nous protéger et
protéger notre santé cette protection
commence par faire de la prévention pour
réduire les risques liés à cette
activité
professionnel le bénéfice de la
prévention est évident on réduit le
nombre et l'intensité des accidents de
travail et des maladies professionnelles
nous savons bien que ces problèmes de
santé représentent un coût pour les
entreprises et pour le système de
protection sociale la prévention assurée
aujourd'hui représente la promesse
d'économie de demain tel est le sens de
notre sous-amendement à l'amendement de
notre collègue Raymonde pensée mange et
au delà de cette amendement ce que je
voudrais rappeler c'est que nous avons
fait ce travail parce que nous
souhaitions réellement parler des
maladies professionnelles et nous
constatons que même s'il y aura un mieux
par rapport à ce que vous avez enlevé en
2018 c'est-à-dire les maladies dans le
c-3p vous ne les avez pas remises pour
autant dans le compte pénibilité le 54
32 madame meunier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre si j'avais l'esprit détendu
et l'humeur badine j'aurais pu dire que
à ce dialogue de sourd je rajoute les
atteintes auditives provoquées par les
bruits légionnaires et nous interrompons
pour nous dans quelques instants cette
séance car je suis avec le président du
groupe Union centriste au Sénart vers
Marseille également président de l'UDI
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Hervé Marseille un mot déjà sur et bien
le déclenchement de cet article 44-3 de
la Constitution c'est votre unique qu'on
appelle aussi le votre bloqué c'est
ainsi c'est l'expression consacrée qui
aboutit à cette séance un petit peu
surréaliste avec cette présentation
d'amendements de la gauche un
successivement et sur lesquels on sait
déjà qu'il n'y aura même pas de vote
c'est un peu la conséquence des derniers
jours je veux dire nous avons une
opposition
de gauche qui a cherché à bloquer le
débat comme cela a été fait à
l'Assemblée nationale pour empêcher le
vote tout simplement du texte bon la
vocation d'une assemblée parlementaire
c'est là en l'occurrence c'est
d'examiner les textes de les débats de
les enrichir et de voter c'est la
responsabilité du président l'archet
c'est notre responsabilité en tant que
parlementaire et donc nous nous sommes
donné les moyens d'aller au terme de ce
débat ça va être le cas selon vous un
Caron on le voit il y a quand même deux
minutes par un moment ça faisait une
trentaine d'heures de débats on voit
après des amendements qui tombent les
uns après les autres mais vous êtes
confiant sur le fait que désormais on
aura bien un vote dimanche
je fais confiance au débat j'ai
l'impression cet après-midi que les
choses se passent mieux qu'elles ne se
passer ces dernières heures et c'est une
bonne chose et parce que c'est un débat
important et je pense que ce moment
mérite pour tous ceux qui nous écoutent
pour chaque chacun et chacune de nos
concitoyens d'être éclairé et donc de
travailler sereinement comme on le fait
maintenant mais vous avez entendu la
gauche dénoncer un coup de force on
l'entend dans l'hémicycle de temps en
temps dire que c'est un simulacre de
débat et de fait c'est un simulacre de
débat il n'y a pas de réel débat
possible dans ces conditions c'est qu'on
est quand même pas un débat
parlementaire idéal à l'Hervé Marseille
on en est loin d'accord alors on fait
quoi on attend on va au bistrot à côté
en attendant que chacun des sénateurs de
gauche est fini son soliloque son
monologue pour occuper le temps et nous
dire à la dernière minute ben maintenant
c'est fini on est qu'à l'article 13 il y
avait un article et donc on n'a pas voté
donc c'est pas raisonnable s'ils avaient
souhaité qu'on ait un vrai débat il
n'aurait pas fait l'obstruction on a
connu avec beaucoup d'amendements
enfin les traditions classiques de
l'obstruction parlementaire j'ajoute que
le dispositif qui a été utilisé qui a
été actionné il a été par tous les
gouvernements de gauche comme de droite
d'ailleurs c'est fait pour ça c'est fait
pour ça c'est dans la Constitution il y
a rien d'anormal la réforme Touraine a
été adoptée comme ça également monsieur
Valls l'a utilisé de nombreuses reprises
comme le gouvernement de Monsieur Fillon
2013 sur les toutes les dernières
références
je veux dire on utilise le règlement
intérieur il a été adopté à l'unanimité
je le rappelle bon il permet à la gauche
de pouvoir s'exprimer il l'utilise
abondamment et il nous permet aussi avec
d'autres articles de pouvoir contraindre
le débat de le limiter et de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse atteindre la limite
qui nous est un parti par la
Constitution c'est-à-dire le le 12 mars
à minuit la question c'est aussi
l'impact que cela peut avoir sur les
manifestations on va avoir une journée
de manifestation demain encore une
mercredi le jour de la commission mixte
paritaire le fait et bien qu'il y ait ce
débat ce qui va être interprété comme un
débat tronqué Hervé Marseille par les
manifestants
c'est légitime que ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord manifestent ils l'ont déjà fait
à plusieurs reprises dans le calme
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de dignité moi
je salue la façon dont se comporte les
syndicats et je trouve qu'on devrait
d'ailleurs dialoguer beaucoup plus avec
ses syndicats qu'on ne l'a fait par le
passé nous avons un vrai problème depuis
l'élection de Monsieur Macron c'est
cette volonté d'égarter écarter les
corps intermédiaires des quartiers le
dialogue avec les syndicats paritarisme
et c'est un peu malheureusement une
aussi des conséquences de cette
situation aujourd'hui que nous vivons
donc il y a ce que ce que font les
syndicats ceux qui protestent dans la
rue et puis le travail du Parlement et
puis ensuite vraisemblablement le regard
Cora jeté le Conseil constitutionnel
mais on peut pas demander à la rue et au
Conseil constitutionnel de remplacer le
débat parlementaire d'ailleurs c'est un
sujet pour l'avenir on peut pas
constater à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat
que des min bloc systématiquement le
fonctionnement de nos institutions c'est
un vrai sujet préoccupant pour l'avenir
Hervé Marseille cette réforme des
retraites mais on en a entendu dans
votre groupe pour qui ce n'est pas le
cas on a eu par exemple Pierre Antoine
Lévy qui a dit j'entends dans mon
département les personnes qui ne veulent
pas de style donc qui s'est abstenu on
voit leur seul rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales
Jean-Marie vanderenberg lui et bien il
est toujours sur la retraite à 63 ans
comment expliquer et bien toute cette
diversité c'est différence au sein de
votre groupe bah écoutez d'abord mon
groupe est libre je crois que s'il
fallait une preuve supplémentaire en
revanche j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
communistes toutes socialistes ou de
verre qui changeaient d'avis j'espère
pour eux que si c'était le cas ils en
auraient le droit tous les cas moi dans
mon groupe ceux qui ont un avis
divergent l'exprime en toute liberté et
donc les amis que vous avez
signalé ont pu voter en toute liberté
j'ai aussi d'autres amis qui ont voté
dans le groupe
contre cette réforme parce qu'il
trouvait qu'elle n'allait pas assez loin
parce que je vous rappelle quand même
que s'il y a une réforme c'est parce
qu'il y a déficit et donc il faut
abonder financièrement le régime des
retraites on le sait ce défi c'est de
plus en plus fragilisé Olivier du socle
a dit peut-être qu'il manquera à 300
millions d'euros en 2030 c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être attentif j'ai aussi des
collègues et amis qui qui disent moi je
veux pas voter ça parce que ça va pas
assez loin chacun a des raisons de
s'exprimer c'est respectable et
d'ailleurs il le fait en toute liberté
cette majorité
du Sénat qui est quand même favorable à
cette réforme est-ce que ça fait pas un
peu désordre non vous avez cinq groupes
sur 8 qui veulent qu'on aille au terme
du débat après les votes ils sont
individuels chacun en tous les cas dans
mon groupe chacun votre comme il
l'entend et je crois que c'est l'honneur
de notre groupe que de laisser à chacun
la liberté de vote et de réflexion je
vous en parle d'autant que à l'Assemblée
il est en train de se passer la même
chose mais au sein de la majorité
présidentielle on voit que les voies et
bien sont de plus en plus hésitantes et
que désormais on ne sait plus trop s'il
y a une majorité pour voter cette
réforme des retraites alors que penser
et bien de cette évolution que l'on
observe à l'Assemblée avec bien de moins
en moins de voix favorable à la réforme
c'est ennuyeux parce que c'est leur
effort oui et c'est ennuyeux parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de perdre
des voix alors que nous il y a une
majorité très large ici au Sénat sur sur
ce sujet et donc si les uns ou les
autres manifestent des différences c'est
pas essentiel à l'Assemblée c'est
essentiel parce qu'on est à une deux ou
trois voix près donc
il y a du travail pour le ministère là
sur le Parlement et je veux pas me mêler
de ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée puisque
moi je suis au Sénat et notre job c'est
de faire en sorte que de dimanche soir
avant avant minuit le texte soit voté
allez chacun dans sa chambre absolument
merci beaucoup Hervé Marseille d'avoir
répondu à mes questions en juin tout de
suite les missile ou raymond-point
écologiste qui est en train de
s'exprimer
sensibiliser les travailleurs au risque
lié à la pénibilité au travail et
contribuer à l'élaboration de politique
de prévention aussi d'assurer une mise
en oeuvre effective des mesures de
prévention et donc important de
reconnaître le rôle des syndicats dans
la protection de la santé et de la
sécurité des travailleurs et de les
appliquer de les impliquer activement
dans les actions de prévention de la
pénibilité du travail au travail pardon
alors la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur défavorable
la vie du gouvernement
un amendement 3821 madame Cohen le
présente
merci monsieur le Président cela fait
plusieurs articles que nous discutons de
l'impact de cette réforme sur les femmes
et nous souhaitons ici qu'un vrai
travail de réflexion soit mené quant à
la pénibilité particulière est souvent
ignorée des métiers dits féminins je
pense notamment à ceux du soin et du
lien où les femmes sont largement
majoritaires je pense aussi aux
personnel de la propreté qui sont venus
manifester hier devant le Sénat on le
sait partant du postulat évidemment faux
que les qualités naturelles des femmes
leur permettent d'exercer dans ces
métiers ces professions sont souvent
très peu reconnus du fait d'un manque de
qualification la dimension pénibilité
est très largement minorée absente et
pourtant elle existe vraiment dans ses
métiers lorsque les travailleurs et
travailleuses du soin et du lien sont
interrogés elle est ils font état de
contraintes physiques fortes liées au
port notamment des patients
malheureusement ce critère n'est pas
pris en compte pour définir la
pénibilité or on sait très bien que ce
geste répété comme soulevé ou déplacer
des corps de 50 60 70 faut voir 80 voire
même plus abîme celui des soignantes et
des soignants le taux d'accident du
travail dans les services d'aide à la
personne s'élève à 5,2 % quand la
moyenne ailleurs est de 3,8%, surtout le
taux de fréquence est supérieur à 36 %
et le taux de gravité de 64 % monsieur
le ministre dois-je vous rappeler que
l'espérance de vie d'une infirmière est
de 6 ans inférieur à la moyenne des
femmes 20% des infirmières et 30% des
aides soignantes partent à la retraite
en incapacité à cette pénibilité
physique on peut aussi ajouter la charge
émotionnelle ressentie par ses
professionnels face à la souffrance à la
détresse de leur patient ou des
personnes qu'elles accompagnent je crois
qu'on peut tout et tous ici penser aux
aides à domicile qui travaillent auprès
de personnes âgées ou handicapées et qui
sont confrontés à leurs difficultés
quotidiennes une étude de la DARES
reconnaît les risques psychosociaux de
ces métiers les infirmières assistantes
sociales auxiliaires de vie connaissent
aussi les taux les plus importants de
dépression et d'épuisement professionnel
ce n'est pas un hasard je vous remercie
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci d'avoir effectivement
précisé c'est important les difficultés
par ces personnes le font s'adresse aux
hôpitaux aux établissements
médico-sociaux qui sont déjà largement
féminisés et donc nous pensions que la
création de ce fond on va témoigner
justement du processus de revalorisation
et de reconnaissance de ces métiers et
le mérite
demandes de retrait donc défavorable ce
n'était pas le cas pour les mêmes
raisons j'ajoute qu'on a notre chantier
à ouvrir sur les métiers du soin puisque
selon qu'on est aide-soignant ou
infirmier à l'hôpital public dans une
collectivité locale je pense notamment
aux EHPAD ou dans le secteur privé les
conditions d'accès de protection sont
radicalement différentes ce qui n'est
pas justifié mais ça c'est un chantier
sur le métier en général qui relève de
mon collègue 1900
terminé avec l'article 9 mais je vais
donner la parole pour rappel au
règlement monsieur Fabien gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
sur l'article 42 excusez moi et aussi la
sincérité de nos débats
sur le ministre tout à l'heure et depuis
plusieurs jours vous a vous avez dénoncé
le mouvement social et le désordre dans
le pays parfois illustré
il y a eu ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
notre collègues Laurence Rossignol après
les propos donne nos collègues ici il y
a pas de désordre et il y a pas assez
genre là mais ce que nous venons
d'apprendre par voie de presse je pense
qu'il faut le donner à notre hémicycle
et appeler au calme je me permets de le
lire monsieur le Président c'est des
propos tenus par un des conseillers du
président
le seul événement qui pourrait faire
bouger le Président c'est un pays à
l'arrêt c'est à dire une grève générale
reconductible qui produirait un choc
économique
confie l'un de ses proches on en est pas
là constate l'Élysée malgré le blocage
de 5 dépôts de carburant des baisses de
production d'électricité l'arrêt de
terminaux métallier et des perturbations
essentielles sur les trains régionaux le
pays n'est pas l'arrêt le seul scénario
où il lâchera
c'est si Paris est en feu s'il y a un
problème aigu de maintien de l'ordre
estime Gilles Savary je finis cela ne
peut être qu'un scénario extérieur un
mort dans une manifestation ou un
attentat approuve un conseiller à
l'heure où demain le mouvement social
est une irramblée et Pacifique depuis le
début nous nous appelons au calme malgré
le coup de force démocratique nous nous
voulons obtenir le retrait mais dans le
plus grand calme et ces propos là sont
on pense incendiaire dans le moment que
nous sommes de vivre et je pense que
nous pouvons les condamner de façon
unanime je remercie de monsieur le
président
point d'un rappel au règlement je peux
me permettre de vous dire
puis qui doit
s'intéresser à nos débat et pas
commenter les commentaires donc voilà
donc je le rappelle quand même par
rapport à la vision que nous devons
avoir d'un rappel au règlement alors
nous sommes un passé à l'article
additionnel
après l'article 9 des amendements qui
vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune en fait un amendement étroit
sous amendements madame ponce
oui merci monsieur le Président ce
nouveau fonds d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle il
vient s'ajouter à d'autres fonds de
prévention sans qu'une évaluation de
l'utilisation de ces fonds auquel il
s'ajoute ne soit réellement effectuées
les actions de prévention des risques
professionnels souffrent d'une
méconnaissance de la part de nombreux
employeurs il en résulte dans certains
cas d'une situation de défaillance dans
l'organisation générale de la prévention
que certains employeurs quelquefois
jugent optionnel et l'absence de mesure
particulière adaptée aux situations
vécues concrètes réelles par les
salariés le rapport de la Cour des
comptes pour améliorer l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
prévention des risques professionnels
mais en lumière les défauts de l'action
publique dans le champ de la santé au
travail le présent amendement est une
demande de rapport
pour évaluer l'efficacité de ce nouveau
dispositif dans la réduction des risques
professionnels liés à la pénibilité au
travail donc nous demandons que le
gouvernement remettre au Parlement dans
un délai de trois ans puisque c'est une
évaluation quand même à compter de la
promulgation de la présente loi un
rapport sur l'utilisation du fond
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle que nous créons
et qui est mentionné à l'article 1 non
chapitre 1 plutôt de l'article 9 je vous
remercie
merci
nous non le sous amendement suite doit
être présenté madame la rapporteur sous
amendement 57 21
madame Ferré merci monsieur le Président
donc au travers de ce sous amendement
donc nous signifions que nous
partageons complètement la volonté de
notre collègue de demander donc un
rapport sur l'utilisation du nouveau
fond d'investissement dans la prévention
d'usure professionnelle qui est
essentielle en effet l'usure
professionnelle reste encore bien trop
développée aussi nous proposons que ce
rapport soit
prévu et interviennent dans des délais
plus contraints c'est l'objet de ce sous
amendement au lieu de trois ans deux ans
mais je veux dire à ce moment et parce
que je ne me suis pas exprimée sur le
sujet je veux dire que je regrette et je
condamne la décision prise par le
gouvernement ce matin d'activer
l'article 44-3 véritable 49.3 sénatorial
tout cela pour prévoir un vote bloqué
vous avez ainsi décidé de limiter le
débat d'empêcher le débat après les
articles 42
déjà 10 et 42 alinéa 16 qui ont été
activés par la majorité c'est natoriale
vous allez ensemble le gouvernement et
la majorité sénatoriale
empêcher donc ce débat et vous allez
même jusqu'à retirer certains de vos
amendements monsieur le rapporteur pour
nous empêcher de présenter nos
sous-amendements alors celle-ci ce n'est
pas empêché le débat je ne sais pas
comment ça s'appelle depuis le début de
l'après-midi nous présentons nos
amendements nous sous amendements mais
nous n'avons aucune possibilité de
réagir de compléter de soutenir ou de
dire cela nous convient ou pas on est
véritablement là encore une fois dans un
déni de la démocratie un déni du rôle
essentiel du Parlement
sous amendement 57 22 qui le présente
monsieur Tissot merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le rapport
proposé par nos collègues sur
l'utilisation sur l'utilisation d'un
nouveau four d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
est essentielle les fonds de prévention
existant ont manqué d'évaluation dans le
temps et surtout des ajustements qui
auraient été nécessaires pour donner une
réelle impulsion aux actions de
prévention encore trop
inefficace voire inadapté aux situations
des salariés concernés le compte
personnel de prévention de la pénibilité
a déjà été modifié et transformée en
compte de professionnels de prévention
mais le rapport de la Cour des comptes
de décembre 2022 est un nouveau constat
d'échec elle dresse un bilan sévère du
C2P qu'elle juge sans ambition et non
contrôlé la Cour souligne en particulier
une faible approxygiation du dispositif
par les employeurs concernés et
regrettent la disposition la disparition
en 2017 de tous mécanismes d'incitation
financière à la prévention la prévention
de l'usure professionnelle reste encore
bien trop peu développé et pourtant les
salariés que leur domaine une activité à
exposer à des fonctions pénibles
qu'elles soient reconnues en tant que
tel ou non au titre de la pénibilité
peuvent se trouver progressivement
incité à cesser leur activité
professionnelle ou à devoir chercher à
se reconvertir au sein d'entreprise ou
en dehors sans nécessairement que leur
situation relève de l'inaptitude au sens
médical ou de la maladie professionnelle
la réalité des efforts consentis pour
répondre aux enjeux de l'usure
professionnelle et de la pénibilité de
la sinistralité parmi les salariés n'est
toujours pas à la hauteur des enjeux il
convient de mieux veiller à l'adéquation
des mesures mises en place au regard des
actions réellement engagées et des
priorités affichées il faut donc
s'assurer rapidement que la mise en
oeuvre de ce nouveau fond s'accompagne
effectivement une prise de conscience au
sein des entreprises pour engager une
réelle politique de prévention ainsi le
groupe mon groupe le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain propose le
rapport proposé par nos collègues
interviennent dans des délais plus
contraints merci
l'amendement
5722 23
les fonds de prévention existants
manquaient d'évaluation dans le temps et
surtout des ajustements qui auraient été
nécessaires pour donner une réelle
impulsion aux actions de prévention
encore trop inefficaces voire inadaptée
aux situations des salariés concernés
effectivement le rapport de la Cour des
comptes de décembre 2022 prouve que
c'est encore un constat d'échec donc il
faut il faut donc s'assurer rapidement
de sa mise en œuvre et que la mise en
oeuvre s'accompagne d'une prise
conscience au sein des entreprises pour
engager une réelle politique de
prévention aussi le groupe socialiste
prévoit que le rapport proposé par nos
collègues interviennent dans des délais
beaucoup plus contraints mais au-delà de
cette question
j'ai un drôle de sentiment parce que
depuis dès le début de l'après-midi là
j'ai l'impression de soutenir de
défendre des positions et des
propositions qui finalement sont pas
soumises au vote et donc serviront à
rien et pourtant cet article 9 permet
d'évoquer dans la dentelle et dans le
menu les vrais problèmes rencontrés par
l'ensemble des travailleurs et des
travailleurs et des solutions censées y
apporter et apporter des solutions aux
problèmes moi c'est des citoyens c'est
ce que je pensais pouvoir faire en
venant ici dans cette belle institution
et bien je suis servi pour ne pas dire
déçu par le spectacle que je vois depuis
tout à l'heure et le fait de museler de
museler les parlementaires dans leurs
propos c'est la règle je m'y plie mais
je suis vraiment déçu et je constate
depuis 2020 date d'élection que ce pays
que j'aime beaucoup la France belle
République ressemble de plus en plus à
une monarchie présidentielle on a passé
deux ans à être dirigé par un conseil de
défense depuis l'année dernière il n'y a
pas de majorité c'est du 49-3 en
permanence pour faire passer pour les
lois des finances et aujourd'hui
j'apprends qu'il existe en 44 3 pour
museler la parole du Sénat et bien
écoutez cette attitude prouve vraiment
que notre président de la République a
bien un problème avec la représentation
nationale faites attention les amis
c'est très danger très dangereux pour la
République
alors
la vie de la Commission
oui effectivement je pense que le
Parlement a un rôle à jouer on va suivre
de très près il y a un peu les fesses
tous les ans ce que devient quand même
se fond d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
c'est pas nécessaire d'une part de faire
de me semble-t-il un rapport ni de
mettre dans deux ans ou dans 3 ans ou
dans je sais plus combien d'années quoi
d'accord donc la vie défavorable
la ville du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président dans les
amendements pour les amendements au
sujet desquels le gouvernement indiqué
avoir un avis favorable leur de ma
déclaration de ce matin aucune demande
de rapport n'a été retenue nous
considérons de manière assez constante
que les demandes de rapport ont un avis
défavorable du gouvernement puisque nous
considérons aussi que les missions
d'information les commissions d'enquête
les prérogatives du Parlement en matière
de contrôle sont plus adéquates et comme
le souffle madame la Présidente de la
Commission et quel que soit les époques
le niveau de réalisation des rapports
n'est pas toujours au niveau attendu
donc la vie est systématiquement
défavorable
merci nous allons passer
toujours après l'article 9 un amendement
monsieur benaroche
oui monsieur le Président bon
cet amendement que je vais présenter
en fait
s'inscrit dans un certain nombre de
prises de parole on va appeler ça comme
ça que nous avons eu sur la non prise en
côte de la pénibilité par le
gouvernement dans ce texte bon au
préalable quand même je vous laisse
signaler juste une chose je reçois un
tas de messages et de coup de fil depuis
cet après-midi et donc je vais répondre
globalement à tous ces messages et à
tous ces coups de fil de telle façon à
m'éviter de le faire par des centaines
de messages et en fait personne comprend
ce qui se passe donc on m'a dit on
comprend pas vous présenter l'état
d'amendement sur la pénibilité qui nous
intéresse avec des argumentaires
développés personne n'aurait pas surtout
il y a jamais de vote donc j'explique à
tous les gens qui m'ont écrit en fait la
mise en place par le gouvernement
l'application de cet article 44 de la
Constitution et la mise en place du coût
du règlement intérieur du Sénat avec
l'accord de la majorité du Sénat fait en
sorte que nous pouvons présenter nos
amendements mais que bien entendu
personne ici même nos collègues de
droite qui auraient souhaité le faire ni
répondre ne peut dépâtre ne peut
s'exprimer et surtout ne peut voter et
donc d'ailleurs je vraiment je vous
remercie d'être resté dans la séance
parce qu'en fait ça doit être
effectivement excessivement
désagréable pour vous de ne pas pouvoir
participer à ce débat et de ne pas
pouvoir voter vous exprimer d'autant
plus que sur certains points je suis sûr
que nous aurions été tout à fait
d'accord donc merci d'être resté merci à
vous d'avoir continué à être présent je
pense que vous pouvez tous nous
remercier de continuer avec opiniâtreté
à présenter à certains normes d'éléments
qui auraient dû servir au débat et dans
le gouvernement ne tiendra finalement
aucun compte mais malheureusement c'est
un peu à cause de vous aussi puisque
vous l'avez toléré cela est donc dit
maintenant vous concluez et ben je vais
conclure monsieur le Président en disant
que la pénibilité est absolument pas
prise en compte par ce projet de loi et
que nous aurions souhaité pouvoir faire
en sorte que ce cette pénibilité le soi
alors l'avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur défavorable
[Musique]
nous passons
à
un amendement ici sous amendements
le
3237 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
l'avons dit les risques
psychosociaux sont croissants et on
qualifie les plus intenses d'épuisement
professionnel
pourtant on l'a dit
on devrait plus en parler parce que en
l'espace depuis 2016 disons quasiment
doublé ils sont maintenant à plus de 20%
contre 11% 2016 et ils ont dépassé on
l'a dit les troubles
musculo-squelettiques qui désormais à
16% sont donc la deuxième cause en
France selon les chiffres d'une enquête
menée par Opinion Way en 2021 2,5
millions de salariés seraient
actuellement touchés par le syndrome
d'épuisement professionnel on m'a mis
toujours burn out je vous demande moi de
dire épuisement professionnel
et deux salariés sur 10 seraient en
arrêt maladie pour des raisons
psychologiques ayant très à la fatigue
professionnelle
ces chiffres en constante augmente
augmentation sont en concordance avec
l'imposition de plus en plus intense des
nouvelles pratiques de management dans
les entreprises qui usent abusent de
l'engagement psychique
physique on le savait mais psychique
désormais de leur salarié de plus la
perte de solidarité entre les salariés
mais qui est dur à la fragilisation des
collectifs de travail l'externalisation
etc et l'augmentation de la charge de
travail mine la santé mentale de
nombreux travailleurs sous le coup
d'ajonction souvent paradoxal d'après
l'étude Summaire de la DARES l'exigence
au travail et ses effets psychologiques
en termes de stress et d'anxiété sont en
forte augmentation et selon l'Agence
européenne pour la sécurité la santé au
travail le coût du stress au travail est
évalué à 3 milliards de dépenses pour la
France
ces 3 milliards nous n'en parlons pas
assez nous n'en parlons d'ailleurs
guerre
le voyez à force de le dire
voilà notre amendement demande que c'est
la scène c'est qu'on inclut l'épuisement
professionnel dans le tableau qui
énumère les risques psychiques au
travail merci
sous un moment 5703 monsieur Kerrouche
merci monsieur le Président cette c'est
sous amendement vient en renfort de
celui posé par notre collègue qui vient
de s'exprimer premier point la plus
grande et la plus forte des pénibilités
c'est le recul de 62 à 64 ans que vous
avez voté
ça c'est le premier élément le deuxième
c'est que effectivement nous proposons
de compléter l'amendement par un
syndrome d'épuisement professionnel mais
l'ensemble de la litanie des sous
amendements que nous avons porté cet
après-midi prouver simplement une seule
chose c'est que cette loi est loin
d'être complète sur la pénibilité et
qu'il aurait fallu la compléter
troisièmement manifestement nous ne
sommes plus dans une enceinte
parlementaire depuis ce matin cette
hémicycle s'est transformé au mieux en
ateliers macramé groupe de parole
téléphone et je comprends tout à fait
d'ailleurs l'ennui de mes collègues du
groupe LR nous ne servons ici
strictement à rien nous sommes dans un
écran de fumée et j'espère justement que
les Français voient très bien qu'il
n'est absolument pas possible de faire
avancer ce débat
merci
le 5706 c'est pas soutenu
5707 madame Libin merci monsieur le
Président effectivement cette amendement
est très ressemblant à l'amendement
précédent donc je n'insisterai pas
là-dessus simplement sur j'insisterai
sur ce que nous aurions dit si nous
avions pu mener un débat classique avec
vous reculez l'âge de la retraite de 62
à 64 ans c'est pour un grand nombre de
salariés de ce pays ajouter des
problèmes de santé toutes les études le
démontrent pour un grand nombre de
salariés
s'apposera un problème au niveau de leur
intégrité physique et de leur santé et
c'est vrai que lorsque nous parlons de
santé et de métier difficile nous
pensons toujours au métier
manuel il n'y a pas seulement des
métiers manuels et nous savons
aujourd'hui que le travail est organisé
dans les entreprises avec une un certain
nombre d'entreprises avec un besoin une
nécessité une exigence de rentabilité de
performance toujours plus importantes et
que on en arrive aussi à avoir des des
salariés qui ne sont pas forcément sur
des postures physiques pénibles mais qui
ont une telle charge mentale que au bout
d'un moment ils finissent par craquer et
avoir de très nombreux soucis de santé
ou psychiques ou physiques liés aux
psychique nous aurions pu nous aurions
pu parler de tout ça si vous nous avez
si vous nous aviez autorisé à débattre
voilà
non
madame
je poursuivais donc je comprends et
j'entends ce que vous dites mais vous
savez on va on va pouvoir se renvoyer la
balle jusqu'à la fin je vous assure que
les choses auraient pu se passer
différemment merci monsieur le Président
5710 monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
sous amendement
identique et vous me direz à quoi bon le
présenter à nouveau puisqu'il ne pourra
pas y avoir de débat et que la réponse
du de la Commission comme du
gouvernement sera certainement des plus
succinctes mais en même temps il est
important pour nous ici dans cet
enceinte de pouvoir redire tous les
défauts immenses de la réforme qui nous
est présentée dont le but est purement
budgétaire
qui repose sur du sable sur beaucoup de
mensonges et sur aussi beaucoup d'angle
morts et des angles morts en particulier
en matière de santé et oui le recul de
deux ans de l'âge de la retraite sans
mesure réelles sur la prise en compte de
la pénibilité fera exploser le nombre de
Burn Out de situations d'épuisement
professionnel si nous demandons un
rapport avec l'amendement de Madame
poncemonge et non sous amendements si
nous demandons un rapport sur cette
question de l'épuisement professionnel
c'est parce que nous pensons vraiment
que c'est un enjeu essentiel qui n'est
pas prise en compte par cette réforme
qui sera aggravée et même si notre
amendement et nos sous amendements ne
pourront pas être soumis au vote nous
espérons que cet enjeu sera à l'avenir
pris en compte dans l'application de
cette réforme si elle venait à être
adoptée et dans l'attente nous
continuerons aux côtés du mouvement
social à nous battre contre son adoption
le solide
monsieur Carnot
merci monsieur le président
c'est un sous amendement pour ajouter
les mots stress chronique au travail
alors figurez-vous que il y a aussi il y
a pas que les rapports McKinsey il y a
aussi un rapport sur les du cabinet
empreinte humaine publié le 9 mars 2023
ou la santé mentale des salariés
demeurent très dégradé en France 44 %
des Français sont exposés à la détresse
psychologique les femmes les jeunes les
managers sont particulièrement concernés
l'ancienne d'ailleurs souligne également
que cette salariés sur 10 ont peur de ne
pas pouvoir tenir avec le recours de
l'âge de départ à la retraite la même la
même proportion déclare que les
perspectives de travailler plus
longtemps les angoisses et oui et puis
depuis le premier janvier 2022 le
burnout a été intégré par l'OMS bon je
sais que vous aimez pas l'avis du
Conseil d'État vous n'aimez pas aussi le
rapport du de la Cour des comptes
maintenant l'OMS l'OMS dans la nouvelle
classification internationale des
maladies comme un phénomène de lié au
travail au niveau burn out la prévention
ce phénomène qui s'amplifie devient une
nécessité le burn-out doit être
une dernière fois cette séance un
consacrée à la réforme des retraites et
c'est le moment de rejoindre Audrey
Audrey qui se trouve dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat pour revenir sur la tonalité qu'il
y a eu assez étrange toute cette
après-midi dans l'hémicycle avec des
succession de prise de parole de la
gauche oui Tam après le coup de théâtre
de ce matin les débats se sont
poursuivis de manière assez calme même
si le gouvernement a donc dégainé
l'article 44,3 avec un vote final sur
les seuls avec les seuls amendements
qu'il a retenu il y en a 70 en tout la
gauche qui a vu tous ces amendements
tombés à quand même le droit de les
présenter pendant deux minutes un droit
qu'elle prend elle veut prouver qu'il ne
faisait pas de l'obstruction et qu'il y
avait des idées sur le fond des prises
de parole qui aussi de commenter
l'actualité directe je vous propose
d'écouter le sénateur communiste Fabien
gay c'est des propos tenus par un des
conseillers du président
le seul événement qui pourrait faire
bouger le Président c'est un pays à
l'arrêt c'est à dire une grève générale
reconductible qui produirait un choc
économique
confie l'un de ses proches on en est pas
là constate l'Élysée malgré le blocage
de 5 dépôt de carburant des baisses de
production d'électricité l'arrêt de 4
terminaux métallier et des perturbations
essentielles sur les trains régionaux le
pays n'est pas l'arrêt le seul scénario
où il lâchera c'est si Paris est en feu
s'il y a un problème aigu de maintien de
l'ordre estime Gilles Savary nous nous
voulons obtenir le retrait de mais dans
le plus grand calme et ces propos là
sont on pense incendiaire dans le moment
que nous sommes de vivre et je pense que
nous pouvons les condamner de façon
unanime les sénateurs de droite qui
n'ont pas pris la parole cet après-midi
seul les sénateurs de gauche s'alternent
pour défendre donc leurs amendements qui
ne seront pas dans le texte final et
parmi
d'amendements défendus il y en a quand
même un quelques-uns pardon qui
figureront dans le vote final dont un
qui a été présenté par la commission des
affaires sociales et qui permettra de
créer un fond d'investissement pour
lutter contre l'usure professionnelle ce
qui a valu une remarque un peu à serbe
du sénateur écologiste Jacques Ferney
qui écoutait je suis particulièrement
heureux de présenter sous sous
amendements puisque dans cette morne
phase de de vacuité parlementaire
engendré par le 49.3 de la Constitution
et le 49 de notre règlement et bien
c'est un moment précieux puisque ce sous
amendement et oui figure dans la fameuse
lipste des amendements et sous
amendements acceptés par le gouvernement
et donc je suis ravi de vous le
présenter il propose que les fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention
levure professionnelle puisse bénéficier
à d'autres entreprises que celles
identifiées par les CARSAT
la gauche qui a donc décidé de siéger
jusqu'au bout même si elle n'a aucune
chance de voir ses amendements adopter
nous le devons aux Français la gauche
qui a aussi dénoncé à plusieurs reprises
cet après-midi l'attitude de la
commission qu'elle dénonce la commission
qui est en fait retiré certains de ses
amendements ce qui est enchaîné et ce
qui a entraîné la suppression de
dizaines de sous amendements la gauche
qui critique donc cette manœuvre qui
consiste je cite à museler encore plus
les débats parlementaires écoutez vous
allez même jusqu'à retirer certains de
vos amendements monsieur le rapporteur
pour nous empêcher de présenter nos sous
amendements alors ça si ça n'est pas
empêché le débat je ne sais pas comment
ça s'appelle depuis le début de
l'après-midi nous présentons nos
amendements nous sous amendements mais
nous n'avons aucune possibilité de
réagir de compléter de soutenir ou de
dire cela nous convient ou pas on est
véritablement là encore une fois dans un
déni de la démocratie un déni du rôle
essentiel du Parlement
thème a pris un mini coup d'oeil sur le
dérouleur il reste encore 916
amendements à examiner merci merci
beaucoup Audrey de nous faire vivre ce
débat dans l'hémicycle et comme ensemble
des équipes de public c'est là pour vous
faire vivre et bien déjà c'est 80 heures
de débats dans l'hémicycle du Sénat 7 de
plus qu'à l'Assemblée nationale et
demain ça continue à 9h30 vous retrouvez
et bien Quentin Calmet Mathias aez pour
vous faire vivre la suite de la réforme
des retraites Élysée aussi bien sûr
toutes nos décryptages analyses sur
notre site public sénat.fr très bonne
suite des programmes sur la chaîne
parlementaire
[Musique]
les 5 millions de Français qui
s'apprêtent à quitter le front on l'a
conscience très forte d'être des
survivants
comment vont-ils revenir autant de paix
retrouvez leur femme leurs enfants leur
travail
comment la société de l'arrière
va-t-elle réintégrer ces hommes abîmés
par quatre années de guerre comment
l'État va-t-il donner un sens au
sacrifice du million et